[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to the feed a
World Cup and Women's World Cup I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
today as yesterday is Grandmaster Ben
Feingold Ben several players have to win
today they have to Strike Back win on
demand after yesterday's debacle who do
you think is most likely to score that
victory
uh likely man it's yeah usually when you
when you lose the first game you're not
necessarily likely to win game two
unless you have white and you're higher
rated
um so I don't think there's gonna be a
lot of uh striking back today because
most of the people who lost um
you know that they lost so I think
there's gonna be
um some upsets as far as people who drew
in the first round I expect some of the
low rated players to go through because
I don't think a lot of the low rated
players are are necessarily weaker
um
it's funny in past World Cups it seemed
like
if they drew the first game sometimes
they drew the second game quickly it's
like they wanted to play the tie breaks
but that doesn't seem to be happening
here it seems like avoiding the type
race just gives you more time to rest
so I'm expecting a lot of Fighting Chess
and not just one one let's go to the tie
breaks but uh I I'm not gonna predict
that anybody who who lost yesterday is
going to win today because that's that's
that's tough to do especially at this
point in the tournament it's not the
first or second round all right well
I'll go on the limb and say Alexander
goriatric you know she's the high rated
player she has the white pieces not
really you know going out of my way to
pick it over right she is and we saw her
lose that game one after blundering her
night so uh well to remind everybody of
the tournament formats they know what's
going on or in case they've just already
forgotten today 32 players remain in the
world cup and 16 players remain in the
Women's World Cup at this point the
players are paired against each other in
two game matches so if you had the white
pieces yesterday you get the black
pieces today and vice versa the time
Patrol 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
after move 40 you gain 30 minutes in the
clock and since the start of the game
you get 30 seconds added per move so
when you're in time scrambles you can
build back time and that way you are
living on the increment build up a few
minutes and then can go and sit for a
thing but let's also remind people of
what happened in previous round in round
three Anish gear rate five minutes
shocker and Mama Jarvis were eliminated
that means that Magnus Carlson thanks to
Fabiano's elimination is the lone player
above 2800 and of course the young
players they are absolute stars in the
making some of them not just the future
but already the present you have
prognananda you have sundarov amongst
other players like bibisara asaba in the
Women's World Cup so Ben you know that
was the storyline heading into the
fourth round which we are already
halfway through are I guess not quite
halfway we're halfway classically
through and I don't know the storyline
continues to be very interesting with
these young players you know cindarov
abusitarov lost yesterday with the white
pieces against vasif durability
maybe their run is coming to an end
yeah there were and the opposite of the
Young Guns is we had we had four players
in their 50s
um you know not losing around one or two
but then round three was tough we get we
got I mean Pia cramling lost and your
give lost and krasenkov lost and golf
fan lost so that was a tough round for
the 50 year olds but we still have some
Young Guns in and I guess
if either mvl or or Magnus loose today
that that'll be the big story
right and that would be very surprising
if Magnus in particular with the white
pieces actually I should say Maxime is
maybe even less likely to lose use the
white pieces because the white pieces
also yeah against one of the youngsters
you see on screen here probably Nando so
that would be very good that's also why
so if any of them lose that's a huge
upset yeah and we're not expecting that
to happen but anything is possible in
the World Cup what is not possible is us
staying on screen because we got to go
do a quick break that way we're ready
for the start of the round please stay
tuned for the exciting second game of
the fourth round of the World Cup and
the Women's World Cup we'll be right
back foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
clock above the players they have less
than 25 seconds now until the games
begin Jeffrey Zhang at the Forefront of
the camera here and now it's changed uh
that looks like the safe durability
against noribbeck Abdul sitarov some of
these players they need to win on demand
looking nervously around trying to
figure out how to drum up some play with
the black pieces and there's hike Marty
rosian taking on anti-birkich hike win
game one with the white pieces in that
rook and Knight risk rook and Bishop
endings are Ben you see the handshakes
um that looks like Sam
against all those pieces there you go
that looks like Magnus yep Magnus and
Sam both adjusting everything
well maybe it's something that uh I
should do more often so I can win games
there you go
is what Tasha gonna play a night ORF
I guess the answer is yes
you think Magnus will play Bishop B5 or
let him play at night or
or like take on D4 with a queen and then
just not going somewhere random hey you
know sometimes he does those things he
might play C3 but
you well what let's see all right we're
gonna find out after D6 it's the
critical point of the match
come on Magnus play D4 do it you say it
jokingly Ben but these opening decisions
right they are actually very critical to
how these games will develop so man this
is like what he's playing the Sicilian
no he knew that yeah
oh you were right
just by asking the question you were
right whether or not I played Bishop B5
check
and
I did oh God take the jacket off did
we're touching block with the bishop it
was a knight with a knight wow yeah okay
so it's funny because historically I
always felt like blocking with the
bishop was sort of the safest option in
the sense that there weren't as many
tactics in the resulting positions but
the Knight D7 uh move has been
considered more fighting and I guess
white tajik says let's just go with a
principled approach if you take on ever
take on D7 uh from White's perspective
then black gets the bishop pair so as
soon as black plays A6 that's an
important decision that now we'll see
Queen takes before yes I took with the
Knight huh
but I thought in these positions you
take with the queen yeah
I like the way the players look look at
the camera uh between moves come on
Magnus look at us yeah there's nothing
interesting on the board I'm just
showing Queen takes D4 and the point
everybody is that there's no night stop
to C6 because the Knight already
committed itself to D7 so the queen can
nicely centralize itself in the middle
of the board if you're gonna kick the
queen of E5 you hand over this very
important D5 Square to White's pieces so
that's very committal uh but instead
Knight takes D4 and I are shocked and I
wonder for tajik is a bit surprised as
well
yeah he looks like he literally doesn't
care
and he just develops his night out to F6
attack E4 Knight C3 is the obvious reply
defending the pawn on e4 but
he's Castle he did
okay so I'm not gonna pretend to know
the ins and outs of this because it's
already a rare line Ben Knight takes E4
presumably too risky
yeah I think I've actually seen this
position before I don't think you're
supposed to take on e4
it's too dangerous
and the question is why I assume that
rookie one very simple star just to
attack the knight in the center will
encourage that's bad when the end when
the engine likes white when White's a
pawn down but that's a bad sign and it's
going up and up and up and I think that
actually now this is looking a bit more
religious knife at five yeah yeah this
Pawn is pink but Robert G6 attacks
tonight where would it go oh definitely
back to uh G3 yeah yeah you got a
retreat yeah that's good well you say
always Retreat so it's your fault if
people don't find Knight takes D6
Checkmate because they're worth pins the
pawn yeah
so I Blame You
and we are not going to see Knight takes
E4 I imagine too risky
but looking for tajik by the way he's
got his
hand on his head and his well Magnus
knew this position was going to occur
and votachik did not
yeah he was going to play Bishop B5
track and take with the Knight
well it's always uncomfortable
especially when you're playing the
number one rated player in the world uh
when you are studying all of these
different openings and trust me
everybody these play if you're votic
you're studying uh against D4 against E4
against C4 on the first move so there's
so much that you have to work through
just in preparation for the game then
you get to the board and your opponent
plays a rare line so you may have some
preparation in the line but you're like
what is Magnus expecting from me why did
he go for this line are there two
equivalently strong moves and he's
expecting one and not the other so I
should play the one I feel like he's
less prepared in and then of course you
walk into some 15 moves of preparation
and you're in trouble these these and
players are just so well-rounded
yeah the psychological part of the game
in the opening is always uh interesting
to watch
and
Ben you've been a player for a long time
you know Grandmaster very long yeah yeah
what do you you know when you see this
kind of decision by Magnus here right
he's avoiding most of what toxic's
preparation but how do you do balance
the decision to play something that's
offbeat but something that's also strong
because oftentimes if you're playing
something your point doesn't expect your
opponent is expecting the best most
principal variations so that seems like
it's a delicate balance at least I think
it's a lot easier to do it with Wyatt I
think
technically
whether you play the main line or an off
b line you know White's fine right but
if you have black and you're trying to
play something unusual because maybe you
need to win that's that's tougher
something sound and unusual because if
it was sound it wouldn't be unusual
that sound I'll play that so that that's
the tough part of Chess I think when
Magnus is white he likes to get out of
theory but it's just out of the mainline
theory he still knows it so he's finding
these lines with white that are sort of
pet lines and I mean I think a lot of
people do that but unfortunately for for
Club players 90 of them think that by
playing the London they're doing that
but everybody plays the London it's not
it's not offbeat anymore so they go back
at a time machine and go back to the 80s
and play the London now they're all set
very true and well said Ben and let's
head on over to another game because I
see the game between pankratov and bakra
that was an absolute a wild game one so
let's check out their game too because I
just caught up the corner of my eye
there's no G Pawn Black's King is in the
center I may remain in the center and
pankrata needs a win with the white
pieces this seems like a pretty ideal
position not that he's better right now
or winning at the moment but in order to
play for a win you need a position that
is as unbalanced as this one
yeah and Bob Crow is just taking the
attack of I'm gonna play my game I'm not
gonna play for a draw because as you
know Robert playing for a draw is
playing for a loss
so he's just playing his usual stuff and
it's sharp but that's the way he likes
it so here we have a real night ORF oh
Knight C6 that's what I play now we're
in trouble
if I play it I don't play that move
order but I've had this position a lot
yeah I mean these positions in general
right after the bishop comes to G5 the
white king is clearly castling Queen
side because the dark spot Bishop got
out of the way whereas the light Square
Bishop is still at home and after A6
that's important to take away the B5
square and allow black to play B5 in
many variations we saw Bishop D7 and
Bishop E7 so Ben it's funny because when
I first started dealing with these
classical Sicilians it seems like black
is playing extremely passively not a
single piece past the third rank whereas
white has all of these pieces the Knight
the pawns the bishop on G5 it seems like
you've given white a free hand and yet
these positions are known to be quite
sturdy for black
yeah and I I haven't played I I might
have had this position once A6 Bishop D7
isn't uh what I normally do
um probably I lost to Danny in in Vegas
in this line don't admit that he likes
to have white in these open Sicilians
and play like a maniac
that was a bad idea by me
um
yeah this is if you're white it's it's
hard to know exactly what setup black is
going to take
um so A6 Bishop D7 is one line
um I've played A6 and H6 I played Bishop
E7 without A6
um you know I try to change it up a
little bit and
I mean they played very quickly and got
to a known line
um
I guess until somebody stops and then
there's the end of their preparation it
looks like uh Black Crow has stopped
first yeah I'm looking at the Explorer
and I I'm very familiar with this
position but I was looking at the number
of games and hundreds and hundreds of
games in this exact variation the Knight
came back to F3 so that when you take on
F6 this Pawn on D6 is in trouble so and
you can also play E5 as in the game so
E5 played your support of the square B4
as a response we had this exact
situation yesterday in one of the games
where you think oh I take your knight
you take my knight I take your Bishop
you take my queen and then I take your
queen I win that because I win two
pieces and a queen you only win a queen
a night but of course when this queen is
captured on D2 it's checked so this is a
key moment to work on your visualization
ef6 takes C3 Queen takes G takes F6 the
bishop wasn't actually under attack
because the Rook on the in the corner is
hanging so the pawn is pinned but Bishop
H4 just getting out of Harm's Way is
generally speaking useful and after
rookies King B1 always play King B1 said
Ben Feingold and what do you make of
this it's a messy position the black
king where is it going to go is going to
stay on E8 maybe at some point go to f8
what's Black's plan with this sort of
awkward Pawn on A6 it could be hanging
in some moment so what do you make of
all the complications here
you know most um
GMS and super GMS don't like playing the
classical with black that's why they
they play the night or if they like that
better
um so I think you know when when strong
players like this are playing they they
tend to prefer to have white and there's
a player
I'm trying to remember what his name is
from from South America he plays in the
US a lot maybe he even lives in St Louis
now
um he's played in St Louis before in the
round Robins he played in the World open
he's always having and he played in
Chicago
um he's always playing these positions
with black and I've seen him get totally
crushed and I've seen him totally Crush
people but I don't see a lot of draws
because uh it's such a it's such an
interesting position
um you know if I have black I actually
like these positions more than when it's
than when white doesn't do anything like
not E5 and take on F6 but just sort of
chills you know plays like Queen E1
Bishop D3 King B1 and then seems like
it's passive for black this seems like
with all those Pawns in the center
um black has really good control of the
center it's double edged which most
people would think is weird for a guy
who needs to draw to play with black but
you got to play your game you got to get
positions you like and pitches you
understand and if if it's okay it's okay
um so I think I think both players are
happy I think they both got the position
they wanted it's very hard to play and
right as as I was talking black played
Rick ba after you were explaining the A6
Pawn could get weak so there you go yeah
it's a big question actually can white
just snag that pawn and this will show
how deep pancrata's preparation is I'm
looking at that pawn I see it's hanging
but I also understand fewer pawns mean
more open files for Rooks and queens so
if I take on A6 maybe I'll be in trouble
down the a file but Ben I think one
thing that's really troubling me about
Black's position is this Rook on G8 and
King on E8 because if you really are
going to launch an attack you probably
need all the Firepower in Your Arsenal
and this Rook on Jake doesn't really
seem like it's coming over to the queen
side anytime soon and I'm not the
biggest believer in Black's attacking
chance I'm also not the biggest believer
in taking this Pawn A6 for the record if
you take out A6 and black takes on G2
that seems dangerous opening the G file
for Wyatt right that seems scary to me
so I think it just is upon sacrifice but
it's not clear if white wants that pawn
and just to finish off this line for a
second if Rook G6 Bishop D3 looks very
strong because you still can't play F5
and your Rook is under attack F5 allows
the queen to jump to h8 with check and
only one way to stop yeah and you lose
your queen here on d8 that would be a
mess
so I feel like I should have made a
Tobey Maguire joke when you said Pawn
sacrifice but the moment has passed
laughs
uh I I wonder though so if you don't
take on A6 or actually even if you do
take on A6 what's Black's plan maybe
night before looks pretty interesting to
me trying to play D5
there's play here but is it worth a full
Pawn that's the essential question
no I think um if I had white in a must
win game
I would be very happy with the outcome
on the opening
oh this looks like good chances to win
already I mean good chances that
somebody's gonna win and I take white in
this position and that's why I always
have black
and how that happens like yeah I like
white yeah but I'd have black man and
and you know let's change my repertoire
or something well we've received
questions asking for example have you
know we played in the World Cup and I
actually have played in one World Cup
where I played against Alexander motilev
when he was 2700 and I was around 2570
so first round matchup where I was the
much lower rated player and I drew the
first game with white and then I had
black in the second game and I had some
options to keep a tame I decided to you
know play some uh lines that got me into
trouble and I did in fact lose that game
so the psychology out of the opening is
very important yes but Crow has the big
Edge in this match considering he won
the first game but here with the black
pieces you said it's his comfort zone
even though for most this may not be the
most comfortable looking position with
Messy pawns a king in the center and the
King on B1 looking actually nice they
tucked away for the moment it's the type
of game we can tell that about Crow
likes especially based on game one in
this match and Ben so many games going
on I was just going to take us over to a
game that looks completely different
from this one the game between Dubai
is very lucky to be tied in this match
and not down in game and now with the
white pieces he's doing the solid
approach this isn't the Vintage dubov
where pawns are being sacrificed and
attacks are flourishing this is really
as solid as it gets
man with that Bishop on E6 I just think
of Fabi he's always playing that Bishop
E6 and Knight dvd7 and Queen's Gambit
wines it sounds like you don't like the
bishop E6 here no no I just no I mean I
I haven't seen that a lot before it was
played recently like 20 30 40 years ago
I never saw that now I see like almost
every game
yeah I mean this is really solid for
black
and as you said Dubois normally likes to
mix it up
but um this seems like he's playing like
me it's as boring as can be so I like
that I like when it's boring I know the
do-bomb like that maybe it's a stylistic
choice because of his opponent because
if yessa panko also likes more open
positions the way to open the position
for black is to play C5 but as soon as
you play C5 you're likely going to be
left with an isolated Pawn so for
example if you play C5 right now and the
pawn takes on C5 Knight takes C5 I have
always disliked these positions from
Black's perspective some players really
enjoy playing with the isolated Pawn I
absolutely hate it I feel miserable in
these types of positions uh where you
can put the Knight on D4 always blockade
an isolated Pawn so it can't push and
then later you're gonna try to pile up
some pressure on it and it the bad thing
when I say Pawn can't be defended by a
pawn which is a Pawn's best friend the
good thing is the open files in the
adjacent lines but here I'm just very
happy from White's point of view yeah I
mean black doesn't have a dark squared
Bishop then I wouldn't mind some much
but with that white square Bishop I
don't I don't want to have an isolated
Pawn I want to have a dark Square Bishop
maybe you can move it over now they
won't I just moved to C7 there you go
that works
perfect yeah
yeah you think like I do
I bet I you know we're talking about how
dubov and he is such an exciting player
always coming up with fresh ideas in the
opening do you think that is it he's
playing a kid who's a very strong he has
to make a beat Magnus Carlson in Viking
Zay at the beginning of 2021 so maybe
it's just matching his opening to his
opponent and saying well Andre if you
want to have a fight here if you had any
chance of the black pieces for some
active play you're going to have to
force matters and that could backfire
right normally White's playing on the
Queen's side here like Rook B1 B4 A4 so
Rook 81
um and now black is thinking seems like
a uh
uh interesting idea I'm wondering if he
wants to
you know push his kingside pawns like E4
and F4 I don't know that's
rookie1 I think is an unusual idea
because his Rook on F1 is trapped so
that indicates to me he wants to do
something on the king side which is
which is a bit odd yeah and usually the
pawn as you were saying would be on F3
in the night like on E2 and you just
start pushing pawns here perhaps E4 is
in the future uh in this game but it
looks very solid for Block even if I
would prefer the white sides a little
bit uh more to choose from but we're
getting word that the mvl game is
quite unique whoa what actually what is
this Ben check this out you ready I'm
checking it out what is happening in
this game still Theory uh
probably is still Theory
oh my goodness why is there a king on D1
yeah let's go back I'm confused white is
up a pawn in the current position that
should be black has a big threat though
uh give me this one or this one yeah
exactly
uh let's check this out so it was a
sicilian uh-huh and Knight F6 do not
play E5 everybody just quick little tip
here because you can play E5 against me
that's okay
you think you're attacking the Knight
the Knight is gonna move but you don't
always have to react by moving the piece
that's attacked Queen A5 check picks up
the pawn on E5 so that would just be a
blunder so instead after Knight F6
Knight C3 Knight C6 and
we get E5 there's no check so it works
and these lines are super popular these
days Ben I don't pretend to understand
them but the King goes on a walk I think
we saw it was a yes of panko's King on
F3 in a previous round yeah we saw this
line already I I studied this line a few
years ago and then I was like I can't
remember this for black I'm just not
gonna apply it I can't remember what to
do like you know 9 10 11 12. I give up
and wasn't this is too weird for me and
wasn't this the infamous position from
Isle of Man where shirov and honestly I
was like carjacking against drayov and
Sheriff against yugangi they're playing
on boards next to each other yeah I
remember that and they were both playing
this opening and they're like confused
and looking at each other and so they
moved shirov's board to the last board
and the second room so they were very
far away from each other just to prevent
not it's not cheating but they were
uncomfortable all the players like
staring at the board yeah it feels weird
so F5 played that's known if you take D5
down goes E4 on passant the night has to
take and then Bishop E3 hitting the
queen so all of this I believe is known
Queen d8 and then Knight D6 checks
that's how
white secure the bishop pair at a first
glance Bend this looks really nice for
what right it makes me not understand
why black ever plays this opening
um yeah I think if black doesn't do
anything the next five moves he's losing
but there's probably some tactical
nonsense
because you know the white Kings I need
to so there's always tactical nonsense
would you say it's not on E2 anymore now
it's better oh King D1 he tricked me
yeah so the King goes back to D1 this
has actually been played a handful of
times here C5 so we're still in
theoretical territory not my theory but
there's so giving away the pawn so the
bishop is open the diagonal Bishop E4
does make sense
and Bishop E2 people may be asking but I
feel like this is a question some why
hasn't black Castle I can't Castle
through check just to remind people that
yeah probably has too young to do that
yeah so D6 does attack the Queen the
pawn G2 is threatened and
have we seen any moves no no move so I
think this is the end of mvl's prep but
uh I'm not sure if it's if it's the end
of uh prognan house prep probably
they're out of prep now
yes based on because Maxine he's so
there are two types of players Ben and
I'm curious which one you are there are
types of spiders here when they're in
their prep they Blitz every single move
don't waste any time and there are
others who like that psychological
warfare where they're sitting there
thinking but they really know the lines
want their opponent to get into this
false sense of comfort so first of all
which type of player are you and NBL is
definitely the type who blisses out
every movie you know so yeah well
thinking is not my strong suit but uh
yeah I don't play super fast but I'm
gonna sort somewhere in the middle
um it's funny my good friends Stuart
Rachel's
um it was a former U.S champion
he would do something
I guess that's why he's a professor now
instead of a chess player he he would
think forever when he was in his prep
and not for psychological reasons
because he was thinking about stuff
and he told me once he'd use an hour on
the clock and he was still in his
pre-game prep
and I believed him I mean he just you
won't move he just finds everything
fascinating
um I understand that that's that's sort
of crazy but
um
you know I don't I don't like to move
too quickly in my prep because you know
I don't want to give everything away but
uh
yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not slow like
Stuart I'm just gonna play like at a
normal Pace the opponent doesn't really
know
um yeah I remember playing Chomsky in
1994 at the World open
and he
was it 94 93 sorry he he blitzed
everything out and then he stopped so
then I was like okay he's out of prep
I mean and when my dad played Fisher in
63 my dad said Fisher played the first
about 20 moves instantly and then he
stopped so when they stopped I guess
they're out of their prep and that is a
big tell of course Maxine Russia live
Rob and you know he's an elite player so
he can think on his own but it is a nice
thing to know when your opponent's prep
has ended because probably Ananda still
seems to be in his preparation uh
apparently this D6 move after Bishop E2
uh D6 was the first new move of the game
they were following a 2007 game between
Vladimir okopion who was above 2700 at
the time and he was playing against
Timor Raj above who is well known still
to this day and Rook C8 was the choice
in that game here D6 Queen before and
castles quite quickly by prognanda that
would worry me if I'm Maxine my king is
on D1 I am up a pawn but in my
opponent's preparation and is my king
stuck in the center worth the extra Pawn
I'm not sure funny that seems like one
of the few players
who doesn't seem to be bothered by
walking in the prep because he just
believes in himself yeah like I'm the
better player I got two Bishops I got an
extra point I don't care if my
opponent's in prep he just believes in
himself and I mean
if this is still prep progdon has very
happy he's following his prep and I
think mvl's happy to have this kind of
position this is even if mvl was black
he just likes these crazy positions yeah
he really does although I would I mean I
think both players are relatively happy
now
it just feels like the type of position
where you know you go in with the white
pieces or the high rated player you
expect to press and if not you go to
play tie breaks it's a type position
where you could see your tournament Run
come to an end because your king is in
the center and there seems like black
despite being the pawn down has
everything else under control and I
would prefer to have black side I see
that the engine slightly prefers white
it's a practical decision at this point
of you know which side you prefer
because it's uh it dynamically balanced
in many ways uh you know white has the
extra Pawn the bishop pair the potential
down the line but right now I'm
concerned about Maxim's King and if he's
able to keep his King defended find a
place to go with it and finish his
coordination then I will of course start
liking his position but for now I think
probably Nanda he's won the opening
battle
you know it's funny I said it yesterday
normally when somebody who's in the you
know mid to low 2600s and they're black
against mvl they put their head down and
say why is this my pairing but not these
young kids they they play for a win with
both colors they have a lot of prep
they're great tactically and they don't
feel like they're the underdog they're
like I can beat anybody so this is and
progdon has showing that that he's not
afraid
yeah and like super sharp they relish
the opportunity you're absolutely right
Ben and I before we go to our first
break I do want to bring up the game of
Peter Fiddler of course extremely well
known to the trust community and it's
very funny I'm friends with Peter and
people think about Peter as this great
commentator which she of course is but
we know Peter Fiddler as an amazing
player and people you know either are
newer to chess and just have not seen
his games or they just are so uh I don't
even know the words to say here but
they're so enchanted by his great
commentary that uh they forget that he
is an amazing player but here he is at
this stage of the world cup with the
black pieces against his compatriot
Nikita vitilugov and this is surprise
surprise Ben a grundfeld position where
white has just put the bishop on E3 we
see a clear Target here and I think that
Peter has some things to figure out and
that's why he is down on the clock and
if I'm not mistaken this looks kind of
new to me I'm not in the grunfield
theoretician expert that Peter is but
this looks like a new position to my
eyes
speaking of the grinfeld one of the few
times you played it was when you beat me
um
yeah I don't know Bishop E3 I think
if I remember correctly and I don't
there's some
like you can play Queen D2 and F4 or you
could just play F4 right away you could
play Bishop H6 and then try to play F4
Bishop E3 is um
it's not I I don't know that move that
doesn't seem like one of the plans that
white usually plays usually white just
goes crazy and tries to push those
Center pawns Bishop E3 a boring
developing move what I've never been so
mad and obviously um Peter's out of his
prep Bishop E3 is probably new because
Peter's just sitting there right he's
not gonna move and Peter Fiddler knows
the grinfeld better than anybody not
named Maxine versus both of those
players the leading theoreticians in the
grunfeld and the fact that he is down
nearly 20 minutes in the clock to the
very strong Nikita I've actually heard
your commentary on Nikita Ben you remind
everybody of my absolutely
demoralizing loss to him in the opening
round of the uh the world Team
Championship where that was really lost
wasn't it you played great that event I
had a good tournament but that game has
been imprinted in my mind that was yeah
well you lost that game because I think
I was helping you beforehand I think I
was
uh there are many reasons I lost the
main one being that Nikita is an
absolute Menace on the chessboard and he
doesn't get the credit he always
deserves because I think there's so many
of his compatriots that are a more
famous more renowned but Nikita is
always just he's right there in the
thick of things and the most important
event so he has a well-respected player
but just quickly to hop through this
game uh it was at grunfeld as we were
speaking of and this is all Mainline
theory if you ever just Google the
grunfels variation you know the group of
Defense you will find all of this Knight
takes D3 and black plays C5 to challenge
the pawn Center and here is the first
it's a known move but it's not nearly
the most popular with Bishop B5 check
and the reason Bishop B5 check isn't uh
so common is that white often plays
Bishop E3 just defend the center right
away or even Rook to B1 is a main try
here but Bishop B5 check gets the Knight
to C6 Your Castle and now D5 you get to
play this move attacking the Knight so
that's the good news of playing Bishop
to B5 the bad news is you open up this
bishop on the long diagonal and gear 95
takes takes and Bishop E3 which as Ben
said the First new move that we have
seen and that has put Peter deep in the
think tank Ben made a point of f4 coming
your way soon and you don't often care
about this Pawn on C3 you're just
pushing those Pawns in the center
gaining space and it's an interesting
Battle Man
yeah as you said Peter's the world's
leading Authority maybe he even knows
more than mvl because he's older
um Theory you know I was thinking when I
was you know mini complaining earlier
about all the 50 year olds are out I I
wonder I'm going to be corrected
immediately but is Peter the oldest
player left in on the in the open side
oh I think so yeah he's not young I've
I've known Peter for
what year is this I've known him for 30
years wow so yeah I met him in in
Groningen actually
something around 1990 yeah he he was
protecting me because
I I lost badly to
um Arthur frolov man I can't believe I
remembered his name and when we analyzed
the game froloff was explaining that
everything wins for him every move and
every movement was terrible and
Fiddler's like what and Fiddler's like
now you know he was yelling at him so I
I need the protection because I couldn't
refute his moves but I did get beaten
badly it's true well there's a few
people yeah a few people in the world
better than Peter spitler to have
backing you up and yeah well speaking of
backing up we are going to take our
first break of the day Petersburg has
just made a move so it'll be interesting
to see how this game develops amongst
others we are going to take a short
break and come back for more coverage of
the fide World Cup and feed a Women's
World Cup in just a few
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we had Magnus Carlson's game on during
the break and he is your world chess
champion at least for now because coming
your way in November is the 2021 World
Chess Championship chess.com is your
exclusive twitch home for the video
feeds for this year's World Championship
join us for the best coverage around as
we watch this year's players the
defending Champion Magnus Carlson and
Challenger Jana palmchi battle for the
title The World Chess championships
coming your way November on chess.com
but for now we are in the midst of the
World Cup so this will Crown a World Cup
champion the top two finishers will make
their way to the Canada tournament which
Jana palmchi won to earn the right to
face Magnus Carlsen but that's a long
story that's far from now right now
everyone is folks and just playing their
current game getting to the next round
if they can and Ben let's head on over
to the Women's World Cup where three
women's candidate spots are on the line
many of the players are rooting for
Alexander Alexander as long as they
don't play her because she's already in
the woman's candidates so if she can
make it to the final four the other
three participants there will be assured
a spot in the candidates and she needs
to win this game Ben from the white side
when you look at this position not a
single Pawn has been traded are you
liking stefanova's chances to hold on
and make her way through to the final
eight or do you think gorias could have
something up for sleep here
no I think
um that White's doing a good job of uh
you know when you don't trade anything
the game goes on and on I prefer white
here anyway black has to solve the
problem of her Bishop on C8
um so I think I think White's doing a
good job of trying to get an advantage
make the game go a long time put her
opponent under pressure and she's not
rushing it by playing some crazy line
where you're trying to win right away
she's just playing your game a normal
Advantage for Wyatt and just trying to
win the normal way not going not going
totally insane and that's that's the
problem when you have black in these
situations which a lot of people do
um when they lose the first game with
white they sort of have to go crazy with
black which we're seeing a jumbabaya do
now against him
um but but uh yeah this is the right
approach is just play your game play
solid get an advantage make the game
last a long time put pressure on your
opponent and don't go crazy and
obviously as you said nothing's been
traded so white White's not going crazy
yeah sometimes people believe that the
only way to win games is by just going
for all the tactics and going for
checkmate but goria she's such a strong
player she says I'm gonna play a
fundamentally sound opening and in fact
black has a difficult time making a
single move in this position because if
you push your B Pawn the C6 square that
could be a big weakness you don't
realize that right away but for example
after B6 I'm already looking at things
like cd5 and the C6 Square looks a bit
vulnerable and if you take with this
Pawn maybe there's just an E4 break
because I'm threatening E5 I'm
threatening to take here if you take and
we get all these kind of Trades watch
out you don't want to keep trading
because at the end of the road there's a
rook hanging the corner and a Pawn on H7
under attack so there actually are a lot
of tactics beneath the surface a lot of
room for error for both players and
let's say you know you don't play B6 but
you say oh I'm going to play E5 we've
talked about isolated pawns and some
other games well enjoy
in isolated Pawn if I take on E5 but
also white often just plays E4 and blows
the whole Bordeaux open and white is
more fully developed black has this
bishop on C8 Rook on a not quite in the
game in the same way and queen and
Bishop lined up against H7 I've seen
many games go south for black in a
position just like this
that's right and as I said black has to
be careful and this is the problem you
can get by just staring at the engine
evaluation it might say black is a
little worse but if black doesn't play
accurately she can be lost right away
she can have just strategically lost
position so if black plays really
accurately to defuse you know White's
leading development an initiative then
then she's almost equal but any little
mistake here could could cause black as
the variation you show where there's a
fork and it's tough to play Black here
just you know not only can C6 become
weak but the bishop on C8 is hard to
activate so difficult position for black
yeah when you start pinpointing specific
weaknesses you want to fix them right
away this bishop wants to develop but
playing B6 loosens control the C6 Square
playing E5 mainly black with an isolated
Pawn or just an explosive position that
will backfire so it's not easy to make a
single move here here and I think that's
why goryovskana has quite a lead in the
clock and I want to take us to a
different type of position Ben but at
the corner of my I think you'll like
this one in the game between keshlinsky
and savvica Silva here what in the world
is happening there's a Pawn on G5 uh the
black king looks very safe but the eval
bar looks like it's just right down the
middle as if this position is completely
even
what in the world
I mean you know if the problem is on G3
I wouldn't be so shocked but the point
on G5 I'm like whoa what happened and
black is up a pawn to start with
yeah this is this is strange
I guess white has two Bishops and white
eventually wants to either take on a
seven or play F4 kick the Knight away
and you know I guess white just has good
compensation for a pawn but this is um
this this is quite the position and
check out how it happened because Knight
C3 is it this is actually let's go back
a little bit and I won't really harp on
the theory but this is Indian Pawn
sacrifice yeah and known Pawn sacrifice
for you give up on D5 and you just say
I'm in the lead in development there is
going to be some problems on this
diagonal if you're not careful and we
saw Rook D1 Knight C6 please take on D5
it's a free piece I blundered oh no my
knight Eric Rosen you're taking photos
in Sochi but you would be the person to
make a trick like this you get the
fourth you win The Rook on D5 back so
and it doesn't work out here Queen A4 is
a known move and then you just play
principal chest and then G4 happens so
you start playing principal chess and
then you play G4 but the idea is clear
right then just play G5 take over the D5
square and start yeah I think it's
clearly prepped because I can see how
much time white has on the clock
but yeah I mean if G4 was in prep that's
a hard move to play
it makes sense you're trying to control
D5 and E4 that's fine yeah you're just
using your Pawn as a weapon so my king
is not actually under attack and here
goes the pawn Knight E5 what a move to
play the square is not defended by any
of White's pieces but the d-pawn is
pinned and so you lose your queen if you
take with the pawn E5 and if you take
with the Knight as in the game which you
have to do because look at how many
attackers three attackers on the night
on C6 only one Defender you can't leave
your knight there so Knight takes E5
give me the bishop pair and as you said
Ben ideas with F4 the A7 Pawn hanging I
actually really like this for white if
you're a pawn down but that doesn't tell
the story of the game yeah and you can't
take on G5 unless I'm mistaken because
of f4 forking
okay I'm not mistaken it's never
happened
um
yeah so this is this is really
interesting prep she has a big time
advantage and we like her position also
yeah I kind of want to get a position
like this myself in the white piece why
do I always have bad positions from
White how do I get this I don't know if
you know you were there so you must know
in round one the match that ownership
won
um he had wided a similar opening with
the D5 Pawn sacrifice and he needed a
draw to win the match and he just
absolutely crushed his opponent I mean
he sacked a Pawn on D5 and he just I
mean that was an amazing you know like
Blitz of his opponent
um yeah the problem is with this line
for black and I used to play the Queen's
Indian uh before you were born and then
as soon as you were born I was like
that's enough Robert Hess is born no
more Queens Indian
um
either I equalized or I got smushed I
never got an advantage I never got a
good position and these positions worry
me when whenever there's a pawn
sacrifice on D5 I just like those
positions for Wyatt yeah I'm the same
way just stop playing it this bishop
unopposed on the long diagonal here
black just doesn't have space so you
have your extra Pawn but it doesn't even
feel like you're up material because you
can't really do anything with it so I I
didn't know until you told me I didn't
know that white was a fondant because it
looked great for white yeah it looks
amazing and unless somehow these pawns
get rolling on the queen side you know a
B5 a B4 things like that but then you're
also just inviting the Knight to D5 I
really love these positions from White's
perspective and Alina keshlinska she is
married to Radisson boy tachek who's
playing Magnus Carlson so they're a very
strong chess couple just like Alexander
grashook and Katarina lock know and
speaking of Lucknow let's go over to her
game uh quickly where I see that it's a
very different type of position it was a
info just by the structure and as we get
here we see that
the night went the king went back to E1
which already is weird so let's go
through the opening moves which should
be familiar to our grunfell players in
the audience and Bishop E3 C5 Queen D2
this is known theoretical territory
Queen A5 putting pressure on C3 but also
as often happens Queen trade so this has
been played
many many times castles Knight F3 Knight
C6 D5 makes sense and after Rook d8 King
E1 is the main move so I'm just not as
familiar with the ins and outs oh she's
preparing the castle later so
to uh to Castle this way kingside that's
right well the other way is silly Robert
come on yeah true the rook's already
moved how could I yeah come on but this
line here by acebreva is catching
Katarina lock no in a difficult spot
both players have spent a decent amount
of time to this point and I do not like
the look of Knight A6 I generally
speaking uh 996 in a position like this
looks awkward I don't even want to take
it I just we'll leave it there but
Knight A2 do you live to tell the tale
Knight A2 yeah what do you think giving
me fond memories of a game that I lost
against vandersteron because that H2 was
really cool but
um
uh well first of all
there's a there's a bigger question at
hand here not what the right move is but
when you play very common openings that
have tons and tons of theory and you're
in a theoretical position and now you
just sit there you're like hmm what do I
do that's very dangerous and that's why
I'm always afraid to play 10 20 moves of
theory because it takes a lot of energy
and work to learn that much and know
what you're doing then you have to
remember it and then if you're like hmm
what was I supposed to do here your work
was sort of for not because your
opponent knows the position better than
you so I try to avoid theoretical lines
like this and it worries me when players
as strong as this in a position that is
either still in theory or one move out
of theory or like hmm where should I
move my knight that's it's a scary
Prospect to play Knight A2 unless you
already know it and 96 looks bad so
this is why I'm not playing these lines
because you have to know everything and
that's why mvl and Peter Fiddler can
play them because they know everything
that's true and if you're going to sit
and think right out of theory and then
play Knight A2 you better be darn sure
that Knight's getting out of there and I
think it is because there's a C3 Square
uh and actually I kind of like Black's
position because if I can get an F5 move
in I'm collapsing White Center and the
King on E1 feels a bit wrong to me uh I
I guess there's Rook C4 just to defend
the pawn directly and if Knight C3 like
can I just attack your knight since this
Pawn E4 is already defended and while
the engine is going like up and down but
I was just gonna play Bishop to D2 it's
too difficult for the engine give it
something
I mean where's this night going all
right the night is actually in big
trouble here if you're a knight V5 I
have a bishop hitting your knight
Through The Rook so I would just take
your roof uh your Bishop C8 right there
I was gonna go to B1 because it was
funny that should be a white knife and
it's a black knight I wasn't really
going to go there just did it for jokes
yeah it's not bad look at it it
it's perfectly fine but how do you I was
afraid of Bishop before because the E7
Pawn is hanging so I was afraid I would
be afraid too that night looks like it's
trapped
but somehow this is acceptable for black
that's why you have to know these
positions otherwise you're going to sit
there for 20 minutes and still be wrong
yeah this is a above my pay grade um you
know Knights jumping to A2 then to B1
and you know that's just fine but Rook
C4 also there's B5 as a potential move
although B5 is a scary move to play for
black on one hand right you're getting
ready to March the pawns down the other
you're getting all your pawns under
attack whether it's A7 E7 or B5 things
like this could collapse very quickly so
I think both players have a lot to work
out here they're both out of theory
they've spent quite a deal of time to
this point so this is important game as
they drew game one but let's uh head
back over to the World Cup the open
section because
not only is you know world champion Max
Carlson playing of course but I want to
go to that joomap live game against Sam
Shanklin because you and I were talking
about it during the break well I used to
play that opening with black and I want
to emphasize used to
don't play it now you mean E4 and Knight
C6 is not yeah yeah I've played this
with black like again it was before you
were born
everything I did was before you were
born even stuff I did yesterday hard to
understand yeah I had I had a book on
the nimsovich defense when I was a
little kid and I was playing it and my
opponents are like what what is this
um and then yeah my positions were
always bad
yes I can understand why because
typically you want your Pawns in front
of your night to challenge the center
and so if the position gets closed that
won't be good after E5 you know what's
funny about this game Robert isn't the
position the fact that black is playing
a surprising opening and Shanklin just
moving instantly in his opponent's
thinking forever that's funny well Sam
Shanklin is one of the best prepared
players on the planet I think people use
that kind of Sling at him as an insult
that and it's not just him right some of
the best players in the world including
Sam they're kind of maligned for being
knowing too much Theory as if they're
not also just great players out of their
theoretical framework but Sam does know
many many openings including this one
apparently even though it's a rare line
and he's playing instantly sacrificing a
pawn because gmobile plays F5 to keep
that pawn on e4 and yet Sam goes yeah
whatever have your Pawn Knight H3 that
way there's no F4 trapping the bishop E5
gonna take that on person I don't want
to leave your Pawn mass in the center
and now after the queen trade here well
Bishop B4 was played but I see a pawn
hanging on C7 uh maybe I played Bishop
C4 to keep my Pawn E6 but this is the
type of position you need to have your
dream about trying to win with the black
pieces against Sam Shanklin
um yeah I mean he's trying uh to do
something but as I said when you're
black and you play something off beat
it's good to get your opponent out of
their crap although you can see no work
here
um but sometimes the reason it's not
played a lot and it's off beat is
because it's not very good right so I
think you agree Robert you'd rather have
white in this position I would rather
have white but all things considered
this is the perfect type of position for
joomabaya to have because it's not just
a symmetrical position locked up no
there's a Pawn on E6 that is either a
great strength for white or just an
eventual weakness because let's say you
do play Bishop C4 and black decides to
play I guess King E7 is one way of going
after the pawn directly or let's say I'm
greedy and play C6 can I eventually
coordinate my pieces and get this Pawn I
doubt it because white can castle and
play F3 and things like that but there
is a chance for black in a way that you
might not have in some other positions
and even if the chance you lose are
quite great and I do think that white is
very happy here at least you're also
increasing your winning chances so you
might lose the game but it draws you got
to increase your winning chances drawing
is the same as losing that's right yeah
so I I think it's a good decision about
Jim Bob even if we both acknowledge that
shanklin's position is quite nice and
well speaking of people who need to win
with the black pieces nobody back Abdul
sitar have lost with white yesterday and
here he is with the black pieces in this
position and Ben we quickly glanced at
this game during the break and look at
that eval bar it's heavily in Black's
favor and I don't know about you Ben but
the Philadelphia defense using that as a
win you typically see that in the when
black is a much higher rated player than
uh his opponent is trying to play some
line that's not theoretical but in this
game this looks totally fine for white
everything is normal Castle your king is
safe your Queens in the center can't be
attacked and yet at this moment he
decides to get too active for his oh he
lost his patience he probably thought
just trade everything and draw and go to
the next round yeah yeah E5 trade Queens
let's make a draw as you're saying but
the problem with E5 is after Knight G4
he probably thought oh I'll just win
upon on D6 maybe black gets some play
but Bishop F6 the tough move to meet
hitting the queen on D4 the queen needs
to stay in line with the pawn on F2 but
then after Bishop takes C3 wait the
queen uh oh I can't do both at the same
time and so if I take on C3 I lose an
exchange and that's the exact type
position I do sitarov wants and if you
take with the pawn it's also the exact
type of position he wants you can have
this D6 point I don't care about that my
Queen's coming to A5 your king or queen
side but where your king is is in
shambles and I would much prefer to have
black in this position
right and I and he just played E5 too
quickly and after Knight G4 he realized
what he did and he's he he didn't move
he's like what do I he's been thinking
forever here
um maybe he already did okay he played
Bishop G3
defending his F Pawn again
um
I guess the idea is if you take on E5 I
do I take queens and trade Rooks and
play H3 well no
then Bishop G5 check it yeah I don't
know
I would be scared to have white here but
obviously he thought forever but yeah E5
doesn't make a lot of sense because
white White's not developed yet his
Bishops on F1 his Rook is on H1 why is
he opening the center
and I actually did a video series about
a year and a half ago for chess.com
which you can if you're a premium member
you can look at now on the Philadelphia
fence I think there were 10 videos
and one of them discussed this being a
good line for why Bishop F4 and Castle's
Queen side another way white could play
is to play G3 early Bishop G2 that's
also good for Wyatt
but yeah I think I think he knew Bishop
F4 castles as a good line for white but
he he played E5 without thinking better
of it without thinking of the
ramifications of Knight G4 did you see
Bishop F6
then after Knight G4 he did see it and
he thought forever and played the move
Bishop G3 which I guess has the engine
seal of approval I I suppose
and but we're getting this position here
and even if it has you know and thumbs
up from the engine is it's okay I take
black you have the bishop obviously take
black if you've done nothing and you
have the bishop pair and okay you're not
up material after Queen takes E5 but the
Queens will stay on the board now right
so you gain regain your material for
white unit temporarily down a pawn okay
great now it's back so here you have a
position where I played Bishop D6 and
this A2 Pawn could be in trouble at some
point I could launch my pawns over here
on the queen side this is the exact
position that you would want for black
and you haven't even done much to I mean
opposite side castling and two Bishops
and a must win position when black
person
this is how you draw it up uh you know
couldn't ask for anything more so right
now there's still lots of proof for Abdu
sotara but he's up on time yeah I I
think that vasiv might be a bit rattled
because you make the move E5 thinking
I'm just playing principal chess and
then Knight G4 happens and then you're
nervous because I just need to draw oh
gosh if I take on D6 then my king is not
very safe so I just should play it safe
but oftentimes playing it safe is the
most dangerous way to play because you
think that you're just working your way
towards a specific result but that kind
of tunnel vision can really backfire so
I love Abdus atara's position uh he just
has the Bishops as you said the Kings on
opposite sides at no risk whatsoever and
he can play for a win
without any concern at this stage of the
game so I think that vasif has gone
wrong
yeah agreed completely and let's uh keep
venturing to other games we haven't
looked at plenty of them at this point
there was a weird game between pyoroon
and cindarov oh yeah where the knights
were in the corner nobody puts the
knights in them well right now black is
up a piece for a pawn but unfortunately
for black two pieces under attack you're
gonna lose one of them but let's go back
because it was kind of funny how things
happened here it was an alapins which is
a great opening Choice when you only
need a draw this is a solid opening uh
White can often claim a very slight
Advantage not think too major but it's
not tactical if Black's gonna try to
drum up some kind of winning chances uh
good luck to you and this is what
cindarov tried but it didn't exactly pay
off for him because he played Knight B4
Bishop E4 and then he went Bishop D7
here
PRN said don't mind if I do I'll snack
on that pawn and Knight C2
this Rook is trapped but the problem for
black at this point is while you are
winning this rook and will be up a piece
for a pawn after the very nice
retreating move always Retreat right Ben
91 bye bye to your nine on a one so
White's just up a pawn and very happy
the Queens are off not many pieces left
it couldn't have gone better for Casper
no this is a a really nice position for
white when you especially when you need
to draw you know I I play Knight F3 C3
with white sometimes against the
Sicilian and I haven't faced you know
like E6 like this variation often but
the one time I remember facing it was
with your good friend Assuming he's
still your good friend uh Mark Arnold
and man did he crush me yeah I'm glad he
stopped playing chess because I haven't
lost to him since he stopped playing if
you still keep in touch with him or yeah
yeah I haven't seen him in years hey he
doesn't play chess anymore which is a
very common uh well around the globe but
especially I would say in the United
States where he was a very strong Young
America I mean I knew him when he was
like seven that's when I first met him
in New York and he was obviously really
good already you know when he was a
little kid yep um but then he beat me
yeah what a what a bad person I guess I
can't be friends with him any longer
yeah exactly yeah that's why we're not
friends you're always beating me
well I thought we've you know we've
overcome that and I guess not you know
I'll work on it but that's why I don't
play Ben so I can't beat you right yeah
as soon as people beat me too much they
better stop
well
Casper pieron is not going to be stopped
right now A cindarov unfortunately for
him it looks like his Cinderella
tournament run is coming to an end he
eliminated alireza faruga he keeps on
winning but unfortunately for him after
uh you know uncharacteristic mistakes
yesterday from the white side against
pure Rune Casper just keeps on going and
it's an extra Pawn for white I don't see
how black can even think dream about
playing for a win here you'll be lucky
to hold at this point yeah this is a
great position for white there's just
going to be a solid Pawn up and no
problems yeah wow so it's going to I
think Casper puren is looking like our
first entrant into the round of 16 and
it's not set in stone yet I think crazy
things happen but uh this is as
risk-free of an advantage as you could
ask for and somehow in my bracket I
didn't have him in the final 16 I don't
know what it was yeah you're just bad at
prognosticating yeah that must be it
well as long as it's procrastinating so
that's good hey that's a that's a talent
in and of itself but a Casper pieron is
one of three polish players remaining he
has defeated opponent after opponent in
regular classical games he has not gone
to a single tybreak he beat Austrian
Grand Master around 2680 Marcus ragger
he beats Jordan Von Forest one and a
half half and now he's up one zero and
you have a care sundarov and about to
win the match he if he goes through
he'll face the winner of buck Crow
against Punk ratov so maybe pjorin is
the his magical run may not be stopped
anytime soon he actually has I mean
obviously Robert he was the big favor
coming into the event yeah of course
when you think of the Polish
Grandmasters who will make their mark on
this Tournament of course the first
person he thought of was purein and
krasenkov but they uh had a great event
still going and uh Duda and voitacek
still in the mix as well let's uh
quickly glance at one more game uh just
uh the Duty game we're mentioning him
and right now with the black pieces
it's White's term you're probably going
to take a knight that just captured
something on C3 captured a bishop there
so yeah this looks to my eyes like
not so much danger for Duda but I guess
there is this Pawn on C6 that means I'm
tending to
yeah I mean I'd rather have white but
I'm expecting to draw this game yeah
yeah this looks like it's going to a tie
break
I agree and for uh idani who had that
pretty crazy game one with a black side
of that sharp tactical position against
Duda he probably was a little
disappointed not to score Victor at some
point it looked really really dangerous
for Duda he was living on the edge but
right now it looks like Duda he's right
at the ship and he's looking to go to
tie breaks where he will be the favorite
as he is of 2700 Plus in all formats and
just uh an Ops of Beast
no I agree and again uh
another guy that I wasn't expecting uh
to do well because he's not considered
one of the top two players in this
country but
he just doesn't care these guys who were
third fourth best in their country
they're coming here to play
they really are no fear and they
shouldn't be fearful in a two-game match
anything can happen you may be outrated
but that does not mean you're going to
lose that's the beauty of chess the
struggle of Chess and so we'll see how
this game continues as well as the
others but for now then I we're gonna
take a short break and return more from
the fide World Cup and the fide Women's
World Cup this coverage brought to you
by chess.com
foreign
[Music]
superstars in Rapid and Blitz here in
the world cup and those tie breaks the
St Louis rapid Blitz part of the grand
chest tour will be coming your way in
August the likes of Fabiano caruana
Lavon aronian and others will take part
amongst the 10 grand Masters competing
for their share of 150 thousand dollars
it's going to be fun you will not want
to miss the action chess.com will be
covering it so we'll see you back here
in August after this tournament for the
St Louis rapid and Blitz but this
tournament still in full swing the games
are heating up Ben during the break
we're looking at various games including
the game between patelahari Krishna and
his opponent Amin tabithabai remember
the Iranian player won yesterday with
the white pieces pental trying to do the
same to even up the map score and head
to those tie breaks I like White's
position from the sense of you need to
win a game having this kind of position
where it's not clear the direction of
the game I think is a good start for
Hare Krishna yeah and it seems like all
of the players who need to draw in the
second game
um are aren't playing for a draw and I
think the the one person who made a
mistake by trying to trade too much and
equalize the position was Derby Ali
who's actually like a wild and crazy
player but after E5 94 he was like oh so
yeah black needs a draw but it doesn't
look like he's playing for a draw
um but yeah I'm with you I I really like
White's position
um black hasn't castled yet
and you know he the G3 Knight the E4
Pawn the F6 Knight there's pressure
everywhere
so this is a tough position for black
and this is what Hari Krishna wants you
know good winning chances and
you know he's got to be the favorite if
they get to tie breaks he's just a much
higher rated player and I guess that
doesn't matter much this event but I
mean Hari Christian is a tough opponent
yeah he is yeah yeah sort of sort of
along with Peter's Fiddler he's also a
commentator that I like a lot I like his
explanations as do I and I think that
Kevin Dubai he's a great speeches for
himself so he's not going to go now
without a fight if he happens to lose
today's game and I think your point
though Ben is well taken that black is
struggling from all angles I mean
Black's next move if you gave like a
free turn is Knight takes C5 so we know
that that's the plan for black but it
moves that I'm even considering in
addition that Bishop takes D3 is the
move Pawn to A4 sort of thematic Pawn
break because if your move is Knight
takes C5 you've opened my queen up to
the B5 Square so if I play A4 and you
play Knight takes C5 well thank you very
much you have my Pawn I have yours and
White's Pawn structure uh is a little
bit safer this E4 Pawn sticks out maybe
maybe it could be in some trouble
there's the pin here what are you going
to do about your A6 Pawn Knight D2
happens next as well to put more
pressure on e4 I just feel like white
has much better coordination of pieces
has the bishop pair the king that's
already castled so if not A4 there are
other options like the simple Bishop
takes D3
I don't know quite spoil for choice
yeah white has more than one one good
move here and uh yeah I mean black has
some issues the Knight on F6 pinned is
King 98 he has doesn't want to be down
upon the rest of the game so there's
there's a lot going on here that's
that's not necessarily good for black
now and the clock situation also not
good for black our Christian has a bit
more time so everything is trending in
his Direction uh it's not losing for
black nothing of the sword it's just a
difficult position to play practically
speaking and for Hare Krishna he has
many options here that maintain that
nagging advantage and doesn't seem like
black is going to be able to solve his
problems anytime soon
that's right yeah actually one of my
lesser known rules which I usually say
for my Advanced students is when your
opponent as black has a point on B5
always play A4 so I like your A4
suggestion that was good yeah it's uh
thematic and I really like that as a
principle if there is a Politics on B5
A4 is just such a common move to play
because black is in a way is
overextended here on the queen side and
you can start putting some attackers
there and actually it's important to
note that whether or not you play A4
castling is not possible because Bishop
takes D3 and you've lost the defender of
your queen on E7 so it's a really tough
position for black to deal with no
uh let's uh keep on going there's so
many interesting games Federal save
against kovalev vladislav kovalev needs
to win doesn't know how to play for a
draw no he only knows he only knows how
to play aggressively but firstly what's
with this party on the H and G file over
here everyone's invited yeah all of
Black's pieces are over here saying ah
go for the Queens I take D6 take B7
snack on all the pawns you want over
here but black is clearly focused his
energy on the king side if we go back
just quickly through this game here it
got wild quickly this queen D2 moved
popularized by Magnus Carlson against
none other than Voit that was their game
where he dropped his Queen back to D2 it
looks very strange but white fianchetto
is the bishop and tries to go for an
attack so
Bishop came to B2 E5
pinned Pawn
castles and he takes F4 benefit first
glance I think that looks really scary
because you opened up the theme of that
Bishop yeah but it seems like Federal
save he's prepped this out because if
you look at his current time he's only
spent 10 minutes for the whole game so
he knew what he was doing
yeah it's funny in the in the last round
of one of those super St Louis
tournaments where they invite like 2650
pluses fedoc was in first and he was
white again shankland
and
you know Federal save doesn't know how
to draw so he played his usual chess and
Shanklin just crushed him and that that
caused Federal say a first place and I
was like man if I needed to draw to win
a tournament and I I depict somebody I
wouldn't pick Federal save with white
because he just he has to play for a win
he has to sacrifice he has to play Crazy
he has to and he does it really well
he doesn't perhaps he doesn't know how
to play for a draw doesn't know how to
do that yeah perhaps it serves him in
the long run but in individual moments
like that yeah it's not very good here
on the other hand it does look scary it
looks like you might fall victim to a
checkmating attack but actually the
Knight on H5 Bishop on H6 combination
not only puts pressure on F4 but covers
the G7 Square multiple times so you can
always Retreat your Bishop in this game
always like King B1 so that gets out of
any danger on the diagonal but simple
takes 95 this Pawn is pinned you lose
your queen if you take a knight and look
at this Knight E2 Queen H4 Queen B4 and
just Knight to G4 why not let's bring
the Knight to the party over here I
don't understand exactly what's going on
in terms of the over-the-board chest but
I do know that Federal Sev is well
within his known territory because he's
been playing pretty quickly every move I
just I would be hard-pressed to have
this position yeah he always has this
big time Advantage puts a lot of
pressure on your opponent
doesn't look that great though and
something about this bishop on B2 the D6
Pawn the V7 Pawn
is it that simple for black you have to
move this Knight
don't go to E3 because Queen D4 will win
a knight
mm-hmm
so you have to go back to F's all right
Knight F2 also looks strange
yeah the engine doesn't like that move
that that's like the first move you look
at because it works for drugs okay I see
why well having the Evolve really helps
Queenie one just pin the Knight yes yeah
what a weird position
you just go for an easy Fork of Rooks
and oh Queen Retreats D1
and then you just pick off the uh yeah
that's not good yeah that's hard to
escape
what a ridiculous sequence I think
Knight F6 always Retreat and how does
this look to you Ben I mean if I'm
thinking From kovalov's perspective
they're definitely are very good winning
chances yeah he's got to be happy in the
must win situation yeah
how do you balance the fact that the
position looks very interesting and
dynamic with the fact that Federal Sav
is spending no time at all and you're
spending all this time like how do you
regain that confidence to recognize I'm
just very glad I never played Federal
save that would not be a good opponent
for me somebody who's super confident
plays super fast knows more Theory than
me calculates better yeah and I I just
luckily I'm never going to play him
because I don't play in tournaments with
him
have you played Fredo save Robert uh not
in not over the board no just uh online
online yeah man online he's pretty good
too yeah he's one of the highest rated
players in chess.com and for good reason
he's I was really impressed with him
when I saw him in St Louis because I I
like that kind of you know style that
this reminds me of uh the younger mvl
although mvl probably hasn't changed
where you just you played for a win you
calculate you play tons of theory you
believe in yourself and
any of y'all too pretty quickly I mean
this is the way Ray Robinson plays but
he never makes a move I mean Ray
Robinson thinks Forever on every move
and mvl and federal save are pretty fast
so those are those are tough guys to
play against when they put so much
pressure on you and you're always way
behind on the clock
but I'm convinced that FedEx only spent
three minutes in the last term because
he wasn't at his board
well he was away uh strolling yeah
that's probably because he went Knight
F6 which I mean we just saw it was the
only move and he still seems to be
within its preparation and
I feel like for cover you have to be
content with the position you have but
the fact that better say is playing so
quickly makes me nervous about White's
position and perhaps you know taking on
D6 or taking on B7 will just backfire
yeah positions like this you you when
it's crazy like this you don't want it
that your opponent knows the position
pretty well then you don't even if
you're better you're like what is this
position and your opponent seems like
super happy to have it it's very strange
it's hard to be objective that's the
real issue is that psychologically your
opponent's playing so quickly okay this
is verified by the engines to be good or
acceptable for black so and they know
what they're doing so if I make some
kind of inaccuracy because I'm in my
opponent's preparation they will find
the correct response whereas I don't
even know the evaluation right now I'm
just on my own and I'm down what is it
almost 40 minutes on the clock I need to
win there's so much pressure so I don't
leave the World Cup I just feel like
it's hard to stay grounded in the moment
and only focus in the move ahead to play
if it's Queen takes D6 or if it's Queen
takes D7 just take a pawn and then keep
on calculating
foreign
I mean Federal Savings you know a fellow
save isn't trying to draw games when he
wins the first one and he ends up
winning that's good for his rating too
because his rating fluctuates a lot it
does because of his crazy Style
it does but yeah you don't want to play
Fredo save when he's when he's on fire
that's not good nope you want to play
the federal save who's off his game and
he's been on fire lately he played a
term in Serbia that nihal sarin won and
I think Federal sale finished just
behind him in second place gain some
rating points here in the World Cup he's
gaining rating quite a bit of rating for
sure he's back to something like 27 15
27 20 territory so he's maybe a bit
underrated at his current 2696 or and
already impressive ELO so uh let's uh
move from this game for the moment it
does seem like Federal save will
continue to show us the top lines
because he's so well prepared and what
about Jeffrey Zhang against vidit
Gujarati because Jeffrey needs a win on
Demand with black and as we pull up the
current position well his chances look
much better now than they did right here
where White had full control of the
center uh black lacking space and yet as
the the game continued here struck with
E5
that it took and I'm guessing Ben you
are going to heavily criticize this
decision here and taken by C5 yeah I
mean it doesn't look terrible for white
but it doesn't look like the way
that white should play if he's trying to
increase his advantage of space
advantage and
you know I just wonder
I don't know but I wonder if you know in
the back of his head he's like if I
drive win the match and this is safer
than D5
so I mean I guess it is safer but it
probably gets rid of most of White's
Advantage if not all of it right do you
think that the lack of clarity in D5 you
know from as a strong chess player but
it knows that white should have some
pull there but there's such an ambiguous
looking position that he just said let
me just take on E5 and play C5 where I
know I gained some space my queen now is
on B3 and has an open diagonal but what
Jeffrey did is kind of the plan you want
to do regardless so yeah and when the
people watching who are watching us now
this is actually very instructive What
Jeffrey did here
he understands the squares his pieces
need to go to and this function on
chess.com exists for a reason you can
make an arrow like this but that's where
the Knight wants to go to unfortunately
you can't take your own Pawn for the
moment just share a square and go to D4
but he realizes that the E6 square is a
very nice one how do you get there you
can play Knight D7 but then you need to
go to f8 you need to move the Rook first
let me save a move Knight A6
Knight C7 and very directly to E6 and
queen C4 has played an H5 and this isn't
even just Alpha zero influence that's
just a good move because it gives you
the G4 Square you can play H4 Ben I'm
starting to appreciate it
I'm having flashbacks to my game with
Jeffrey uh similar Pawn structure we had
traded queens and his Rook was on age
eights he was playing H4 and my Pawn was
on C4 but eventually I pushed my queen
side plans it was too late but this is
this is better for white than my
position but the
Jeffrey's pieces are on similar squares
and yeah the big big problem for white
here
um is black has access to the D4 Square
white doesn't have access to D5 usually
to counterbalance that white does one of
two things pushes his pawns on the queen
side you know B4 B5 or Maneuvers a
knight to D6 but the Knight on F3 is
gone so he can't play 92 to C4 the
Knight on C3 getting to D6 is made extra
Difficult by his last move Queen C4 so I
guess he's not interested in that but
you know this I mean if I had to pick
white or black here just in general I
would pick black because you know the
Bishops are um are not very active now
it's a closed position you explained it
well some of these ideas the night
hopping D6 and the problem is if you hop
on Rook to D6 once rookie eight Bishop
f8 happens all your Rook is probably
gonna have to leave the Square anyways
Play Bishop f8 always and this bishop
and F3 is just a bad piece we tend to
like our Bishop Pairs and I think that
grand Masters when we explain the
Dynamics of Bishop's first Knight we
make it seem like we always want the
bishop hair but this is a position where
I would not want the bishop there it's
closed the bishop won't F3 what's the
diagonal of choice for it uh staring
into its own Pawn staring into a
protected Pawn over here not going
anywhere so where would I want this
bishop maybe on C4 actually but that
takes a while to regroup and if not
there I don't know where because Bishop
G2 Bishop H3 you know against Jeffrey I
had my Bishop on H3 and for three moves
in a row I could have taken his Knight
on D7 which was correct and I never did
and eventually he moved his Knight to
like fa we traded Bishops on C8 and his
Knight on E6 was was just too strong so
I should have taken that night and then
his Bishop on D7 wasn't going to crush
me with the Queens off the board
it's funny when we had uh a vision with
with Danny wrench um before you showed
up uh there was some position and this
she was like yeah I'm not really a two
Bishops guy so I like you know whatever
and I was like you're not a two Bishops
guy what so I was I was shocked to hear
that
um so yeah he he would probably like
black here as well because white is the
two Bishop so
yeah Vichy is known for loving those
nights and it's just rare that the
higher levels but she has made good use
of them to become a world champion and
defend that title so many times and
still in his 50s remain one of the
absolute best players on the planet but
yeah this is a great position for
Jeffrey the clock is favoring him
they've only made 16 moves so 24 moves
to make to a Time Patrol and that's two
minutes per move and then add the
increment for vidit but some easy
position to even find a plan so it's
going to take time just to come up with
ideas for video do you play Knight E2
just to cover the D4 Square notes it
looks very passive not very pleasant for
white so I much prefer Jeffrey's
position at this point in time and I
think that he can try to make a win
happen it's not going to be easy but
it's strong the position is not like
much better for black yeah from what
happened like six moves ago this is a
dream for black yes we didn't like his
position before you know yeah after we
just thought white was doing great here
and somehow he
you know white played like solid but not
you know he he gave away the E6 Square
by not playing D5 so Jeffrey took
advantage by putting that Knight on E6
and that's a great night it's all about
this D4 square and vidit knows that he's
a very very strong player but something
happened in his mind probably that
thought of the draw looming you know
just lurking there oh I just need to
draw so maybe I should just take here
and it's a bad decision it's an
objectively bad decision and it's
causing him to
uh be in a tough spot but Ben I I wanted
to keep on going around so many
fascinating games right now let's go to
our world champion Magnus Carlson
against radical because I just caught
this position the pawn structure has
changed I don't really love the look of
a bishop on B3 staring into it that is
weird it's on Pawn on C4 but there's a
new Dynamic after the last few moves
which were F4 Knight to B6 that's why
the bishop came back to B3 to defend
upon those under attack
and E5
Knight F5 takes takes and
well I don't really hate Black's
position I must say that uh this Pawn on
C4 Ben can we just go right after it
with Rook C8 no the Magnus is
threatening Pawn C4 to C2 opening up his
Bishop
always Retreat right yeah there we go I
saved my Pawn
um no I mean winning the World
Championship that's easy winning the
World Cup not so easy
the world the World Cup has hundreds of
players and only one person wins it
World Championship 50 50. either you or
your opponent that's why Magnus is
always winning the World Championship
but not winning the World Cup the World
Cup's tough you say that no but
obviously you know two game match shows
there's a lot of luck well you said it
in Jess but honestly winning the
candidates is maybe less likely than
winning the World Championship right
yeah one sort of one famous world
champion Vladimir krumnik he didn't have
to win the candidates Tournament of
course he proved to be in exceptional
world champion I'm not taking anything
away from him but of course there's a
controversy we're sure of but the fact
that he didn't have to go through the
candidates that Gauntlet to play
Kasparov is a real benefit because if
you didn't have the Canon's tournament
someone like levonne aronian might have
been world champion but he just never
could top the field winning the
candidates is tough yeah oh yeah and uh
Jana Palm she won this year and he will
go on to face Magnus in November which
chess.com we'll have exclusive video
feeds on Twitch 4 and it'll be you know
of course the highlight of the calendar
year but uh it's not easy to win an
event like the World Cup and Magnus
himself said it's easier to play the top
guys because I'm used to them and
voytajuk hey he's played many times but
there's so many strong players you're
getting a bunch of different styles and
it's hard to settle in but right now uh
Ben speaking of settling in I'm just
trying to figure out what magnus's plan
is here because Rook C8 seems obvious
and there's a pawn C4 that cannot be
defended and it looks to my eyes that
black just has the
quick activity no black should be happy
with the with the outcome of the opening
and uh
yeah you can see Magnus isn't super
happy there
he's he seems like uh
you know he I mean knowing Magnus too
he's probably thinking uh how do I make
this game a draw so I can beat this guy
in Rapid so that there's no risk
um
because this looks like
you know if I have to pick a side I'm
going to pick black here right and is it
his move because he's sitting there and
Watashi isn't there but I haven't seen a
new move in
so that's what I'm trying to figure out
here yeah if you just look at the board
I mean Magnus looks really concentrated
like he's thinking about a move but our
thing is saying it's black smoke yeah I
mean Magnus looks really serious like
what am I gonna do because the Styles
move that's funny or maybe he made his
move and then he's just waiting for more
time to come back there's a famous story
from uh Dubai uh was it Dubai 86 yeah
um it was it was the famous I think it
was dubai86 it was the game corsinoy
versus Kasparov and a benoni where
Kasparov sacked everything and won
brilliantly at the end
um of course you know I'm missing a draw
near the end of the game in time trouble
yep the the Soviet you know delegation
showed up not not necessarily strong
chess players but you know like the code
you know people who were very good and
they walked into the room and they were
like
oh my God Kasparov has a night hanging
he's down a pond and this and that what
is he gonna do and then they realized a
few seconds later it was questioning his
move
so yeah chess is a tricky game it is and
that was an amazing game the course Roy
uh encounter man now I'm starting to
think it wasn't 86. I think it was 82.
yeah it wasn't 86. it was I think it was
82. I I've changed my story but if
anybody ever sees that game and you
haven't seen it before you'll be amazed
at how freely Kasparov is just
sacrificing everything against such an
esteemed opponent yeah no I mean this
was vintage Kasparov unfortunately the
most recent uh kaspar of Chess we saw
was not vintage kaspara no no he uh was
not in the top level that everyone knows
and loves and we did get confirmation
that the camera was frozen sorry about
the technical difficulties of course
things are happening in Sochi Russia and
their
sometimes the things happen in the
process but we will get that fixed for
you all and yeah Jeffrey Zhang we see
the on the ticker here he made it to the
quarterfinals the previous World Cup he
knocked out in each Geary and he also
knocked out John Christoph Duda if I'm
not mistaken before eventually losing to
Timor rajaval
yeah I just I was white against him
about three weeks ago I never felt I was
in the game it was somewhat embarrassing
usually with white I'm in the game a
little bit Jeffrey's good yeah really
really good chess.com said that he was
never in trouble he had the advantage
from the start and he was black ah I
think when that happens so do I and I
just out of the corner of my eye when I
was glancing at some of the games here
there's a game I want to go to dubov
against yesapanko two fan favorites and
I just noticed how many pieces are on
the D file wow and what is happening who
is winning The Showdown along the D file
here how many pieces are hitting D4
super white and three for black so it's
all defended at least for the moment
yeah right now this looks like it's
going to go into a tie break I think a
lot of Trades are going to happen
most likely although Ben is 95 kind of a
threat here for white
let's say I play H5 is Knight D5 just a
winning move
Knight D5 is good that's pretty tricky
too like Knight takes D5 Rook takes D4
and now we're attacking D5 instead of D4
what happened
he can't move because the Rook on D6
yeah this is immediately winning yeah oh
my gosh so 95 is a threat
and it's just one of these should black
play Knight F5 here or am I falling into
something I like falling into stuff so
Knight F5
looks pretty reasonable is there some
kind of queen B3 at some moment like
just jumping stop checkmating me I'm a
nice guy you are a nice guy but yeah
don't Checkmate me
yeah with 905 is Queen B3 just on the
spot
can you how do you deal with that threat
oh
uh
I'm looking at is This brilliant line
where white sex is Queen and wins
actually that doesn't win I can play 98
at the end
um
I mean you could win 986 but that's
clearly bad I just trade everything on
all right I gotta move but you're gonna
laugh at me what are you gonna say
um yeah that's not good I was gonna just
say take the Rook on D3 what yeah don't
laugh at me I'm going to laugh at you
okay King h8 yeah like G7 then I take
your Rook here right takes takes you
know I was gonna play 98 and I
miscounted the pieces I thought black
had another piece left no I saw this and
I thought it was made that I saw 98 and
then I thought black had a minor piece
somewhere oh I give like a bishop on E5
yeah okay I resign right just to finish
the variation white has a rook Knight
bishop and a pawn for the queen you
could even maybe be down one of those
pieces and still be doing okay a
brilliant Queen Sacrifice by Robert I
love Queen sacrifice I saw all the way
to the end but I miscounted the pieces
yeah
it's happened to all of us before
and so Knight D5 looks like a threat if
the Knight moves there's Queen B3 like
this this idea looks quite menacing
I mean
I'm looking at Knight F5 Queen B3 Rook 8
D7 but it's hard to believe it just
looks terrible
because if I take und6 you have to take
with a knight right and I figured there
was some tricks somewhere but the
engine's not laughing at me yet
it looks very scary wow psychologically
really difficult to play like this but
uh it seems like you're holding on
wow yeah it's really scary I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if if white has a
move the wins immediately but the engine
says he doesn't well I think there are a
bunch of drawing mechanisms for black
where you give up your Rook on D7 maybe
and like have Knight to E4
so like are you gonna Perpetual me A4 94
just something like this where if you
take or take take take you get a free
rook but then Queen takes F2 check
we can now have an ig3 and Knight F1
back and forth as the King has to go on
these two squares and if you say start
with King two H2 I have to check on F4
so if you play G3 you just move the game
[Music]
and you have to get your queen and then
you lose so yeah maybe your move ban as
we
sort of go back but that's scary it's
really scary to to play Knight F5 and
then Rook D7 because you're walking into
all sorts of tactics but it seems like
is holding on
all right apparently mvl sacrificed his
Queen so we will quickly go there uh you
know we were looking a different game
but Maxime
sax is Queen if I can even find his game
there's so many games going on there it
is
oh okay he does not have a queen now
we left off here after Queen D4
King C1
I mean C7 okay it looks pretty normal E5
striking it at this queen here
and I sort of oh first first we try to
trade Queens then we sack Our Queen yeah
as long as there's no Queen he's happy
whoa
say what Knight D5
yeah I understand takes Rick Sierra C2
check all right
looks pretty good if you um you're in
trouble so he didn't sack his Queen okay
I think
I think he had to give up his Queen so
there's a little bit of a difference
here it wasn't the most voluntary uh way
to give up a queen but he had to do it
and honestly once the material count
white has a rook a bishop and a pawn for
Queen Lasker compensation and don't be
taking this Pawn on D5 Prime the blunder
Bishop takes D5 yeah Rook takes D5 he
takes D5 I hate when that happens
skewer
all right that's a pin
either way the queen is lost here and
white is of a piece and just winning the
game so you can't take on D5 and if you
can't take on D5 this Pawn is very
likely to go to D6 in the near future
I'm concerned for prognanda here it
looks like mvo has the upper hand
yeah that's amazing to even see them
with Knight D5
I mean that's such a crazy move because
I found that now I was looking if you
didn't sack his Queen if you played
Queen B5 then I guess you can check and
play Queen E7 check I guess there's
probably maybe there's something better
um and then and then well actually then
I don't know what to do is it Queen E7
looks pretty I guess so the engine
didn't move much and if you go B4
there's Rook C3 check at the very I mean
I'm afraid to have white here yeah I
guess you can play Queen B4 and just
trade off Queens but then everything's
hanging at the end yeah it's a d5's E2
E3
yeah everything probably that's just a
draw because opposite Bishops and could
be even puns I guess
yeah well I feel misled by our wonderful
viewers that was not a queen sacrifice
that was a decision he had to go with
because prognando was on the offensive
either way looking like a chance for
Maxime to score a full point here
perhaps I'm
underestimating's position because he
does have the queen maybe there are some
opportunities for him but for now we are
going to go on another short break when
we return more from games like this at
the fide World Cup and the fide Women's
World Cup
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there are many familiar faces left in
the world cup and some of them are
streamers and commentators that work
with chess.com
up there still fighting it out against
Jeffrey Zhang and in the win section A
number of names including Anna music
who's facing off Elizabeth Pitts you
have Alexandra costenuk the chess Queen
who is very well known to the Chess
World and still trying to add to her
great list of accomplishments but let's
bring up the matchup between Anna and
Elizabeth because they are great friends
they're very close and they have to face
off against one another never a
comfortable thing to have to face off
against a friend but I think that Anna
is a little bit more comfortable right
now given her position with the black
pieces the white king in the center and
it's not super easy to Castle in these
positions it is Black's turn but you
have to look out for this Pawn in H3 as
well
no this is nice the F files opened
blacks completely developed safe King
it's not clear where white skin is going
to be safe or if it ever will
um so yeah white white has a problem
here trying to figure out where the King
on E1 goes but it can't stand E1 the
whole game
um so yeah this is this looks pretty
pretty nice for for black and black has
a nice time Advantage as well
but yeah as you said sometimes it's not
easy it's not easy to play your friend
and uh well sometimes it is easy it
depends depends who your friend is it
depends on their strength right yeah it
might be easy because they're a beginner
right no it's funny when when uh when
Dimitri guravich and and Gregory
kaidanov were you know came to the U.S
um kind enough later you got here in
1991 maybe or 90.
um they were really good friends you
know back in the old country but they
realized right away that if they drew
all their games quickly like a lot of
friends do that they're not going to win
any open tournaments because so they're
like you just got to play against each
other and sometimes it's a draw because
it's a draw and there are people when
they play their friends they just they
don't play they just play a quick draw
and they just don't want to play their
friends but you know in the World Cup
there are no there are no draws because
it's a match and somebody's gonna win
the match so that that's the way it goes
players are professional and they know
that so hopefully there's no bad blood
when when good friends play each other
and you know something happens that one
doesn't like I uh highly doubt that you
hold it against your professional so you
have to play the game in front of you
and the move played with Rook a to E8
which does make sense although I'm
starting to wonder what's that Rook
doing on E8 like what's the purpose of
its placement here uh Rook F7 followed
by Rook to f8 you could have done that
in one if you return perhaps but I guess
white still is struggling to figure out
what to do with the king so if you
Castle kingside here
um Bishop takes H3
looks acceptable right recommended by
shirov yeah and if Bishop takes the H3
Queen H3 Knight takes C7 you're like oh
well it's a pawn trade I didn't just
lose a pawn I would much rather give up
my C7 Pawn to win this H3 Pawn Yeah well
why better be careful not getting
checkmated so yeah yeah actually you
just Rook C8 and where's this Knight
going it has to go back to D5 and once
you take take maybe some kind of Rook
lift at some moment soon it's a funny
move because
it's like encouraging your opponent to
Castle either way you're like hey Castle
King side you'll take my C pawn and
attack my Rook oh no if you cast the
queen side oh no I played rookie eight I
wish my Rooks were on the queen side
right it's sort of like a psychological
Ploy like it encourages white to Castle
maybe into non-safety it's a funny yeah
that's a really good point because
actually after rookie Castle Queens it
does make a lot of sense so just point
out the Rook is no longer on the queen
side where it could help the pawn to
push up the board but perhaps just The
Rook on E8 it's a solid position the
king even though it's not getting
checkmated maybe it's just not as safe
as possible with this A2 Pawn will need
some tending too and I think that black
should have the better position maybe
yeah
so
that looks pretty good yeah I mean it
really just it as you said it yesterday
puts the onus on white to figure out
what am I going to do now because black
made sort of a nothing move but the
Rick's probably better on E8 than A8 so
just like it's your move I dare you to
move yeah and it also defends this
Knight in case you guys get distracted
so it's a useful move and I think your
point bent really really well taken is
just throwing the turn back over to your
opponent and saying Elizabeth you need
to figure out your plan because uh
where's your king gun go if you don't
move your king what other move even
comes to mind here
uh I I'm not sure
yeah I really am struggling to come up
with individual moves for white and so I
think I mean Elizabeth can I mean
Elizabeth she can do little that's
terrible
yeah
so uh it's gonna be tough for her to
figure this out she also is down about
10 minutes and it's only moved 13 and
one more thing actually about friends
playing is there are no draws before
move 30 in this event so you know if
you're playing your friend and you both
have 40 minutes sometimes you're like I
don't know what's going on I offer a
draw here you can't do that and so you
have 36 minutes to make 27 moves good
luck to you that's the most fun you can
have yeah that's a lot of time pressure
so this is looking pretty Pleasant for
an amazing trick let's uh stay in the
women's section go to some of the other
games here uh Paulina shovelova won the
first game against Nana zagnitzi and
that means that Nana needs to win game
two and you see that what
where's Black's Queen
what well there's a they have a rook of
the night for the Rook at a bishop for
the queen there's no way this is
accurate right
no it is yeah
I mean that's that's what happened oh my
God yeah the Queen's trapped yeah oh my
gosh so Knight takes showing Knight D4
so
ah okay I I mean I would I would do that
too I mean I'm not saying I would make
these same moves but I wouldn't see my
Queen's trap because c4's hanging C4 is
hanging but after Bishop takes H6 if you
just take back on H6 I guess after
I mean some kind of queen H5 is going to
happen maybe immediately but you can I
don't know Queen H5 Rook D4 Rook G4
yeah Black's not doing a good job
defending the king there's there's
nothing that's going over there yeah and
so you could lose your queen and you
could get mated it's a two for one and
it looks like this should be H6 is
brilliant it is brilliant and the evil
where I dropped a bit so Rook D1 first
is probably useful the queen only has
one square and then same idea Queen H5
right
this is yeah rookie for the G4 and
Knight E3 to G4 oh gosh yeah that's I
mean there's a lot of stuff coming here
you can either put the Knight on G4 and
the bishop on e4 or The Rook on on e4 to
G4 and take on H yeah I mean the blacks
pieces just aren't defending the king
is a brilliant move I like that move a
lot yeah I mean it's really nice
almost had a false sense of security did
shuvalova right it's that it looks like
a good decision with C4 being under
attack multiple times but it
unfortunately wasn't meant to be because
after Rook C1 she did take on H6 to D1
your queen is trapped and that is why
black is missing a queen and
and it's just over this king is about to
be obliterated yeah but white has an
extra Queen and is better yeah yeah and
I know I've heard you say this many
times right where what's up material and
has the compensation yeah but I still I
still there for me yes sir that's a
stolen joke all my good jokes are stolen
got it but at least you admit it that's
right man I got an email from yesterday
last night so good timing was it about
how you've been taking we're trying to
get some some very strong players to
come to our club and do stuff like you
so we'll talk later you know a Simo
lecture it was actually funny yester
said Silo I haven't given a simul in 12
years
the best part is you didn't speak to him
over the phone or anything but he just
heard His email in his voice oh yeah
yeah yeah whatever he says me anything
it's him talking yeah I can't just read
it normally yeah oh well I was pretty
surprised he hasn't given a similar in
12 years that is surprising yeah let's
uh hop on over to the Magnus game
because oh boy things are happening here
and look at that eval bar skyrocketing
yeah and what happened Rook fe8 was
played instead of Rook C8 so for some
reason footage didn't want to go for the
pawn and I'm guessing it's the same
reason as as it was the game rookie 8 G4
so even if Rook C8 I guess G4 was still
the move that Magnus won to play because
if Knight takes C4 I guess there's some
kind of G5 and this Knight is kicked and
the D5 square and the light squares in
general oftentimes go Queen goes to G2
which takes control of the diagonal
threads F6 and all this good stuff so
wow one rookie eight oops sorry uh
rookie it was played and then G4
and Bishop f8 Queen G2 I mean he just
has everything you could ask for from a
position now he's the bishop pair he has
pressure on D6 he has the pawn going to
G5
that doesn't look good
I feel like
you can't really allow
all this progress been and this is this
looks yeah this looks uh great for white
and I think
Magnus is not unhappy this E4 Pawn is
gone no it's helpful right thank you for
taking that away yeah well G6 comes to
mind this this is like Magnus is playing
the best Smith more ever yeah there's no
C Pawn he's down a pawn he's got two
Bishops he pushed his King side pawns
he's got D5 for his Knight
yeah he's got to be happy here
yeah but Magnus came to play G4 G5
and he always plays the principled line
you know if he he's like okay G4 G5 is
right and it might not be right but he
thought it was right that's what he does
and mvl does that too
everybody I was like this looks right
and then we're like what that's too
crazy and they're like maybe but it's
right
so you know it does make sense to take
over the D5 square but there was also a
knight on B6 and you know this Pawn C4
as you just said it's good that it's
captured now yeah it's like C4 hooked
them up yeah yeah G6 is coming to my
mind first right yeah this is very
difficult no no it it is the is the
camera stuck again because we got we got
oh no it's this White sub move 90 H5
yeah 95 was played yeah
a Magnus should look happier than he
does stop looking so not happy
he looks concentrated and Voit playing
pretty quickly has a you know 13 plus
minute lead on the clock but the
position isn't good however neither
player you know has an eval bar taking
in their head saying oh white is plus
two or plus three or whatever it is so
it's not that straightforward to figure
out even though I'm sure Magnus
recognizes that this is his moment
yeah and I think for votachik he just
like I don't want to get have the black
pieces against Magnus and have one of
those suffocating games he's like here
my knight on C4 is active my rook's
active on yay my opponent pushed all his
Pawns in front of his King I'm up upon
this is a this is a three result kind of
position instead of Magnus is pressing
me I'm clearly worse I'm defending and
probably I'm going to lose in the long
run this this has you know more action
going on and that's probably one he
wanted than just getting suffocated but
Magnus is still trying to suffocate him
yeah that's true and it's easy to see
mistakes happen a position of this
nature as you said three results are
possible we see what the eval bar is
telling us but that does not tell the
whole story because it's a very
complicated position there's no
immediate knockout blow you have to be
certain do I really want to give up this
bishop how is this Knight doing on H5
can I break through on the diagonal or
is B5 just going to cement the knights
placement there is Knight D5 a good move
will Queen C5 check be the response
there's so many different
moves possible in a game of chess and so
even when the Evolve Army may be
screaming saying that Magnus is winning
he doesn't know that and there's so much
to work out chess is a very rich and
complex game so we like Magnus position
Magnus probably likes his position even
if he's not jumping for joy so uh yeah
Ben this is looking very promising yeah
I want to see Magnus jump for joy that
would be funny
oh gosh well this uh game is
I mean I'm looking at G6 I'm really
fixing on it but is there something else
that's possibly better Knight D5 of
course comes to mind but I I like the
look of this The Brute Force approach
that's often why I mess up attacks
though
yeah it like the way I play chess which
is wrong is I'm attracted by a
nonsensical move like King H1 because I
don't want the guy to check me when I
play Knight D5
and
obviously that's not really in the
spirit of the position to just make a
safe move but I do want to get off that
diagonal and potentially if I play G6 I
might want to play Rook G1 true
um but yeah that's the problem is G6
looks good knight D5 looks good and so
you know you don't want to make a
mistake here if you have an advantage
you want to you know press not let the
guy equalize
okay King H1 is generally speaking a
very good move in these Sicilians when
your F Pawn is gone but you need to
operate in the spirit of the positioning
I like King H1 it's one of the moves the
candidates that I've had in mind but I'm
really fixated on The Brute Force I
think he played 95 based on his hand
movement on 95 I can't see I can't see
perfectly yeah he did
and he also you're right though Ben I
think your read of his body language is
is right because he doesn't seem
that at home in this position he he
really seems like he's struggling with
every move thinking uh he specifically
said I don't know if it was a week ago
or it was a long time ago I guess it was
a long time ago he said he wanted to
change his style instead of winning the
smooth games he wanted to play you know
more like you know Alpha zero and
you know play aggressive put pressure on
his opponent get interesting positions
and try to play those well and you know
when you first start doing that it's
it's not easy because Magnus is so good
at being slightly better and squeezing
and giving his Oppo no counter play
positions like this that are more
interesting aren't necessarily his bread
and butter but he wants to get better at
them
so Magnus didn't play King H1 but he
waited until he was checked
and uh you know the knights on D5 and
this yeah it looks really nice for white
the Nugget G5 is great the bishop on f8
is really passive and the Knight on C4
can get pinned and it sort of is pin
because you want to open the bishop G6
is always really annoying so it's very
hard to play Black here yeah and people
often think opposite colored Bishops
draw not when they're attacking chances
and hear the bishop on B3 is so much
better than the bishop on f8 in fact
sometimes you wish that Paul and D6
didn't exist so your Bishop could get
out of there but this is just going to
be a promising position for Magnus who
has left the board he has decided to
take a walk it's now vortacek who's
going to sit and think and it's a
complicated position where I'm not even
sure what the best move is for black one
idea then although I guess I lose an
exchange but I was thinking Knight A5
just to get rid of this bishop but there
could be a rook C1 oh there's not Rook
C1 because Knight takes F4 huh so 985 I
guess is possible
no Rook C1 Knight F4 there's this Rook
takes uh sorry uh Knight
no actually this
I'm confusing myself yeah because if
Knight F4 you can't play your um Knight
C7 although
man I'm getting scared of G6 and Bishop
F7 maybe first I'm just I'm really
scared here yeah this looks really I
mean I I
even if black is okay here in a in a in
a game I would I just I know I'm gonna
lose it with black I'm just gonna get
run over somehow it doesn't look it
looks really dangerous you're playing
down a piece the bishop wanna fade is uh
just stuck here The Rook on AIDS on
helping so yeah I guess you 985 doesn't
look that appealing after all so
maybe oh he can't even stack a queen I
was trying to come up with a queen sack
of Knight A5 Rook C1 Knight takes B3 and
the point being that if you take on C5
the Knight takes back but there's still
the oh there's no Knight C7 because
Knight takes a four
but the engine hates it it's like D5 I
think B5 I think he played it
oh no I'm wrong oh wait maybe I'm not
wrong no he played B5 yeah okay so let's
uh go back to the game no Queen sack
here B5 played makes perfect sense
logical move defending the Knight on C4
yeah you need that Knight to offended
more so that's good yeah geez now he
doesn't get mated he's fine G6 has to be
the move
I'm I'm playing G6 you have to attack
this King
yeah but the threat is stronger than
something
the threat is strong in the execution
but depends on which definition of
execution you're using
and actually eight B5 is a really useful
move because Rook A7 can defend the F7
Pawn so
it's a Multiverse now this might this
might lose in one move but Knight F6
check looks interesting to me
okay so I will take with the pawn
right I take with discover double triple
check
and then I play oh if I play Rook G1 are
you playing Knight takes F6
I think I have to right yeah I was
missing Knight takes F6 I thought I was
gonna win well you were close there was
a Checkmate down the Jeep yeah there was
some good stuff happening
it's always sad no there's no good stuff
happening no there's not I tried and I
failed miserably the lesson is never try
yeah G6 recommended by Hess
he did play G6 yes he did he's going
forward trying to break open that King
and see chess is easy Robert you play G4
G5 G6 and you win
what's the problem it's the the Magnus
yeah just throw your Jeep on forward and
win the game so
oh my gosh these positions are so
difficult for black to even know what to
do
hey when you play the night or if that's
what happens the guy's attacking you and
you gotta defend sometimes in positions
when there's not a bishop on B3 staring
at the diagonal don't you often take
with the F Pawn play H6 and hope that
the position closes like you take here
and it might do it anyway H6 you really
hope that the king can just find shelter
on h8 and maybe you have to do this
I mean positionally this looks really
bad
this looks like Black's King is going to
be in danger until the game ends
even in the end game the king is going
to be bad hey all you have is this extra
Pawn on D6 which that pawn is going to
Queen shortly well maybe not
this does not look good this is the no
fun variation unless you're white and
then it's everything's fun about it um
so but Magus he really is just locked
into the game
but I I honestly don't really see him
sometimes he looks bored disinterested
like looking all around he is extremely
focused and that just tells me that the
position is very complicated and he
doesn't see exactly how he's going to
win this game he probably knows he's
better he has the initiative here the
king will not find shelter as you just
said Ben but where is The Knockout going
to come from that's what he's trying to
Envision he's looking at the score
shooting out trying to figure out if he
can if he's allowed to offer a draw
I think yesterday yeah I don't think
that's happening
well yeah a lot of people were surprised
yesterday that he offered a draw
it was surprising right just yeah Magnus
doesn't do that in positions that aren't
drawn when it's interesting Magnus
doesn't offer a draw that's that was
weird Oh you mean like the last round of
the world championship against karwana
no no not that but yeah I mean obviously
the exception proves the rule yeah
precisely that but but you have to admit
Robert that was very strange I mean the
example you gave was like nobody could
believe it I was angry and then yeah you
know I said yesterday ban the draw I
mean just yeah no I like when because
sparov said frankly ridiculous and then
when the Mansion did Carlson had some
Choice words for for people who didn't
like his draw offer no you know he
proved that you know he was going to win
that way and he was trying to optimize
his chances and it's nothing against him
I have Magnus is amazing great
Ambassador for the game and an amazing
amazing world champion it's just that in
general the draw for I think it deprives
Spectators of understanding the game
better and also just the entertainment
of seeing a game come to its conclusion
not just by agreement but by what
happens over the board
well he's making up for it this game
he starts playing like a beast he
certainly is and maybe as the Beast was
for him not for audible I don't know
just reclaim the username I have the
username the nickname and let's uh go on
over to the game with Maxine Russell
Grove and prognananda because we saw
what people were saying was a queen
sacrifice I think that he was kind of
forced into it it still looked like a
good position for white but let's head
on over there where oh that pawn is now
on D6
Bishop takes on G2 so you steal a pawn
and the evaluation gets worse for you
that's not a good sign yeah it's
pandemonium over here
um I like that pawn on D6 I like the two
Bishops and black just seems like he's
he's flailing but it's probably the
nonta so he he's gonna have some tricks
the Bishops are lined up to be attacked
by like Queen E4
um black King's not a good Square
because Bishop C4 check is always going
to save White
and the D6 Pawn is annoying and
sometimes white gets an attack with like
Rick G1 Rick C7 so we got to be careful
with black
so there's there's some there's some
issues here for for black and
yeah this this queen quote unquote
sacrifice seems uh very reasonable for
white I was always told Ben that when
you have a past pawn put a rook behind
it so Rook G1 is very interesting I'm
just gonna work D1 yeah go to D1 and say
let me try to promote this Pawn here not
going to be easy because the bishop can
come back to C6 let's say I didn't want
to go to H3 because I prefer to stay on
the diagonal where my queen and my Rook
are I don't want to suffer a miserable
fate so Bishop C6 seems like a move but
yeah white is having all the fun here
yeah this looks uh very very unpleasant
for black
pieces are inactive and then deep one's
really strong and
yeah he doesn't really have any counter
play yet The Rook on A8 is is struggling
to get active
even if it does go to a square like f8
eventually where are you going with that
you don't have any access into the
position the Bishops are too strong and
you always have to be attentive to
whites pass Pawn this looks great for
Max I think he's gonna win this game
it seems like it so far but it's I never
count out the young tricky opponents
so that's smart never count them out but
yeah mvl is I mean
he hasn't been top 10 in the world
forever for nothing
yeah that is true yeah whenever I win a
game which is very rare but when I do
Aviv always tells me you you didn't get
your your GM title in the mail you like
at the you know play well and I was
thinking but I did get in the mail so I
don't know that's the joke I was gonna
make yeah or he said you didn't get your
GM title in the lottery yeah like you
actually had to earn your GM title and I
was like what so yeah you sent me that
winning the lottery isn't the result
that sounds like a good way to earn it
yeah it's tough figuring out the right
numbers so
very difficult and let's um keep on
going around for some of these games
here it looks like Maxime in great shape
right now and just one more game to keep
an eye on is the game between our temmie
event cardiac and we haven't even looked
at it and maybe there's a reason for
that because artemia is just slightly
better with white there's a nice set of
Pawn but karyakan is the Minister of
Defense and yeah he'll hold us easily
while all of us mere Morse would suffer
now this will hold it easily but yeah I
would be more surprised if you lost than
he drew yeah drawing is the most likely
result
but Robert wants to have white go rob it
I'm always trying to play against the
isolated Pawn with it and
it seems like his position is nice but
for now Ben and I are going to take a
short break we will look deeper into
positions like this when we return in
just a few for more from the fide World
Cup and the fide Women's World Cup stay
tuned everybody
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Champs is back the fourth edition of
everybody's favorite tournament
featuring streamers and other
celebrities is coming your way August
29th some of the most popular faces
including Mr Beast Ludwig and others
will be playing chess the tournaments
presented by coinbase and you will not
want to miss out on any of the actions
stay tuned for that that will be taking
place starting the end of August but
right now we need to focus on well the
end of something unfortunate looks as
the end of Maria music's tournament
because Alexandra kostenyuk the chess
Queen is absolutely dominating this
position with the black pieces you see
the eval bar has sunken and white has
two Rooks for three minor pieces Ben not
a material imbalance we see every day
but it's blacks attack should lead her
to Victory it's funny that this material
imbalance exists because I mentioned
yesterday very briefly uh wait was it
today
well it was today I mentioned the move
Knight A2 that we were talking about in
one of those grenfeld games yep and I
said yeah like my game with vanderstein
and in that game I had two Rooks against
three minor pieces and an end game and
man did I get crushed my Rooks had
nothing to do the engine said it was
equal and I lost without a fight I mean
I couldn't do anything my Rooks couldn't
move
so I I like three pieces better than two
Rooks because of my own experience but
obviously here I mean Black's pieces are
great black cider is great
um Black's King is safer and you know
when there's an attack going on the
minor pieces are are just as good as the
Rooks The Rook on A1 does nothing the
Rooks One open files and
because of my bad experience I I like
three pieces better than two rocks and
have you had a bad experience in three
pieces versus two Rooks I I wasn't clear
on that it seems like yeah exactly some
trauma you need to it was terrible yeah
yeah these positions are I mean very
nice for black although The Knockout
isn't that easy to spot but let's just
go back a few moves to see how this
happened uh as if we just go around here
it looks like an extremely composition
not much going on you're like how did
this turn into that well let's see what
customers did she'd move your knight
back she moved her King to h8 a very
smart move getting out of the pin so you
can play Pawn to F5 and after 94
she did in fact
uh just remove her Retreat to say her
pieces but this G4 push not bad is the
eval says that white is still doing well
but it's a risky choice and here it
comes in a moment here G5 gone all out
for the attack and look at this move Ben
F5 ignoring the fact that this is
attacking H6 and all that stuff just let
me push my pawns that's an easy move to
miss if you have the white pieces you're
not expecting that no you are not
because wait black just gave me a pawn
H6 is under attack two different times
but after GTX H6 G takes H6 thank you
for the opening of the G file as well so
it's white king that is in grave danger
and you see the eval bar just sinking
there and Rook G8 Queen F6 here there's
one Rook that's how this one was lost
and where did the second one go uh right
there Rook takes G5 and the reason why
two Rooks one for each of you yeah the
reason why Bishop G5 was played as F4 it
works down the line here on this pin and
White's King is in just big trouble so
we saw this happen and trying to run
with the King but you're only getting so
far Knight G4 threatens a fork if you go
King E2 you're probably just walking
into E4 and Knight to E5 and bring more
pieces to the party
no it was very unpleasant for white and
not only that the time really shows that
she's she's done a lot of time also so
it's look it's looking bad
looks great for black
so it looks great but how to make this
game decisive how do we end this game
because if the game continues for a
while you said the Rooks need some open
files maybe the Rooks will be able to
get into the game and not just defend
the king but turn the tables
yeah I'm looking at trying to play
um in tandem Queen F4 and Bishop C5 to
hammer that pawn on F2 well you can just
defend it
another idea is to try to get that
Bishop on H7 into the game and the
problem with playing F4 is the the
Knight can go to E4 otherwise that would
I guess that would have said in the game
right
um I'm looking at I mean there's some
tricks here like you can play F4 F3 and
you can't take it because of Knight H2
but you know you can just move your
queen somewhere else right yeah also the
Queen's attacked on G5 so enough nothing
works none of my ideas ever work but
your point is still will take you to
take with the pawn here yeah yeah F free
doesn't doesn't uh win immediately
although the engine says it wins
immediately all of your ideas combined
probably Rook takes E4 was better than
Bond takes exactly I I just wanted to
show you up there yeah it was you didn't
have to say it come on yeah because F3
that wouldn't work because the yeah
never play F3
you do say that quite regularly yeah
wait no F4 is my move right it's still
no that was my stupid bro yeah no I
meant to move I made of the analysis
sport yeah I'm refreshing this so it's
not it's not easy to win but now what
about if I play very aggressively with
Queen D2
maybe it's too aggressive yeah
pretty good though you're hitting this
pawn and the B2 Pawn Yeah I was yeah I
was trying to play aggressive
what if
that doesn't look good I'll say what if
rookie too but you just take D3 and yeah
I don't know what to do with white but
the engine didn't like Queen D2 but it
seems like a natural you know
attack everything
maybe there's Knight E4 wow because if
you take I get G4 and then my queen is
just jump into the game and if I take on
D3 with check I might hang over you're
just like I don't you don't care you
just you got an id4 in yeah the good
thing about losing pawns for those of
you who blundered pawns yeah open files
yeah and the Queen on G5 was protecting
the Knight so that that led Knight a94
become a possibility
yeah
I feel like you look at this position
you uh see the eval bar you're like oh
just oh E4 was played she played E4 yeah
okay I'm saying it seems easier when the
eval barge tells you that's winning but
that looks like a pretty good move yeah
she wants access to the E5 Square she
wants her Bishop to get open she wants
to open up that King she also wants to
clog the square and use your idea bin F4
yeah
not my idea but yeah it was your idea no
but I mean the idea of E4 and F4 usually
see white doing in a benoni yeah that's
G5 and F5 and I really like this because
there's no 94 and if your knight moves
somewhere else like Knight F5 then F3
Ben's idea of being that if Queen F3
this Knight H2 check with a nasty Fork
man E4 is pretty um accurate yeah
this is I mean Alexandra has had many
great games she's a former women's world
champion
this is an exceptional game
so yeah this is great she's sacrificed
the pawn on H6 she sacrificed on GA and
now she's continuing to go forward
see this is the composition I like for
black because I I always say always sack
The Exchange she ticked she sacked two
exchanges and got a free piece of it for
her troubles so I gotta like black
and just you know she's also keeping up
the pressure sometimes people get a
position they know they're doing well
they feel it but then they hesitate a
little bit and that allows the opponent
to get back in the game E4 says No Rest
for you you only have 17 minutes 45
seconds counting down your king is in
trouble nowhere to go to uh the bishop
now is opened up from D6 the E5 square
is uh jumpable and I can just hop in
there so this might be
no I mean blacks minor pieces are active
and white Strokes are not so
it's very good for black great game from
uh costoneck so far right so we'll see
if she's able to convert this which it
looks like she will it's a really great
position a great game by her thus far
but let's keep on going here in the uh
women's section there's the game between
and stefanova goresta needs to win that
game and she has the white pieces we saw
it earlier or here this looks great for
white I'm looking at this D6 Square oh
gosh
this Pawn on C4 is bad
I guess Black's temporarily up a pawn
but temporary is the key part of that
phrase
yeah if black puts her Bishop on D5
which looks good that gives away the F5
Square Knight F5 Rook G3 so I don't know
if I probably got to keep control of F5
and I'd have five Rook G3 looks too good
although Knight H5 Rook G3 doesn't look
so good also good maybe maybe even
better yeah because you have because you
have Knight F6 also yeah oh gosh this
looks very unpleasant for black
and the time situation up 20 plus
minutes for goryoshkin it looks like she
will be able to take this one home and
even up the score
yeah she needs to win today and it looks
like she's doing a good job
absolutely let's uh you know I was
complaining like an hour ago about the
bishop on C8 but it still hasn't moved
and maybe it won't move uh though you
have to right you just can't leave it
there
yeah this is this is really tough for
black uh looks pretty much losing at
this point
um
going to bring our attention just you
know quickly staying here go around some
games boxes really and gunina
um this game
it looks really locked up Galena
actually likes these slot positions with
the double pawns you reference this
variation yesterday and you just can't
play E4 very easily when all of Black's
pieces are staring at that square
yeah somebody who plays the chagoran a
lot I'm forced to like black here but I
actually do like black so
it's just a really nice position because
yeah white can't do the one thing you
want to do and
I mean Black's better
yeah I mean strategically white can't
get the moves in that she wants to play
and black black has white tied down it's
not easy for black to continue doing
something but white feels the pressure
of being so passive right
you kind of I mean black and Shuffle
black can sort of move a bunch of pieces
here you can play B5 you can actually
get active on the side of the board uh
this doesn't look very fun so gunina
Drew game one with the white pieces with
black she's looking like she's the upper
hand this this game here between Zhang
Yi and Sarah saidat
she
white looks better the pawn structure is
awkward for black
this actually looks really nice for
white
I don't know how much better though
well I I'm required to like white for
two reasons well three reasons because
F6 was played F6 Bishop F1 and C4 is
explosive okay yeah no I don't like F6
and uh I don't like the pawn structure
on the queen side for black
so yeah I like white here a lot
yeah this looks really nice connected
pawns yeah I don't like Black's position
here not that terrible for black but
she's just gonna be worse than trying to
struggle to survive and there's another
game here look at this one why is oh
didn't
no I'm sorry
I think them or didn't update as much as
I would like give me a second Let me
refresh here
and yeah there's a rook a black Rook on
each one in this game
I just assumed it was a white wow
I wasn't seeing that yeah I just saw
like a black Rook on each one and I I
guess white is better according to the
eval bar but there's a rook here
that's amazing
I'm amazed that White's better
what's the material count it is a rook
for a knight and two pawns this Rook is
really active on the cellar in fact you
can just steal the pawn E7 right now if
you want it
but actually can black just like try to
Checkmate white some out
foreign
have white here but I could see if
Black's scary play doesn't doesn't pan
out that okay White's a lot of Pawns
ahead but it's very scary no fear from
uh I mean I'd be afraid of like you know
Rick A1 or
Rook A8 or Rook B8 or I mean I'm just
afraid that uh if black gets a couple of
moves and it's over
yeah it's a very scary position but yeah
the engine's not scared no and nor is
asabeva she's just having a good one
yeah this is this is the Eminem version
he's not afraid yeah
all right so let's go to because
literally everybody and they're
incessant they're begging and normally I
just ignore people in the chat but let's
go yeah that's a good thing to do let's
go over to mbl's game by the way Federal
save is just completely winning as a
point
yeah fedo save is rolling over his
opponent with huge time advantage and
huge position advantage
wow the pawn got to D7 that's a good
Square
yeah that looks just easily winning
let's see yeah there's there's several
problems that black has that aren't just
involved in cleaning the pawn is if we
check if the king ever goes to H7 we
have Bishop D3
um so yeah that's white has a lot of
threats
the King goes H7 you see Bishop D3 so
Prague takes the vision I don't even
understand why the evaluation bar isn't
isn't off the chart why I can still see
a little black there at the top
yeah I'm just can I ask you the queen
that's that's what I would do
um
it's an extra Rook right
yeah
yeah this is
just completely winning so I mean I I
can also take the rook and have an extra
Rook I don't know it seems yeah it looks
like everything wins
but there's the queen yeah I feel like
just a couple more moves and then this
game concludes because hey black just
sacrificed to Queen now white has a
queen and you didn't so
you know this Knight D5 move maybe
you know prognanda was relying on it as
a way to get that material imbalance but
Maxine was not at all unhappy to give up
his Queen get that past Pawn the past D
Pawn was tough get a new one yeah
I used to call that the kramnik past
Pawn because in the grinfeld when
kramnik was white he always got to pass
deep on and he won
so I call that once it when it's a deep
blonde that's the cram neck fast Pond
well that's a crime to Queen then
because that pawn that's right yeah it's
gone to the other side and yeah Maxine
is completely winning at this point and
we had
his compatriot Maxine as that is I'm
which unfortunately for the youngster
that means it's the end of his
tournament so for everybody watching you
know just nothing but deserved respect
for probably Nanda he's you know a great
talent a youngster from India just like
nihal sarin these youngsters teenagers
are really gookesh ronak sedwani so many
talented players from India and well
unfortunately for Indian fans probably
not his tournament is over so
yeah black against mvl is not the
easiest pairing ever no
anybody
credits of Maxine he had a tough tie
break where he beat paravian and
Armageddon and he makes it through to
the next round of the world's cup so
let's uh go away from this game it's
over how about this one between kovalev
and fedosev it's almost done
look at photos how come everybody's down
to Queen Robert is this the round you
lose your queen it must be but fedo Sam
has more than an hour remaining and 30
seconds for kovalev and that's Etienne
bakrow on screen there
he needs a draw to go through what what
game was that what's happening black one
oh that's the Pharaoh Sam game
is it the federal save game
this is the photo save game that we have
I mean yeah there oh because black one
yeah it's fed of yeah yeah okay so that
that game just ended all right so fed
wins yeah that's scary when a guy beats
you like that he doesn't use any time
and beats you with black like it was
nothing yeah let's uh let's go to the
game on screen here between Buck Crow
and pancrotov and well Crow one with
white in a crazy game and looks like
pancrata is trying to do the same and
the material count is
even somehow yeah it's even somehow
right
I can't count that but I think there are
actually some problems for it this this
and this with all these pieces on the
same diagonal if you play Bishop E5 Pawn
takes Queen takes I believe Bishop C5
just Mets quite some material here
and that's not good news for uh buckrow
especially where all of these past pawns
on the queen side for white well
pay dividends
that's that's actually a nice trick that
that's why you can't take on E5 although
I guess white would have good
compensation anyway the dark squares
look at the last event it was Rook B4 so
I think look at this look at the Evo bar
yeah level now lets them play 95. that's
nice he walks right into it was unseen
oh what's going on here
let's let's show that same time on the
camera wait what's happening right so
what is happening it's cindarov and pure
Rune yeah yeah yeah
what the I look like the Arbiter made a
move I hope it was good
I wonder if there's a three-time
repetition claim or something of the
sort or maybe a draw for that before
move 30 let me try to find that did they
repeat recently that seems more likely
it repeated moves yeah
they repeated moves and I can just show
you the moves that were made yeah yeah I
want to see because I'll I'll be the
judge of that
so I guess this position
and repeating and if you are cindarov
you're worse with black so you know if
you don't repeat maybe you just lose so
you know what I think that's why the
Arbiter made the move I think the guy
said I'm going to play Knight C5 and I
claim a draw with that because you can't
actually make them move and hit the
clock and claim the draw
I think that's what happened right so he
told the Arbiter I'm gonna make this
move and that's three times and the
Arbiter is going to track it yeah and
yeah and then it's it's true it's going
to be three times so
and it's gonna be three times yes so the
the result is in the both task for
piorin goes through to the next round
here and no tie breaks in four rounds
wow polish Grandmaster not the one you
may expect but he is the one that is on
his way to the next round uh voitacek
struggling as Carlson and Duda in an
intense match against puya yidani so
Castro purein could in fact be the only
polish player left let's go back to the
Carlson game what has happened last week
G6 was played Rook hated B8
oh my gosh you see that evil bar yep
it's stopping all the Knight C7 tricks
but it's a little slow
I mean bringing the king out looks
pretty good
although yeah and you were thinking with
B5 he might try to play Rook A7 at some
point yeah as opposed to Rook B8 yeah
Rook A7 seemed like a nice way to defend
the seventh rank but he went Rook B8 and
I'm guessing taken on the seven Dragon
the king out when I say the eval bar go
up and up and up I'm looking for
something over here
but I don't know what it was
you know the king doesn't look happy
here but this isn't right he didn't take
on F7 I think he already did something
else I think he wanted to
keep the pressure so in Rook D1 yeah and
we're at this position after rookie five
which still looks good for white
but black is fighting that Rook on E5 is
excellent this Knight is a little bit
loose the B8 Rook comes to E8 and
yeah he wanted to play Rick rookie five
and that's why he moved his Rook off of
A8 so there's no night check and queen
takes AAA
yes he wanted to play rookie five
earlier but he couldn't
that's a good point The Rook in the
corner was under attack from this queen
here
so Knight F6 check let's see if we can
see the clocks okay more time for black
man it's not easy you're the world
champion you're the only one who's 2800
the engine says you're doing great and
you're still suffering yeah
he wants to win he wants this is tough
yeah it really is and you know looks
like there should be some kind of
knockout and a couple moves ago
apparently there was Anderson go back to
that moment again after Rook 88. so
takes takes I just don't see
where The Knockout will come from one
idea is F6 right never play F6 but when
you're attacking that's only for black
yeah white can play F6
a G6 and I don't see what next
we have that pawn F6 looks good it does
but but this is why Magnus played Rook
D1 he wanted to move his Queen up there
I think and you know with the point on
F5 he couldn't play Queen G5 because the
night swinging would check
yeah he's trying to just solidify his
Knight on D5
yeah but sometimes you have that one
moment where you have the force twin and
if you miss it and keep improving your
position it goes away but still I'm
gonna take white here it just seems
absolutely really nice position for
white he played Rook H4
okay she's trying to take on F7 and you
know H7 is
hanging you can always take on F7 here
H6 probably just results in a losing
position and yep take oh yeah give Queen
G6 a check yeah Queen G6 wins
immediately yeah
to finish the variation Knight F6 and
queen H7 made so that's just game over
and if not for H6 how are you dealing
with all these threads
oh is the threat
that that also looks good oh my gosh
like rookie eight trying to go down to
E1 but not a six check yeah if you take
here
and then you made on G8 next week yeah
can black play like you and play FG and
H6 that you suggested earlier is there
time for that
and then this because you suggested this
a few moves ago but demon engine doesn't
like it yeah the openf file would worry
me Queen yeah
just get my queen here and then Rook
takes H6
oh gosh
no fun
no fun at all
it looks like White's having fun
yeah that's true black on the other end
isn't I just want to show the end of the
variation th8 the queen wants to
get to H7 with Checkmate the Pawn's in
the way so you take this one only move
and that is
a Checkmate by force so ouch
yeah yeah I mean if you can't play FG
and H6 and you can't play H6 what am I
supposed to do Rook takes F5 maybe yeah
that looks not good either though
all right
nothing takes F5 wow I'm stopping
negative six and now six yeah yeah yeah
so if I go Rook F5
nope
don't do that oh there's probably just
Rook H7 Rook h8 Queen H3 Queen that's a
threat yeah
that doesn't look very fun
no
well fun for White is you know right
yeah yeah but there must be a move where
the temperature is not going up and
Black's resigning we just can't find it
no I think this looks
I guess there might be one but this yeah
we're to the H file a very blunt G4 G5
G6 Rook H4
I mean
he makes it look so easy
yeah who knew Jessica would just be
played this way well
what do you think about Queen takes D5
Ben
what do I think about it yeah
um
thinking's not my strong suit
but you you get rid of the Knight
because there's always rookie one check
so you give her an exchange and at least
you're not made it
I mean it looks lost but yeah maybe
that's the only thing you can do
oh just to show everybody the point was
if Rook takes those are you blundered
but rookie one check and you have to
block with your queen and this is the
type of position we're looking for where
white is up an exchange now this is
winning for white yeah definitely
winning for white he's looking for it
but it's not good yeah it might be the
best move this is so bad if you
the thing is it may objectively be the
best move but practically speaking it
just seems like it's gonna be an easy
win for magnets so
yeah but you find a move where I didn't
resign right away I I couldn't find one
of those
oh gosh
it looks terrible
wait someone's like a queen takes D5
white actually has to take with the
queen on D5
why would you have to take with the
queen
uh because if Rook takes D5
I'm still confused why this also looks
good
I don't know maybe people are just
saying things
never believe the chat that's the lesson
I believe in the chat except for one
thing now that's that's my favorite chat
of the day you're not gonna like it
Robert
can we see the carwan again
climbing game up
oh boy come on Then followed by can we
see the car game yeah I think what we're
gonna have to do since we can't show you
those games we're gonna show one of the
surprising players of the event Beth
Harmon
he even talks about her a lot how could
we forget to mention exactly yeah well I
don't want to forget any player there's
so many good games let's go back to the
game between
because that did not look very good for
vasifin oh it looks even worse now yeah
so winning On Demand with black not easy
but it's easier when your opponent plays
E5 on the 10th movement no this just the
Bishops
Bishop pair hanging out easy play for
black and uh just just every move was
easy look at this bishop pair and now
your opponent has an isolated Pawn it's
one of those games where dirt Bailey
after the game you just smack your head
and like I'm supposedly a grand master
and I got a much much worse position
after like 15 moves with white and I
played terribly throughout so now can I
sue him for copyright infringement being
a grand master and having a terrible
position after 10 15 moves that's that
he can't steal my ideas like that come
on hey you know I think uh it's fair
game
but this is just bad remains bad let's
see Bishop V8 we don't want to trade on
D5
and
take any four so black is up a pawn
although
I see what White's doing here
you're just trying to create some
threats
along the last rank I was never a
Checkmate the king could run away so
yeah this has been this is really not
good
you guys assume he's gonna play if King
D2 will play Rick ce5
and that's yes
don't look good for white and if you
take on C6 thinking you're getting a
pawn here this check take this fish up
The Rook takes back and then
I take this Pawn here then this is a
thread this Pawn's weak at this Pawn
Yeah V1 check is annoying yeah just
I mean white has drawing chances but
yeah Black's gonna win
yeah don't remove some time control so
this will go into the next
time period but it's just so good for
black too easy hey can we look at uh
shanklin's game because I thought his
opponent was doing well but Drew Abaya
didn't have any time on his clock but
it seemed like he um
yeah things have actually turned around
yeah black had a good position like five
moves ago yeah it was looking good for
jumabaya with The Blacklist
bad Pawn structure for white we keep
seeing this blonde structure what's
going on okay but this looks really good
for black yeah the engine likes black we
like black but he's playing so slowly
Rook takes C3 free pawns are not good
no such thing as a free Pawn the eval
bar dropped as soon as he took yep so
I'm guessing Knight F6 and just
developing was better yeah I mean
because the night on G8 work on h8 are
ridiculous yeah
Bishop c ah The Rook kind of got there
the 64 is a good move yeah second Pawn
taken and he just castles
yeah I mean white has really good
compensation now yeah but especially now
before yeah yeah Rook is under attack
Rook is under attack so let's save our
Rook at least win a pawn for our
troubles and then take C2 and okay good
luck winning this game as black
you know it's not out of the question
though you have the two-on-one majority
on the queen side so that does leave
black with some real chances to try to
create a past pawn and win this game so
maybe I spoke a little soon by the two
minutes been for human biov that can't
be helpful
no I like white anyway but yeah I guess
uh Black's Black's definitely not losing
but uh I wouldn't want to have a must
win for black here I would I would pick
uh
position instead
I mean fair to say I've had a must draw
I mean drawing wins and he plays like a
maniac and wins easily I I don't I
barely understand what's happening there
but that's he can't he can't play for a
Droid doesn't know how it's impossible
yeah photo save
he's a beast
um let's uh
go away from this game it is looking
like Sam Shanklin has
managed to withstand the pressure and
shouldn't move on to the next round the
game between har Krishna and tabatavai
we really like hard Christian's position
before now I don't like it quite as much
I still prefer White's position
obviously because you have a knight
against a bishop why is that good this
Knight can eventually hop to dark
squares the bishop will not be able to
counter it but the issue is that on the
queen side these pawns are under attack
if you ever played B4 then I play Bishop
C4 check
and your night's not getting out of
there yeah
yeah it's pretty sad actually
and The Rook comes here and maybe white
loses
I mean everybody's there's so many
surprising players this tournament
who's on camera right now yeah that's
what I was wondering
is that on Drake
yes yes that is a yeah he played a
French defense and they castled opposite
sides
yeah so if you see something like that
that's right that is undraken yeah
whoa what is this position yeah yeah the
castle Domino's yeah yeah this looks
like what was going on okay so ivich is
the upset King he yeah you know what I'm
saying beat Paco Vallejo he
just knocking everybody out and here he
is trying to
take down Dimitri on draken after being
Matthias bluebound in the previous round
as well yeah because I looked at this
game earlier when we were off camera and
the engine's like Black's doing fine but
I was worried because it looked you know
suspicious and now it looks really
suspicious blacks have a pawn though Ben
oh okay in that case let me change my
tune I mean obviously always play knife
at five and always play Bishop f8 these
are the only things that matter always
play King B1 all these all these moves
will be played it's true
um
losing in two games is good looks like
it's possible the first game was a draw
it was and he is in big trouble right
now this is not very good well you
mentioned casting on opposite sides I
actually have had some games like this
it can be very scary for black to face
the attack and he allows the capture on
F6 which in some positions you do allow
but D5 it's a thematic
Pawn sack Knight H4 and here come all of
White's Pieces Just into the attack
Rook d8 Queen H5 and F5 took on F5
because this relationship is
and and Ben it's why you always looking
to be one because if the king were not
on B1 there'd be a bishop F4 check and
then the bishop would be defended but
because the king wouldn't be won he took
on A2
takes Queen G5 check
okay white is not going to make a draw
you can make one if you
just repeat moves but of course that's
not going to happen
again white is a nice time Advantage
also
yeah yeah and Dimitri Andrea will be
very happy if he draws this
but yeah I didn't lose this game yeah
this looks terrible and why it's not
even down material usually you have to
be down a pawn or two to get this kind
of attack
and you have the Knight against a bishop
in the end game you can use your knight
in the light squares or if all the major
Pieces come off Ben I could say this
King just going right to C4 winning the
game yeah then on F5 and the King on h8
isn't uh isn't so good for black yeah
white has all the advantages here it's
look looking good
it really is uh well we're being
informed that we likely will get
interviews soon uh the players are
taking
um additional PCR tests and things like
that so let's uh hop out of here for a
quick break and when in return we'll
cover more of the action hopefully have
some of the players for interviews stay
tuned everybody for more from the feed
day World Cup and they feed a women's
world cup under return
foreign
[Music]
there's new merch available on the
chess.com store go to
go.chess.com merch and use the code
World Cup all in one word to get 10 off
on all chest.com products you can get
the sweater the shirts you see in front
of you or anything else that you want do
not miss your chance it'll be available
throughout the remainder of the World
Cup
do get on that but for now we are going
to have to talk about Ben this huge
missed opportunity from Magnus Carlson
he played the last move Bishop back to
C2 rather than playing Rook takes H7 and
you see the eval bar take a swim a nice
dip down there after Bishop C2 was
played so Ben how can you explain Max's
decision to retreat the bishop rather
than to take the pawn I think um
Magnus thought that both moves won and
he thought this move was better but
maybe he underestimated
um the move that was played Queen F2
um which I understand
uh but but my question actually isn't
that my question is what did Magnus
think black was going to do after Rook
H7 I mean because you're threatening
Rook h8 mate so like
if he thought if he saw Rook H7 and saw
Bishop C2 why did he think this the
bishop C2 was more winning
I don't I don't even see what black does
here maybe this Pawn G6 Queen G6 Rook
takes D5 where if you don't see a direct
Checkmate you might start thinking
you're in trouble but
yeah I don't see an actual make here
I'm wondering if if you can sack The
Rook with Queen E6 and Bishop C2
I'm not saying you can I'm just
wondering if you can that's pretty darn
good to me I mean I'm scared well first
of all the Rooks yeah yeah I was just
yeah Rick takes yeah there's mates
everywhere
no I don't know why um
Magnus obviously saw Rook H7 I'm just
wondering what he thought Black's
defense was
I don't I don't really see a defense
that makes any sense
and there was also something better you
know not easy to spot but something was
even better after Rook takes D5
maybe just move the Rook to G1 or
something
that does seem oh Rook F1 threads Rook
takes f8 check that might be this
and there's so many possibilities here
so many variations right it's easy to
sit back and have it I'm just thinking
Magnus thought they both won and Bishop
C2 was easier and he underestimated and
or overlooked Queen F2 I don't know yeah
I think he missed Queen F2 I think he
just missed it yeah possible and the
reason why is Bishop C2 Queen F2 is
played now he's been thinking for quite
a while right so that leads me to
believe he just really it wasn't on his
radar the question is if if black
doesn't play Queen F2 is there any other
move that hangs on because if you miss
queen F2 then his Bishop C2 is
understandable because
he did he didn't see anything black
could do here
I don't see anything else besides I mean
yeah so maybe he underestimated or
overlooked Queen F2 I don't know
wow it's all it's always tough it
doesn't matter if you're winning or the
world champion you're white yeah chess
is just tough
I'm trying to figure out Ben how maybe
Magnus can play on from here because
first of all you're rattled that you
just Overlook something and it should
have been a winning position but his
attack still seems to have some Force to
it
can I take on F7
can I start with that move this seems
like the kind of position if White's
attack doesn't work which it probably
should he could actually get in trouble
right I mean you can't just give all
your pawns away b2's hanging and
G6 is hanging and if flax forgets the
seventh rank the seventh ranks hanging
so
I mean but white has to prove something
here
I wonder what he's gonna do so take on
F7 how to even take back do you do that
it looks like
where'd he go I thought he made a move
but his clock is running
what yeah and
I don't think he made a move but no that
might have been earlier it was a
flashback it was like he wrote something
down but you can't wrote down damn I
suck and then Vara Kobe and said forfeit
him and the driver was like yeah
now that's a reference wow uh oh gosh
won't get into that but uh it looks like
Sasha grishuk and Anton Corbett Drew
their game it was not that exciting to
be frank and so they will go to tie
Break Sport which will be exciting
between grishup one of the best players
in the world three-time world Blitz
champion and Anton corabov who is I
think like
2800-ish in Bliss chess and he gets
invited to as a wild card to some of the
grantchester events he's really an
awesome speed test player in addition to
being a classical
star himself
so Magnus still thinking down to six
minutes Ben that's what move number is
it Robert it is move 25. it's just
Blackstone that's not a lot of time in
this position no it's not so I'm really
focused on G takes F7 because the King
has to take so I'm at least dragging the
king out into the open and if I take on
F5 Queen takes H4
like this King isn't that safe locks up
a couple pawns but that's what you get
when you play the night or if you get
your King on F7
these things happen
it's really concerned it's hard to
believe that he can just take time out
and play Rook B8 and not lose I mean
it's it's I mean like your baby me okay
Rick ba go mate me
well he's probably should have lost and
on a different day Magnus would have
punished him but right now
voitacek is
really in this game and we saw earlier
right Ben and we were looking at the
player's body language even when Magnus
had a very good position he seemed so
focused like you know he was trying to
use every ounce of energy to get that
Victory and maybe just something isn't
on for him today it's just not his and
again this isn't this isn't the Magnus
style we've known for the last 10 years
he's trying to change his style to play
well in these positions you know he's
down material black has counter play
he's trying to meet his opponent
it used to be his opponent couldn't move
material was equal Magnus was squeezing
you Magnus had more time on the clock
Magnus was confident but now Magnus you
know has to prove his attack because
he's done some material and is there any
time on his clock
so it's no it's not it's not it's not
the old Magnus it which was the young
Magnus it's the new Magnus play
aggressive attack
it's hard to do it when you when it's
not your bread and butter you've done
your whole life
yeah he seems out of sorts and these are
moments where you've just made a huge
mistake and you realize it now you're
like wait can I at least Force something
can I force a draw so I don't lose this
game because he's the heavy favorite in
tie brick so yeah he would rather just
make a draw at some point and then head
to tomorrow's action then risk losing he
is down two full Pawns
is is time situations very bad
it is
F7
that was weird he picked up his water
bottle and they looked like he was gonna
drink and then he made a move holding
his water bottle yeah and now he's
taking a drink
King F7 immediately
right putting the pressure back on
Magnus
Magnus puts his water back
yeah he's just uncomfortable now
magnus's positions fine but this isn't
what he was hoping for
not at all it's it's fine according you
know to the silicon beast but to the
players themselves
still
a lot to prove here I mean I don't I
don't I don't see Magnus ever having
three minutes his opponent has 16. what
is he playing final save
retouchik survived out of this shaky
Sicilian and now Magnus on the clock so
we talked about Bishop takes F5 Queen
takes H4 it doesn't really look that
promising are there any other moves here
can I can I throw in a queen E4
something like that just to attack your
Rook to keep my Bishop defended
[Music]
I'm looking at Queen F3 track but maybe
there's other moves maybe I could play
um oh I can't play that
all right Queen F3 checks seems to be
that seems okay to you oh wait a second
it's funny your Rook is almost trapped
on F3
like I'm just visualizing that's true
if we do this
and I go King G2 is your Rook trap
that is that is unbelievable
well I don't know what to do so I've
never strapped that is funny
I wasn't expecting that to happen I just
using legal news with it and they all
hang The Rook yeah you were saying you
know Queen F3 and I was like oh that
looks good but at the night I was like
wait a second The Rook didn't have any
squares along the f file except for the
one that it was on and this one I took
away both he still hasn't moved
um I mean uh you know the time is
getting sort of low there oh he took the
Rook
Bishop I saw his hand moving okay and I
see Queen H4 yeah
Queen E4 looked pretty interesting
actually
what's he gonna do here because he's
down two Pawn the king is gonna try to
probably jump back to G8 at some point
soon
If This Were a pure Blitz game Ben I
would say that white could still very
likely win but the fact that votachik is
17 minutes left and Magnus has one oh no
again
couldn't quite see it
I think it was a rook F1 Type move yes
it was yep
so King G8 looks very necessary
is there another move I don't think so
no chance you don't want to walk in
discover checks
and that's actually sort of the problem
Ben for
Magnus is that voitage moves are kind of
easy
right Queen takes H4 King G8 like these
are three six F7 yeah his last two moves
have been just only moves and the
problem with that is when Magnus the one
a minute and 44 seconds let's figure out
how to press yeah he's just back on the
clock and
he may not even be better
King Jade
I if I'm votachic I'm playing that move
I hear I did play I guess
so I didn't see that he played it is
King still in F7 I think isn't it yeah
it didn't
it's good to be precise you don't want
to just all of a sudden blunder and lose
the game but King G8 seems
very clear there it is that's what he
played
what's the move for
Magnus here Magnus needs to offer a draw
again if Magnus offers a draw here it'll
be declined right
I would decline it yeah
I would accept but then I would lose the
playoffs but at least I drew Magnus
was black
yeah well in this event it's you got to
make it through I'm declining that drug
no I'm just wondering if he would
decline and I think he would
yeah I think that we're toxic
should make Magnus prove it
although what will you turn Rook F4 or
something
yeah he did he's gonna work at four and
that might
Force some kind of queen E1 Rook F1 type
of situation
now if black wants to win there and not
play Queen H4 after Rook F1
um
can I play Queen E5
yep
Queen H3 oh I just hung a piece I would
check yeah and it's probably it's a good
move because it's always a good move
when you do it no way I mean they came
what
whenever you hang a piece it's the best
one I just I'm just check because you're
threatening H7 and quisha V6 track but
I know
yeah and if Queen D1 Rook F1 oh my God
whenever you hang a piece Robert it's
the best
that's why you get the big bucks no it's
absurd I just I'm a beast with check
yeah oh God she literally didn't care no
I didn't Queen D1 Rook F1 and as Ben
said the threat is Queen H7 mate and
Bishop E6 winning the queen oh gosh
oh it was a complete accident so
if this game ends in a Perpetual assume
one way or the other repetition will
Magnus B met he didn't win only be like
man I thought I might lose there for a
second maybe he never thought that
maybe he never thought he was in trouble
all right
yeah it's hard because it happened so
fast that maybe you didn't have time to
process it all I like Rick F4 with this
all these repetitions that's funny
gosh there's the blundering the peace
repetition there's the formal repetition
Queen E1 Queen H4 I can't get over that
that was a complete accident
yeah but I guess before touch doesn't
really have an easy way to play for a
win because you could play Queen H6
Queen d8 looks terrible like you're just
I mean away from the defense Queen H6
doesn't look particularly inspiring but
maybe it's a way to play
so your question before right if I take
a draw if it was offered there's a
difference between like having to find
the moves that make it a drug versus
accepting a
and you know generic offer so I think
that if I'm voitogic I would play Queen
E1 Quinn H4 and make a draw a repetition
but if Magnus you know just offered a
random draw without forcing the issue
then I would be less likely likely to
accept
although the queen E5 line I mean to
blunder Queen H3 but have it work that's
very it's non-human I've just blundered
and it happened to work but I wonder if
there's something besides Queen
look if you're not gonna blunder a piece
I don't want to commentate with you
anymore
but what do I do actually what does
white do here
yeah black looks solid now yeah
so maybe this is like the way forward
the peace blunder would check
unreal I like that you blunder a piece
with check and then you pin your own
Rook
[Laughter]
vg1 I can check with my queen and I'm
winning I assume uh you have to play
Rook D1 I think yeah yeah I think King
G1 loses yeah yeah you have to pin your
own Rook after you blunder a piece
unreal and then you're fine
so we're toxic on the clock Queenie one
check I expect
I just don't really see any other
appealing moves
Queen it I mentioned Queen H6 but that
just
sort of feels wrong I mean blacks uh
can't really do much there's pieces are
all trapped
but I guess if he escapes he'll be up
two pawns but it's very scary to play
that
but I don't know what White's response
is to Queens
H6
yeah I don't see anything crushing maybe
that is maybe that's the way to try to
win it could be a queen G3 Rook H4 type
of maneuver that your your queen is not
exactly the happiest spot on yeah but
Queen C1 track that's true
foreign
gosh can't get over
hanging in also Queen G3 and and Rook H4
doesn't blunder a piece so it can't be
good
it's true yeah
yeah true
uh Queen G3
so something was better but I guess G6
is the way out of this
that's your point now the queen is ah
okay I see what it probably is Queen F2
because I just you know I want to go
Bishop E6 but the queen on F2 is way
better in the attack so G6 is probably
not very good
this is a complicated position still
again all three results are possible
I remember when he was playing tari we
were like yeah atari's position looks
pretty good then he resigned three
mostly
yeah from boy touching I don't think
it's going to be the same phase that we
have Jeffrey on service this is Jeffrey
let's quickly this game was good then it
was bad so maybe it changed again no
it's very bad oh gosh yeah that Eva yeah
Jeffrey I thought was better and now
he's probably just lost
his King's in big trouble yeah
Black's not even up a pawn first his
time position is very bad also right
so Vig Gujarati moving on and I'm just
quickly checking where's his rating so
he will go be operating points if he
converts us into a victory and he'll be
nearing 27 30. he'll be at his highest
ever rating actually
so that's uh pretty exciting for yeah B
Jeffrey 2-0 that's good for your rating
yeah yeah
for the number
actually it's unclear if it'll be the
number two or number three ranked Indian
players Christian are very similar in
reading right but right now he's just
looking forward to making his way to the
next round of the World Cup man Jeffrey
no time and no position
he played King f8
yeah but the two Bishops the attack
Black's pieces are anywhere Queen side
or not near his King yeah Jeffrey's
looking sad
and oh well Jeffrey youngster
unfortunately for Amy's terminal looks
is coming to end but what about velomere
ivich the is he the one who's gonna
who's beating uh draken oh yes he is oh
yes he is what happened the last few
moves we left it off around
here so check on G5 check on F6 rookie
one I like it didn't even take F5 you
can take that later yeah rookie one
morphe style get everybody involved
and Lewis throwing in Queen G5 check
first I wonder why that's important but
he I just want to repeat always repeat
oh and then of rookie four like a boss
oh my gosh he's just going right for
checkmate
um
wow and he just wanted to make sure he
was nearer to the time Patrol you know
okay something yeah if you play H5 I
play Queen G5 Queen H5 and everything
wins The Rook wins the mate wins it's
all winning I can meet you or take the
Rook the king is done yeah you can't
play H5 and you can't allow Rook G4 mate
so
oh my gosh he repeat it again yeah I
mean
he follows all my rules King B1 always
repeat perfect
Miss King is in so much trouble so where
is the mate where's The Knockout how
about how about 96 there might be Queen
A6 checks
yeah they're going to be a bit careful
easy to miss that the queen goes A6 F1
and might just make a draw over there
[Music]
um
uh don't laugh at me King D3
King B3 no no after 96 Queen I said oh
sorry I was like now you can laugh at me
through right away yeah
look at that Rook on e4 defense just
like in Falling Down
C4 that's explosive it's very explosive
but yeah the engine light likes uh White
obviously but I'm wondering and I'm just
confused
yeah this is too hard
feels unnecessary
still good for yeah
you went nine to five mm-hmm
that sounds like he's gonna play King B3
because otherwise it's a draw
oh but the night was on E6 and that
other variation right yeah so here uh C4
I think C4 is necessary because Queen
here King C3 Queen A5 check King D3 you
don't have Rook d8 yeah you don't have
Rook d8 that's important then the king
runs to H6 like Nigel
so you throw in C4 check the king runs
Queen A5 check wait but where is your
king going are you really just taking
this
what
this feels like white probably had
something a little more precise than to
have why couldn't I play Rook Jake C4
instead of King C3 after C4 check uh I
thought Queen B5 King C3 Queen check
here
I can't escape these tracks what I don't
think so
really
I don't know oh so B4 loses my queen
that's a good move
[Laughter]
oh gosh that would be the worst way to
lose a winning position
turn to a loss if King D3 are you gonna
play Rick d a check no I wasn't like
here but actually then right
yeah
um oh
what well I'm stopping Checkmate and
then
you know 93 of Queen G6 check wow I
admit that I foresaw like none of this
wow having to Eva bar helps and you once
you play the moves you sort of have oh
Queen G2
so he has to play King C3 then so that's
gonna happen if he sees this
but just go back and move here there
must be one is rookie three
can I just Checkmate you this way same
exact idea yeah the night stuff's Queen
B5 check we'll also have Rook A3 if you
play Queen Rook a three also good
was this not just a knockout although
Rook A3 Queen C4 track oh
so you're probably right so then check
still King B3
check only move here King C3 check and
still kind of scary but I guess my king
just goes right to D3 and
yeah choosing where to run with your
king is uh the king's safer because the
knight's on D4
but the note on F5 looks more check
maybe that's true but I guess the king
being safer is the only thing that
matters because Rook g3's check media
enough
well this is happening now c4 check
we're going to quickly hop over to the
Magnus game because I'm seeing that
action is happening there as well so
let's uh go to Magnus game and whoa
so they repeat yet or just Queen one the
first time uh Let me refresh actually
always repeat and always refresh
always refresh yeah Queen E5 is play and
the queen H3 the night blunder line
you're the greatest oh it was an
accident there's no way he saw Queen H3
uh uh you know black
it does Magnus saw it he knew it was up
I guess he saw this but
that's amazing you you sack a piece and
then and then pin your own rook and then
it's a draw
oh my gosh yeah um so in future
references to this game I'm just gonna
say that I found the saving tactic yeah
you know no asterisks I'm the one who
suggested that you're these sacrifice
blunders are always okay you did say
that I said oh they're usually good
let's have a look
looks like Magnus checking his cell
phone
just looks like
yeah
wow all right so this looks like yeah
they're gonna draw
yeah is there any way that black can
play on yeah I I wouldn't play on with
black because I I missed Queen H3 if I'm
Black and I'm like all right that's
enough right you can just force the draw
yeah I didn't see Queen H3 so I don't
want to play anymore
by the way yes a Panko and dubov have
drawn their second game they're going to
tie breaks
um cindarov and we saw he was knocked
out by Casper piorun Chris and corbel
have gone to tie breaks the game between
Duda and Idan is still going on here
dude it was better about 20 minutes ago
and Duda remains better of two Pawns in
this end game here not the easiest
position but black is much much better
with the extra material so Jan Christoph
Duda he's definitely going to win that
dark Square Bishop's going to be good
soon oh absolutely and he wants to join
so I also joined his compatriot Casper
pieroning to the next round so at least
two polish players going through
yeah come on why why is photographic
slacking come on beat Magnus with black
the other guys are making them look bad
yeah he's not doing a good enough job
here and we are keeping an eye on the
Magnus game no moves yet that I've seen
and I'm going over to Abdul satara whose
Advantage doesn't look quite yeah he's
uh White's defending I can't believe it
this Pawn on B6 doesn't look so great
the bishop can come to D5 and the C2
Pawn is a weakness
ah this looks really bad for white
it's bad but I I thought it was worse
before that I agree with yeah
yeah Black's a little tied down
but they meet they've reached the time
control so they'll think for a while
so that game will never end because
black even if it's a dead draw black can
never acquiesced to draw it exactly
um Hare Krishna is now up on okay he's
gonna try to press this ending it's
um I mean time to buy and Rook D6 looks
like it wins a piece but not so fast
but back to E3 so it looks like white is
just up upon and we'll try to nurse this
advantage to a full point he needs to
win because he's down one nothing oh it
looks like Pike Marty rosian moves on we
didn't even look at the game but he
makes his way through the next round I
heard he was in trouble before uh at
some point in this game I don't know if
that's accurate but he played this B5
move wow B5
can't take on passant you lose your
queen because that pawn is pinned here
and after the trade well this doesn't
look so bad
I don't know this this whole situation
here
Mike's pretty active over there yeah I
don't know why people were saying the
hike was in trouble because
never in trouble
like not even for a single move his
entire game
and he just made a drop from a superior
position so
I was misinformed thank you so much to
all of you who do your job of lying to
the commentators
appreciate it
Drew
artemiev is still going against karyakin
but
likely results a draw but still plenty
of life left
let's go back to Magnus
oh we did Skip Buck Crow so quickly
gonna go there but he was getting
crushed yeah now he's down in exchange
it's actually less crushed than he was
he's less crushed but he's pretty
crushed yeah yeah Bishop B3 just go for
this Pawn doesn't look too bad
and this Rook is weirdly placed in F4
I'll throw an ambition g3 at some moment
yeah when he played Rook before that was
quite a bad move yeah we'll go back to
that Rook beef now we got his Rook where
he wanted
a big big blunder 95 was excellent yeah
beautiful shot and he gave the Rook on
G6 rather than having problems with
Bishop C5 and the extra material I love
this Pawn structure though this is a
cool Pawn structure for black it is cool
yeah
unfortunately you're down material so
for pancreato it looks like he is going
to tie the score in this match and we
will now really go back to Magnus who is
repeating nope
and it's going to be a draw he'll be
disappointed but he'll also be relieved
that he is not going home as he was in
time trouble and he completely
overlooked Queen F2 so when you missed
something it seems like yeah when you
miss something you're happy to just
survive
Magnus is looking to see when the
repetition exists he's like hmm
on a score sheet
but I don't understand can black not
repeat
I mean uh he has to repeat right I think
so the only other way to not repeat is
Queen takes F1 time for the handshake
you guys can do it
yes they can
maybe they'll do a fist bump though
who's in the background right there
what do you think handshake or fist bump
I think handshake
um yeah that's a handshake as well
I want to argue with you but yeah yeah
there we go
and wow Voit the perfect game
for the entertainment value absolutely
but void toxic survives moves on
tomorrow now I'm not sure Magnus has
realized he had a knockout yet but I
think voytajek is asking him oh they're
pointing
oh they just finished yeah they're
talking about it you can see them
talking about oh they're talking about
that line Ben with uh
so oh look there it is that's that look
of recognition can't believe you missed
it I'm gonna go back just quickly to
that moment where Magnus missed a win
and vortacek saw it uh Rook H7
I think that Magnus was concerned at FG
Queen G6 Rook takes D5 but Watashi was
saying Rook F1 if I'm seeing the body
language and the finger points correctly
which is completely winning for what
um all right though we um actually have
a very special guest we have an
interview ready now that game's over we
are joined by polish Grandmaster Casper
piorun it will be in right now so Casper
huge congratulations on making it
through to the next round
[Music]
I'm not sure he could he could hear you
there a cast freaking years now
we are just saying congratulations on
making it through to the next round
fans uh I really didn't
yeah
yeah I really didn't expert to win today
I mean in general the match because
since I've showed such a magnificent
performance during this tournament
I guess for why do you hate hybrid so
much
in two games
yeah I don't know it's quite surprising
because I remember playing a police
championship last year which is held in
not out the former tour
and I want a tournament part
to investment I had typed in as a result
tournament
you've had enough of your tie breaks and
well you don't know your opponent for
the next round yet but it looks like
um pankaratov is about to even the score
so are you pretty relieved that you get
another rest day and that way you can
start preparing even though you don't
know your opponent yet like do you enjoy
the rest days or would you rather play
day after day
I mean fantastic is quite exhausting
because
it's like it's my first tournament about
uh since
I think February last year
and uh yeah staying adults along made
you feel quite lonely
but again when you when it's I mean it
doesn't matter right winning cures all
ills yeah it seems like your countrymen
are also doing quite well
um Magnus just drew with uh with
matachik and Judas seems to be very
close to winning his game yeah I was
surprised that foreign
but I haven't seen uh he wasn't huge he
was in huge trouble yeah Magnus made it
made a bad move instead of Rook H7 yeah
ah so it's just Mr Bean yeah he was in
trouble but then when Magnus let him out
he got out and then we thought Magnus
was in trouble but he found a brilliant
peace sacrifice first mentioned by
Robert that Drew the game so Magnum
yeah I yeah I saw when he played C5 I
thought after C5 he is just staying over
uh which is not because before I was
little concerned about uh
timer on the clouds right he was like
half the time behind
and yeah now I think a few hours I've
been born up
yeah
yeah so I I hope I mean after such a
hard time I mean with luck in Russian
defense would be
achievement
and and during this event of course it's
a long event and you finish different
times have you been you know with the
other polish players do you guys you
know hang out I know your team is always
very strong at the Olympiad so I assume
the chemistry is good what's your
routine been like in Sochi
yeah I mean
I think this I I don't know if I if I
had more videos or playing face so I I
assume it was playing a place but anyway
uh normally during Fitness I trust
because at the time here it cost me like
a few years of my life
so I mean I have to press the mess and
probably starts
living in different hotels so it's hard
for me to contact them but we've had
some dinner I think before the official
if you die and it was nice to see them
face to face yeah by the way Judah just
won he won his game so he won the match
yeah
Jeffrey just lost so he's out
so some results are coming in because
time travel's over but yeah you're
you're just running through your
opponents have you had any positions
this event where you thought you were
going to lose or has everything been
smooth sailing
oh obviously I've had I had lost
position against Jonathan in first game
uh I was quite shocked to win this game
because he could simply take my
opponency too and then just pay for the
results and probably who would win this
and instead he just allowed my printed
one and
yeah and
and some certain complications occurred
and yeah he couldn't cope with this
and otherwise I think I was playing
quite well uh yesterday I think I've
foreign
I think at one point I could be I
I thought I was lost I mean not lost but
like much worse
uh and yeah it was it last time and if
he won I think she would be so
yeah and Casper a big question for you
if I'm not mistaken you are a puzzle
solving Champion right so yeah can you
tell us can you tell everybody what your
accomplishments are in that discipline
yeah let's start with uh five uh
individual titles in Justice
which puts me I think in seventh place
in all fighters in the all-time all-time
amounts of titles
uh yeah and you can also add I think 10
or 11 states
titles in the team
yes we have a really strong Polish team
uh
yeah I think that's it
well we've been enjoying your games
Casper we will let you go I mean you
deserve your rest and you have a day off
tomorrow so use it wisely but we look
forward to more from you here at the
World Cup
I appreciate it congratulations good
luck next round
friends
and there you heard from Casper pieron a
world-class puzzle solver I mean it's
just really cool to hear his thoughts
after another impressive victory in the
World Cup he keeps moving on showing
that he's good at all stages of the game
not just the tactics but well done by
him and we have a game on screen here
that looks like Dura Bailey and he's
playing against Abdul sitarov and I
wanted to let you know a big update here
andrekin is not losing and drinking is
not losing no he's checking checking
checking and whites didn't get out of
the checks properly oh no um he played
Rick take C4 instead of King C3 and even
though black can't check anymore the
engine just says it's equal so White's
still playing for a win but
oh the engine doesn't say he's better
anymore
so Queen G2 line happened and yeah
wow yeah now it just says black plays
Queen G2 or queen G4 and he's fine
wow and
oh he played Queen G6 he did yeah the
engine doesn't like that oh my gosh
because of Queen D4 yeah we're
threatening Rook G1
wow and what move does move 40 that was
the oh gosh move 40 where everyone makes
mistakes and now for ivich he has a new
30 minutes to think about his move and
queen D4 the Knight is not hanging at
least yeah he probably has to take it
though and try to draw this end game
right you get some position like this
where maybe he will draw I don't know
yeah
I'll take Wyatt but yeah but this this
looks like it should be a hold and the
reason why is I see this position here
Ben and I know some people don't believe
in fortresses but if I can trade off
these two pawns and even if it cost me
my bishop and this Rook just goes from
F5 to H5 I think that's just the draw
I'll tell you something even crazier
than that Robert what's up if you lose
your G Pawn it's still a draw
oh yeah with without the uh yeah if you
have the F Pawn on F7 and The Rook on E6
that's a draw yeah
so that looks like that's a crazy draw
because it doesn't look like it what I'm
wondering is I'm going to find out
um
ah wow go show Queen G2 this is really
funny where instead of Queen G6
yes Queen G2 I was like why doesn't
Queen D4 win why is it the same Rook C8
and then if Rook G1 Rook C2 and you
could just keep yeah oh my God just King
here takes and I was like why doesn't
why doesn't Queen D4 still win the queen
is over word it's defending G1 now Queen
G4 obviously instead of Queen G6 or
queen she stops Queen D4 but yeah yeah
that's funny if he I don't know if he
played Queen D4 if he found it or he's
still thinking I don't know yeah you
know he he played it so oh he did play
Queen D4 okay but we are actually joined
by a special guest band so we are uh
going to have another interview
uh if I'm not mistaken just getting
everything set up and
here it is so we actually do have a very
very special guest in a game we were
incredibly impressed by uh just final
touches production value and here she is
Grand Master Alexander kostenyuk
Alexandra that game was wonderful first
question in addition to congratulations
is where does that rank amongst your
best games
hello well I have no idea I haven't had
the chance to think about it because
first I need to get back home and to
analyze it and then I will make this
conclusion whether it's worse to be
called to my one of my best games or not
because uh I mean yes I sacrificed two
exchanges but
uh I mean it looked very powerful but
I'm not sure whether
my play
before that
was good enough
but one of the reasons the game is so
great not just the sacrificing and the
attack and all kinds of craziness is
that you needed you needed you know to
draw this game I guess and you you know
we we like to see people who need to
draw when they fight to win like Federal
save always does and
that that seems like a better than just
playing solid for a draw and then being
passive and me it seems like the right
attitude
well actually I had no chance to even
think about a drug because my opponent
started pushing her pawns uh uh g4h for
H5 and it was clear very soon enough
after the opening that it's unlikely
going to be a draw uh and um well you
know it felt like a all-in game because
she pushed her pawns and uh I started
the sacrificing and what I liked at the
end that my pieces were so powerful
light pieces that I didn't really need
to sacrifice anything I just improved
the position to the maximum of my pieces
I brought my knight to F4 I I mean
transferred my Bishop to G5 a2j diagonal
and she just did not uh
she could not find any counter play and
yeah sometimes it happens that minor
pieces are just stronger than two Rooks
I didn't see the final position but I do
now that's that's pretty brutal yeah it
was she could have played B3 and then I
would have played Bishop D5 and it just
completely completely hopeless for white
yeah and well Alexandra I have a
question for you how many of these World
Cups have you played it
oh actually I tried to count because uh
I listened to the interview of Pierre
cramlington somebody said that she
played so many well obviously uh and I
started counting myself how many World
Cups I played well they used to be
called world champion championships I
started in 2001. I haven't played in the
first edition of knockout Edition I
think it was in New Delhi in 2000 but my
uh Premiere my debut was in 2001 and it
was very nice tournament for me arrived
from the start I uh went up to the final
at the age of 17 and barely lost on tie
breaks to Richard and after that I
haven't missed a single one so you can
count to yourself but quite quite a few
well part of the reason I asked that
question is what differentiates for you
a successful event because sometimes
even the best players in the field lose
early but you have gone the whole
distance right so you've experienced
that so I do you know why some events go
your way and some don't or you know
what's sort of the reasoning you have
bind it well I think psychologically
it's a little bit easier for me
to
concentrate on a shorter distance and
here you kind of you know you kind of
split these tournaments in uh in matches
so you go match by match game by game
and for example if we compare these
tournament to like Grand Prix
tournaments which are so hard for me
because if they start to go wrong then
it's very hard to break this uh
um in knockout it's kind of I mean it's
more brutal of course if you lose it's
over but at least you don't suffer you
don't suffer anymore it's over you say
okay it's not my tournament you go home
and you get uh back to studying chess
and um well if it lasts then you just
continue going and every every Victory
is like a huge step forward
um and uh problem that's why it's a bit
of a teacher for me to play
no answer yeah brilliant Victory and we
were really impressed
and you you also knocked out Pia right
Grandma yes before that yeah yeah yeah
so I guess I guess the pairings don't
always get easier but I guess gets
tougher and tougher
and it seems like you handled the
pressure as well as anybody it seems
like you don't feel the pressure when
you're playing
from the outside
yes it's sometimes you know it's just a
tip of an iceberg it's much more harder
from inside but that's that's our chest
routine chest life it's fine
used to it
well Alexandra there are you many fans
out here no who knows chess Queen with
all your streaming and commentary and
everything and I'm guessing you're happy
though to not show them more of your
speed chess skills because you get a
break tomorrow so I'm sure the rest day
is coming at a good time right yes yes
breaks uh really appreciated but
actually as long as you're in the
tournament as long as you need to
prepare and think about the next game
it's fine
well Alexandra we really appreciate you
taking the time congratulations once
again you're moving on to the next round
of the Women's World Cup so we look
forward to seeing more of your games and
have a great day off thank you good luck
thank you wow what a game Alexandra
Costa and your cat that final position
that final position was scary yeah that
is a brutal final position with all of
Black's minor pieces white king just out
of sorts getting checkmated so a really
nice game by Alexandra who is of course
uh you know great great player and that
final position I need to refresh just to
believe my eyes on it can't believe it
but she actually faces the winner of the
match between gunina and batya's batias
really excuse me and that game is still
going so I just want to pull that up
quickly because Alexander doesn't know
who her next opponent will be but at
first glance at this position Ben it
looks like she might face her compatriot
and friend Valentino gunina who's up a
pawn it's crazy for black still yeah
great Brooks here the Knight can come to
D5 right now it's Black's turn it's
looking really good for kanina yeah this
looks like that will be her next
opponent
yes
we still don't have a lot of time
I thought they'd move forward in almost
everything it's on move 41 so that was
White's 41st move was Queen F3 here so
it's looking really good for I think
black should have more time then
and white yeah I think once it hits it
like it it restarts oh okay
but let's uh also just go back over here
to see any games that are going on it
looks like we're about to have another
interview which I'm very excited for so
let's pull up the macro game against to
see if any progress well the progress
doesn't look very good for
for Etienne one game one but he's
certainly losing this game just takes B3
now and yeah back rank problems amongst
others so
we're just saying he has problems on the
back row I've heard you make that joke
before Ben I uh it's unfortunate that my
ears had to hear it once more but yes
that is what I'm saying the more
important most unfortunate is that
Maxime had to hear that yeah
I don't know if Maxine's listening to us
yet but you just did let everybody know
of our next special guest it's Maxime I
always like a bad joke then
that's why you watch my games all the
time
how's it going
um it's going good it would be even
better if Etienne manages to save this
but
yeah I don't know yet we need to maybe
yeah some chances
uh yeah not looking very likely
unfortunate for him of course you're
rooting yeah because
in space yeah yeah looks like it's uh
pretty forcing here rook's coming in
yeah it actually looks like Queen E2
before trading Bishops so The Rook can't
come in
we have to talk to you I know you're
interested in uh your friend's game here
but how are you feeling after that
pretty resounding Victory so I guess
part of the question is
the queen sack how intentional was it or
did you kind of get forced into the
queen sacrifice
oh yeah I knew it was an idea so
all right
for me it's not even a queen sacrifice
you get who can bishop and just the last
one it's as obvious as it gets for a
queen sacrifice basically
um now the only question
for me was after I take if he goes to
KCA
do I still go for the coin sacrifice or
do I go through these things I think I
wanted from D6 yeah because look C2 King
AC
2 and book F1
looked good to me but
I'm not sure no well
it is a rugby eight because Rook takes
A2 check ah okay two yeah
so it's one of those moments where you
probably would have thought a lot more
during the game but I actually have a
question you know I guess less specific
more about the general preparation it
seemed like he started using very very
quickly and at a certain moment you
started thinking uh did your preparation
did you feel end before his did or what
was that opening battle like in your
opinion no I think I was trying to you
know remember the subtleties accurately
because I spent lots of times on this
position so I know it's uh you know very
dangerous very double-edged but uh in
general you know those Bishops and fauna
I cannot
refuse that offer
and uh yeah I knew that in some spots
you got books you want OBC and some
others people can see once of course I
was trying not to mess that up but yeah
I think cook C1 grenade five A3 E5 is
kind of an issue so
yeah the King on D1 is very happy yeah
did you did you talk to um your opponent
after the game about what happened or
was he uh dejected
um not today because uh I had good
things down
and I think that's oh yeah that's right
you're all taking tests afterwards
uh well Maxine you had that crazy
tiebreaker against David paravian and
that's probably pretty stressful how did
you regain your composure and settle
your nerves heading into a match against
prognananda and I guess on top of those
questions we've heard from some of your
colleagues like shuk and Magnus saying
it's difficult to play these young
players because their rating belies
their strength they're probably much
better than the rating is at this point
because the lack of tournament so how
did you manage to calm yourself get
ready for a match against a very tough
probably underrated opponent
well uh first I otherwise day which was
useful of course and then I you know I
played
you know this very tough match against
David I knew that he was going to get
off opponent
so you know in general I dominated the
match anyway so even if it came down to
Armageddon I felt like I was in control
I mean for as much as it can be when it
goes down to
and
I mean I knew that not everything had
been perfect from it but
in general My Level was improving and
that I
yeah
that's everything depended on on me for
this one like if I played too much it's
my best friend
there shouldn't be adults that I would
win this match but uh you know if we
woke up I want this uh it's tough so you
know I was definitely not taking it
lightly
for sure
Ben any more questions for Maxime I was
just wondering about your game yesterday
if um you ever thought you were in
trouble or it was it was no problem you
know making making the game a draw with
black because let's
let's say I was slightly uncomfortable
uh but at the same time after I sucked
the exchange I said like I should be
comfortably holding a draw even though
it's slightly worse for me
but nothing that scares me let's say and
then I found this a nice trick with uh
Knight F6 with the idea of 19495 uh for
it but then he found is a nice uh Knight
F3 that's safe
is I mean that's uh first I'm sure
whereas I could have ended up in some
serious trouble with this book and C7
that was trapped and of course after
Rook D2 Knight F6 you should go first
for K2 and then
instead of C7 then I go B5 or C7 A4 and
I'm slightly worse but
I was hoping that would manage to find
my way sir
yeah that makes sense sometimes these
margins are very slim but I guess the uh
that's history now because you're moving
on and you're going to face the winner
of Artemis if I'm not mistaken is that
right that's correct and it's a major
draw which means uh you know they do a
good time tomorrow
so does that mean your rest day is going
to be spent of course preparing but also
watching uh them duke it out in the
quicker time controls oh mostly resting
I would say
you know it's not always that you can
enjoy a good play again it's not tough
to to worry about who your opponent is
uh until you know someone emerges as as
a winner of course uh I mean
we did some preparation already with my
second so I didn't know in general in
some it's some nice so you know
I will be ready uh two days from now
that's all I can say yeah
I I was going to ask you a controversial
question that I know Danny would want to
ask you is do you have a preference on
which opponent you want to play in the
next game but you don't have to answer
that my friend I don't want to put you
on the side no I I know that both of
them are very good so it comes on to you
know
preferences but you know it's gonna be
very subjective
yeah I don't think you know I I think I
can handle
uh any opponent I get but uh you know in
any case it's uh you know there's no
easy opponent and there's only tough
open-ups but so I feel like there are
all possible twins also you know I'm
always confident
great game and thanks for joining us
again and hopefully you'll keep joining
us because you'll keep winning that
would be nice that's a very good plan
cheers we'll join Maxime head to a break
everybody stay tuned for more in a few
from the feed day World Cup in the fide
Women's World Cup
[Music]
foreign
it's not the World Cup but there's
another big event going on that's
bracket style elimination and you may
see some familiar faces including hike
Marty rosian who was still in the World
Cup and Amin tabithubai they are in the
junior speed Chess Championship brought
to you by chess.com this is only one
round in the books you see some top
talent taking part nihal sarin Parham
Max suit Jeffries Uncle unfortunately
was just knocked out but you see these
names here they are superstars of the
present but especially of the future so
it'll be a lot of fun as we continue to
see those matches unfold right now we
are watching the game between Sam
Shanklin with the white pieces and renat
Juma bayev with the black pieces and
right now Ben it doesn't look like
there's enough material material
remaining here for Juma bayev to win
with the black pieces even if his end
game is slightly preferable
yeah Black's obviously for preference
here but um
obviously with accurate play Sam should
draw and he looks pretty confident about
it
man that that interview with Maxime he
seemed um like it was a foregone
conclusion he was going to win this game
he didn't seem uh super excited he's
like yeah I looked at this before into
Bishops yeah I won he's very nonchalant
about it the game because uh he's just
so strong and understands so much that
he he was never worried even when it was
looked like it was crazy and it's one of
those big things about preparation right
where he was saying he was just trying
to make sure he wasn't mixing up his
lines depending move order and his
evaluation position may be different
from prognandez and maybe he's looked at
it more deeply that would make a lot of
sense he is older and more experienced
he also has a team of seconds that help
him and you prepare for the candidates
tournament so for prognanda he may not
have the same kind of team working for
him to help him work through those lines
so this is why my rating is going down
Robert because my team of seconds
they never give me chest analysis they
just bring me Perrier that's all they do
now they do a good job but still
it's the most important thing to quench
your thirst that's right and what well
he's trying to win he's gonna try to get
his King up there A4 A3 push those Pawns
on a big problem for black is that if
these pawns on the king side of trade it
even if white loses a pawn and the King
goes back to B1 you're not winning that
position
the app's still a draw yeah
so I would just be playing King C2 and
bringing my king closer and I don't care
if I lose both of these as long as I win
H5 it's a theoretical draw
yeah you could play King C2 and then uh
yeah King A4
and then probably more than one move
draws here yeah I'm just trying to force
these off the board here and then yeah I
don't know play Rook H3 okay yeah
everything right your favorite cage
three and always play King B1 and yeah
and chill right
just one extra Pawn is not going to do
the trick so for renat Juma bayev he's
been a big story in this event he
knocked off as in a multi-love he beats
Fabiano caruana but his run comes to an
end in the form of Sam Shanklin we heard
Sam yesterday he was uh very blunt about
his thoughts of his own chess and it
seems like he is in Tip-Top shape in
this event and actually let me look up
really quickly he's on the bottom side
of the bracket I think he faces the
winner of svidler and vitiligov let me
see yes that is correct so he's going to
have a very tough match next no matter
which of those Russians everybody's
gonna have a tough match the extra offer
yeah that's true he'll get to the final
16 unless you're you know super duper
good oh that is very true although I
think there probably are some matchups
you'd be a little bit happier about than
others that's true and you you know we
speaking of matchups this will be in a
wild matchup and I'm going to go over to
this game between Hare Krishna and
Tabitha Bai because if top of the body
does not lose this game if he is able to
hold this and maybe even win it he will
face hike Marty Roshan and who would
have expected Marty rosian or tapatabai
two participants in the junior speeches
Championship we just saw that bracket
2600 not 2700 make their way to the top
eight of the World Cup no way no way you
know ESPN let people make brackets for
this tournament there were 28 million
brackets and nobody had that matchup
nobody easy
oh gosh well uh tablet device still has
his work cut out for him in this game as
I see it here he is down a pond there's
a knight against the bishop but this B4
Pawn not the easiest one to keep safe
and sound it is Black's turn here
perhaps a rook A2 check King the G5 is
I don't know if that's actually good or
bad that might get you in trouble if you
suffering your king off the board
but I want to play F5 just start trading
yeah I mean the engine's not super
excited about White's position like we
would be with our extra pawn and pawns
on both sides it thinks black can hold
here but uh I don't know this it seems
it's one of those 50 50 things right you
know like you're betting on whether
white wins or it's a draw
I think I think it's about 50 50 in this
position and it's you know we almost
have a too big of a close-up on top of
the body because I'm trying to read his
body language he just seems like he's
fully he's just thinking yeah
I would be curious to know if he thinks
you know if you could jump inside his
mind for a turn if he thinks that he's
closing in on that half point I'm sure
he feels that pressure because he is
down upon and that weighs on you being
in a material disadvantage
so so yeah then it went through he beat
Jeffrey and Ogden anha is out
so there's one American remaining and a
fiery Christian doesn't win this game
there'll be one player from India
remaining and that's that's what happens
is the event goes on you have a lot of
people from one country
obviously you get less and less and less
and I think somehow Russia gets more
I have more people left than they
started with how did that happen well
unfortunately for fans of the Iranian
players
so two polish players made it through
um one of the two players from Iran have
been eliminated and we'll see if top
Dubai can make his way to the next round
and how many other games are even going
the Shanklin do a bio which we just
looked at we're still playing you know
on draken and ivich are still playing
and oh Dura Bailey and abusotara let's
go over to that game that's that's a
very important matchup because uh
obviously black is much better but he
needs to win he must win yeah
how is he going to do this is King going
to March up to g3 at some point and
maybe we'll see an exchange sacrifice on
the F3 Square that's not the question
always sack The Exchange always that's
that's a good way to win these positions
the second exchange and getting a queen
on the king side
that's that's usually the way to do it
and it's forced you can't stop it no of
course of course because the bishop is
defending G2 and G2 is defending
everything so if your second exchange
usually it all falls apart if black can
can execute that
and the question is how to make that
happen because this F7 Pawn will need
some tending too there's one attacker
one Defender so at some point Bishop B5
could be a problem for black to deal
with and this Pawn on B6 needs that
Rooks defense it's not the cleanest
position that abusotoff could have hoped
for and he just needs to coordinate his
piece as well I mean one other benefit
of bringing the king in is a timely
Bishop C6 and trading those Bishops
could cause white some serious damage
and you play Bishop D5 as you said
okay so pressure on F7
yeah it's hard to stack the exchange if
you can't take the bishop and you
definitely don't want to take it on D5
right exactly hand wet a pass Pawn
so what to do here you could play Rook
F1 or Bishop to E8
all right let me ask you this question
Robert yes
in this situation if you could sit with
the black pieces here or the white
pieces in Hari krishna's game what do
you do
all right so the black piece is here I
agree yeah this team is better than
Harry Christian's position
it definitely well they're both in a
must win
right which is I mean that's the way you
play these games where you have to win
you have to see it where are my best
practical chances and both players have
great practical chances but abusa tariff
is just a pawn and uh he is going to
press this for it's move 54. this game
is going to go 100 plus moves unless he
wins earlier than that
I'm not sure that
received durability is going to be
enjoying the rest of this game but he's
going to put up a fight he is a fighter
he's a super strong player and while he
may regret the start of this game his
bad decision out of the opening he has
chances to hold us
now the question is can vasif easily
draw rook and Bishop versus Rook which
is definitely going to happen
um well that move was really hated by
the engine what Rook D3 yeah Rook D3 I
mean they just went from minus I think
one and a half to minus three on the
spot
so I wonder what the error was here
oh I think I see it like yeah can I play
Rook F2 here yeah and then double up on
the Bubble Up yeah there's and there's
no Rook D2 because rookie three check
and then Ricky too anyway yeah oh gosh
so just that's a commentator's curse
just as I was saying this game is 100
plus moves it makes him a huge mistake
immediately
that's a problem Robert always wanted to
leave work early so he uses the reverse
psychology good job oh gosh yeah Rook F2
is so natural you may lose B6 but B6 is
clearly not the important Pawn C2 is way
more valuable and look at this Checkmate
by the way is if you play Rook takes B6
rookie two Rook B2 after Bishop A4 there
should be four is annoying yeah let's
check he did play Rook F2 man
yeah this is not this is not good for
white yeah Rook G3 was a big mistake I
think vasif is exhausted from defending
for so many moves and he saw the Rook
was tied down to B6 but B6 you can
capture that one the promise C2 is so
important it's funny because as soon as
black played Bishop EA that alleviated
the pressure on C2 so he's like oh I
don't have to defend C2 as much I'll
play Rook D3 right
that's why you always retreat yeah
you make your opponent feel a false
sense of comfort and now it's just
devastating
I don't even think there's a move for
white
so we're shankling well in that
variation you were showing could I play
Rook F3 at the end and try to be some
pawns down because F7 is still attacked
yeah Rook F3
just to keep playing
I could
consider playing F5 I guess but what if
I just take on G2
no it's very bad for white but he's not
getting mated no it's very bad but would
you rather get checkmate or be down like
four pawns and see all these pawns
promote uh unclear
yeah this is this is okay they got the
two against one shankland and uh Drew
mcbive and and Shanklin sacrificed upon
and attacked the a pawn so the king
can't leave A4 so man that's uh
he just played Rook G80 does he want to
play Rook A8 and King A3 because he
can't right the king Louis stay on B2
yeah
yeah there's nothing there's nothing to
do here right there's no winning there's
nothing oh you so that's there
that's the shank on stair
there's there's no winning plan
you can't you can't do anything no I
mean I guess I guess Rook B5 but that's
uh
and then you can even take on B5 right
isn't that a drawn king of buying game
and then you and then you play A3 and
that's it yeah
yep
right yeah the three's just a complete
draw
nope
and just to show everybody either you're
left with an a pawn which is always
drawn with the kings in the corner or if
you trade the king gets yeah I could
draw this too yes I believe you could I
have faith in you that was nice to give
the pawn away and played Rook Shack King
A4 and he just nothing black can do
and I think we're gonna see this
I don't know let's work if I was just my
analysis because um
did he play Rook B5
yeah yep and you just Trick Truck go
play A3
go play this little mate well yeah I was
looking so they played a stalemate
probably yeah I think so now here's the
that's good for Sam here's the bad part
when the game ends feed a vice president
Nigel shortsteps in and declares black
the winner so that's what you got to
watch out for
he may even leave his commentary booth
on site and uh that's right he'll be
like I'm sorry uh stalemate means you
win because I'm the vice president
yeah Nigel's a big advocate of when you
stalemate your opponent that should be a
win
anyway
but he still is this game ends in a draw
so yeah
yeah is out of the tournament Sam
strengthen moves on to the round of 16 a
great achievement for Sam who has
rebounded from South America yeah he had
a dream great achievement for him
beating Fabiano last round yes
and well I just pulled up the another
game that's going to be a draw ignore
the evaluation that says plus two point
something that just means to draw Rook
F5 Rook H5 and as Ben said even without
the G6 pawns the still a known draw so
yeah I I learned that that was a draw in
1984 in Moscow
wow yeah they discovered it right around
World War II they discovered that was a
drawn position
oh it's been known for a long time do
you see Dura Bailey on camera just
shaking his head like what's wrong with
me so he's uh he knows he's going down
in this game and that's unfortunate for
him after winning game one but for Abdul
sitarov and fans of the young Uzbek
Prodigy they'll be excited to see him
move to the tie breaks he played Bishop
F3 Rook D5 that doesn't seem like uh a
great defense uh no a rook D5 checks
again to Tempo but yeah okay I don't see
Checkmate just yet oh my gosh kd3 King
F4 and then yeah King F4 I thought was
pretty good yeah that's mate and oh but
I'd say yeah if you take on C5 Rook E3
and Rook D2 mate
and ivich have just drawn their game
right yeah of course it's over and well
I think if it's the youngster draken is
going to be really happy he drew that
game man he was in a lot of trouble and
image will be really disappointed so
we'll see if he's able to bounce back in
tomorrow's action but after King F4 he
has to resign oh he did play King F4 he
has to resign here yeah let's Checkmate
yeah there's no other move any move is
worse than resigns
Rook takes D4 uh over 65 sorry check
here and Rook D2 is mate yep so yeah
he'll definitely resign here
because the engine move is Rick D4 check
he's not playing that yeah
yeah
wow must win with black and he did it
you were right you take that position
is not happy
yeah the arbiter's like wait you have to
and he just walked away
well it's kind of silly right like
you've just signed score sheets it's
like well we all just watched how many
people are watching right now over one
billion Oh you mean I'm not yeah only
only 12 13 000. right so we all just saw
the result you know uh the signature not
exactly worth all that much man he hits
a draw with why the guy played the
Philadelphia he was all excited and then
he got ground down yeah
one bad decision can cost you an entire
game we're going to go back to move
10 of this game all the way back to move
10. E5 not a losing move objectively the
position isn't that terrible for white
but as you can see it quickly fell apart
for him because he handed his opponent
the bishop pair and the white just got
nothing for it an easy game for black
Kingdom outside the board and a nice
game by abdustarf who was gifted in
opening advantage
yeah E5 was just too uh impetuous yeah
and we do have one more game remaining
here it is the game between Hare Krishna
and Dubai that game will go for a long
time so let's hop on over to the women's
section because in the Women's World Cup
uh they are having a few games remaining
so I'm just gonna
flip to the game between gunina and
batsias really I don't think there are
enough pieces on light squares for black
The Rook should go to D7 next move that
was Black's turn
it's reverse Checkers yeah
Rook D7 and then just all the light
Square yep now
am I wrong because I probably am does
did gunina win yesterday uh draw oh they
drew okay so she actually has to win
this to win the match otherwise they go
into tie breaks yeah right so green the
black's been squeezing forever it's been
no fun for white and it can't have a
nice time disadvantage there that's not
good can black just play C5 because you
can't take on C5 your Bishop's hanging
you want to play C4 that's mean yeah
that's just domination capablanca would
be thrilled to see this position for
black mm-hmm
so this is just looking actually pretty
easy to play for black at this point I
don't even see moves for batius really
who's had a good event and she's
actually rebounded quite nicely uh she
became a Grandmaster she famous to Drew
Magnus Carlson in
um the Isle of manner the cutter Masters
yeah I don't remember which event but
she Drew Magnus and then she lost a lot
of rating points but she's actually
gained quite a number of them back in
gunina on the other hand went from 2500
plus down to the low 2400s but she's
better than her rating and she is one of
the most fighting players
yeah because I've heard of gunina for a
long time yeah she's great oh by the way
by C5
uh ton
so Sarah's tournament has come to an end
from China moves on and she actually won
the Women's World Cup it was known the
Women's World Championship she beat Anna
music in the final uh number of years
back and actually speaking of Honor
let's quickly go over to her game
because she's playing her friend
Elizabeth Pates and Ben this is an extra
Paul in the end game but it's not like
Juma by of Shanklin this is a noteworthy
extra bomb
oh yeah
always bet on black in this position
it looks much more likely Black's going
to win than it's a draw to me
and the question is how how do we make
the progress we need so B takes C5 this
there's two options A3 or pontics uh
C5 it's a Sophie's choice I don't like
either one
and and no Meryl Streep to help you uh
with that one so here taking on C5 this
A2 Pawn is weak
three week pawns yep
black has an extra Pawn Black's King is
further Advanced it's difficult to play
White I don't like it
I like when it's easy to play but are
there chances to hold she did take on C5
the king took back so this is the live
position and other than like Rook F3
Rook E3 what am I supposed to do
a brilliant plan for white do nothing
and hope that black can't win but Rook
F3 I think Rook A4
comes to mind
and if you play Rook F2 and passive
defense just Rook to A3 I think is
a big problem yeah I thought I had to
play Rook at five at that point after
Rook 84.
so you're giving up the A2 Pawn okay
three which one do I definitely Rook A3
and win the C3 Pawn or do I play Rook
takes A2
choices are hard
uh I think if you play Rook A3 and B4
the game is over yes I think uh yeah and
you can't move the king back as I take
what they to a check and defend my age
Pawn
yeah this is this doesn't look good yeah
yeah better King more pawns white spawns
are all weak it has to be winning
so King C2 played mm-hmm
okay that actually looks reasonable
I mean it stops Rook A4 takes A2 so yeah
all right the king will just defend the
A2 Pawn from this side
so what now
King wait King C4 you could get mated
King 64 rookie six Rook takes 400 C6
main yeah that one guaranteed to happen
that would be tragic to walk in a
Checkmate Oh I thought you were going to
take on A6 no I Mouse slipped
oh gosh so actually though black could
start pushing the a pawn that's one idea
I'm not sure where exactly black wants
her pieces
I want to play A5 A4 and then get my
Rook to the seventh rank that's what I
want to do so can I go after your h-bond
giving up no I don't know because rookie
five Rook G3 Rook takes H5 there's check
here on G2 and King goes here
check and Rook C2 is devastating
where's the stalemate there is none
it's close but you have this it's close
yeah C Pawn
yeah that's just funny
yeah this is no fun
and what's the time it's not only that
White's much worse and or lost it's hard
to play White
although Anna doesn't have that much
time with black granted it's as you're
saying easy to play for black you can
just Shuffle around a bit and repeat
position to gain some time on your clock
but not there's no clear solution at
this point
if you played Rook C4 I think
if I saw that right
maybe
I'm not sure where she went I think
rookie E4 yeah okay
is always trade one of your that's
always yeah white should definitely
trade
if they're playing me
oh gosh
I always try to blame you that's nice by
the way Nana's agnesi did even the score
we saw her trap her opponent's Queen
earlier she's like it's Paulina
shuvalova so that's one one going to tie
breaks many tie breaks actually
goryachina won her game with the YP we
loved her position earlier remember that
night on G3 against that visual one C8
no but let me explain rookie four to the
to the peoples now in that variation
before I'm getting mated my rook's not
on G4 so I have rookie two check
so if like Rook F3 King C4 Rook F6 then
I could play Rook E2 check and I don't
get mated yay you just win
he made it was important but winning is
good too yeah
that's a very good point and I have a
king C4 it's actually I think why is it
like a king D2 or something to that
effect but
still going to be a tough defense for
white
I'm listening to quickly show the Grouch
gonna game against stefanova because we
didn't actually catch plenty of it but
Knight G3 we saw this position actually
this is where we left off right and I
really like this Ben instead of taking
back upon C4 just moving The Rook saying
these pawns are completely irrelevant
I'm gonna go crush your King on G8 yeah
Knight H5 Rook G3 yeah tucked the king
away yeah very professional
ouch and here come the Pawns
oh my gosh oh never play that never play
F6 never play F6 but if Pawn takes E6
white probably could get away with
taking on E6 but F6 is just you
obliterate your opponent's defenses here
yeah the king is
unsafe so F6 Queen C1 setting up a
sacrifice in G7 G7 yep
oh boy
also good and queen takes G3 probably
the best move because if that takes
check here
takes Rook G7 and I don't know where's
the I'm looking for a move that doesn't
win but I can't find that yeah it's hard
to find that doesn't win I I sort of
like rookie for Rook H4 but I sort of
like it no it's just maybe the best geez
it's brutal so I have really nice game
by gory option of winning on demand and
okay the rest of this game was easy for
her she's a queen and taking all the
Pawns
getting a new Queen after this so wow
she's great she lost that game to
stefanova which uh you know probably put
her in a nervous situation but she does
Rebound she wins she will be the
favorite in the Thai race but oh yeah
very nice win too Stefano is a great
player but for now we're going to take a
break it's been a little bit and we're
going to leave you with this end game
it's going to be very instructive we
will come back and analyze more from the
fide World Cup and the fide Women's
World Cup you will not want to miss the
final action from this round
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
began on July 16th in the second edition
YouTubers from the anime Community face
stars from the world of fighting games
Sea Dog VA he returned and is seeking
Redemption as the first terminal
Champion gigguk they have their
storyline set we'll see who wins this
tournament you can catch the action in
about seven half hours from now at 5 PM
Pacific time that will be on the
chess.com TV and twitch.tv chess
channels but we are in the midst of this
world cup and Women's World Cup we see
that in this position Ben the eval bar
not as in Black's favor as it was before
so something about this Rook f8 move is
helping to increase White's chances to
draw
well I really like black much more than
the engine does
um but yeah the engine is like nice no
problem white has good drawing chances
I have no idea if I was white here I
would be very upset yeah I might resign
no well now that A4 was played maybe she
can check and play King before no but
the problem so that's a trick is that
after King before this Rook E4 check I
think oh yeah that's right and like
received wait but is that
maybe I can just take on G3 as well is
that
I mean it's all good for black it's just
a question of almost winning or winning
right
I think it's winning and the engine
thinks it's almost winning
it could be a
it's a rook CA check was played
um
and I it's a king B6 that seems like the
automatic definitely could go to B6
because King B4 attacks might be Pawn so
might as well protect it
I'm trying to figure out Ben because
some positions right you play King D6
you take this pawn and you give up some
of your pawns to try to promote one but
of course qv6 is the most logical and
that's what she played
okay so maybe she might just keep
checking and uh
you know bring that King back really far
but Rook takes C3 check is going to
happen so
King C6 uh check yeah then King B7 I
guess or yeah either one
let's go this way I don't know I don't
know
and if Rook C5 I guess you can play King
D6 oh this would this looks very good
where you're only at one Pawn but the
pawns are split this has to be winning
yeah the engine's like no and you say
yeah just fine it might even be table
based might be oh my gosh but I mean
yeah I would hate to have white there
terrible
I mean I like I like pressing advantages
defending these worst positions I I
don't defend them well
and it really also depends on the
mindset of the player because if you
really believe in your chances you will
dig deep and fight every last move and
try to make a draw here but if you feel
like you've already lost the game then
you probably will see that happen
because you need to be objective you
can't just be down on yourself
and and their first game was a draw or
did did Anna lose the first game no no
there's a draw on the first game was it
draw okay
and from the very start of this game
we've liked Anna's position with the
black oh this is yeah
maximizing it scoring a full point
that's another story
gotta love it when you say it's not a
table bass that people say Ceci says
mate in 298. I saw that yeah me too yeah
but she made a mistake and now it's
mating 299. terrible why would she do
that
it's the worst but oh the gunina by the
way that game against batsis really I'm
just part of the corner of my eye and
well that's an extra exchange if I've
seen one for black
and Pawn
and Pawn Yeah and
overwhelming Advantage so let's just go
back a few minutes one more time yeah
more everything we are right around here
and then
yeah we saw C5 that was the last move we
saw
oh
and I hate when that happens oh
that hurts yeah I didn't see that and
also white didn't see it no because Rook
takes E6 you're not taking the Rook
you're taking this rook and yeah
oh that's painful yeah why didn't see
this or white one that's allowed it
and after so she took on G5 but if you
bring the Rook to E3 thinking you're
defending everything
right on D5 exactly and if you play Rook
effort too then we take
yep and then Knight F3 check yeah
ouch
yeah black was working on her Night
Moves
so yeah she she had to sacrifice The
Exchange sort of by force and speaking
of Night Moves man look at this last
move Knight F4 so if you take you're
playing Rook E4 oh yeah
and then you're taking the fifth rank
with chat and with tempo
just force I always like when somebody's
winning and instead of going to auto
mode they play some accurate computer
move that wins the game really quickly
yeah because a lot of people like okay
I'm winning
but she's like what's the most precise
win that you know yeah I think
keep making tactics that my opponent
doesn't see people play autopilot rookie
seven I'm up yeah because you're gonna
win but you know nine of four after
Knight F4 you're really gonna win that's
classy that just gets rid of all the
play
it does indeed
um by the way some weirds are not
amazing it's not weird maybe it's
actually the best but I just in the
corner I saw
Anna and Elizabeth they're going at it
this is a completely winning for good
news she'll move on to face coastinia
but I think if I'm not just well no
that's my random analysis yeah that's
our analysis that's not that definitely
happened there came with the A6 and the
AAA check I wasn't expecting that mm-hmm
so King
I guess King B7 Rick d8 is the idea
okay King B6 repeat maybe she's gaining
time she just wants to repeat right
because black has a lot less time yeah
right
and
where is the king gone we saw King C6
Rook CA check and then made King D7 or
King D6 around the king the D file and
then try to start mopping up some of
these Pawns
all right so this end game yeah the
computer doesn't think it's an easy win
for black so maybe white why do those
good drawing chances I guess
well the pluns go away we need some puns
left
we will oh let's go speaking of Pawns
left and end games and all that fun
stuff let's go to the game between Hari
Krishna and Tava Dubai because that's
not looking very good for the player
from Iran and here is the current
position yeah white gave his Pawn back
and now he has the dominating Knight the
better King the pawns are all weak but
he has to break it somehow
and just to show where that happened the
night ventured in
here
giving up this Pawn on F3 but forcing
the Rooks off the board so black has no
counter play and white just says I'm
going to be able to take this one home
and F6 was not engine approved
yeah
I'm not sure if
is where I can be able to take this
because if you're a king to C5 to try to
win the B5 pawn bishop E2 will get in
grade four
and I actually don't think the
I feel like if this were winning the
eval would be much higher
not that many pieces remaining
maybe I can get away with that but I
have to do it quickly
I have to take on B5 before you take on
G4 but I I can't
so
if you go King E4
which way is the king going is it going
to hear here like that
and you I need to pick a side and I
don't know which side to pick
yeah he's gonna have to as Danny would
say play tickle move around and confuse
him
but there's not a lot of winning
attempts for white I mean play King C5
or you try to do something on the on the
queen side right I think he's gonna stay
on the king's side come on play King D4
and prove me wrong
yeah and trying to figure out where that
King is going and harakrishna himself is
not sure
[Music]
so he just made a move did he prove me
wrong
King E4 he hasn't chosen four seems like
the most flexible yeah right you go to F
or to D5
so now if it's my move it's not I play
King F5 I just win your Pawn right right
sort of like then I'll win then I'll
probably win yeah this would just win a
pawn because King G7 is 98 and thank you
very much
oh B5 was hanging with the bishop to the
wrong diagram I was trying to make a
point that in the
uh
position
at hand here after King E4 yes this Pawn
needs defense but even if black could
pass the turn King F5 and 98 check will
win this Pawn on F6
yeah pintalo looks happy
yeah he does
how does so Bishop E2 seems
very likely okay King F5
King
f8 I guess
uh
uh give me a second this is Michael
you could
take and play I'm thinking I'm thinking
of doing that
but that's very committal like if that's
not winning you've just given away right
yeah the result
of what might be women
seems like with the pawns on B4 and B5
white should be winning
I agree because you you have to defend
the B5 Pawn forever you can never attack
the B4 Pawn White's King is better
Black's pawns are weaker
I mean it feels like white should win
it's not fair if it's a draw
life ain't Fair chess ain't Fair
at what point can the king just dart
back over this way
um
here
check here
something like this right
no but I think what I want to do instead
is play King G5 H6 Knight F6 check
if I can get Force the king to h8 I'm
not sure that I can so one point sorry
yeah I I wanna I wanna use my H Pawn and
my knight to keep your king after taking
the H1 and moving the king
yeah do what you did yeah yeah yeah keep
going
yeah yeah I like instead of that yeah
play King G5
and then put the White Knight on F6 and
the white Pawn on H6
like if you have to play King aha I'm
not sure that you do right then I want
to run my king over to the B Pawn
and then and then if I take your Plum
maybe I save the tempo or two over
right because the king's previous
position the king can't move is your
point yeah
so that I'll play 98 to D6 takes the
pawn and you'll take my Pawn I don't
know I'm not sure if that's winning
though maybe that's just a draw yeah
that's a good draw but yeah the blacks
King is so bad
but it's just too hard to block the
bishop 50 times in a row yeah you have
to go here and then
yeah it's really difficult because
not even clear you can block the bishop
Bishop basically yeah okay this is just
a draw yeah
too fast coming back
so it's hard to foresee though right you
could easily think that just losing for
black and be scared to play it I'm gonna
refresh real quick here
Okay so
Kings on G7
I always like because this happens a lot
in this event when somebody's in a
must-win situation like Hare Krishna and
it's like a True Result game we don't
know if they're gonna win or Draw yeah
we're like I mean it's really important
for both players it's super important
and look how empty the playing Hall is
it's just the two of them and then you
see in the background Anna and Elizabeth
and I is greener did she win already
because she was completely winning
I'm not sure if she ended up no she's
still playing but she's
winning doesn't even come close to
describing how good her position is
all right so you're a betting man you
think Harry Christian's gonna win or
Draw that'll teach you I'm not a betting
man but if you force me to be a betting
man
thank you
I feel like he's gonna win them look at
the clock I'm looking at the position it
just seems as the feel of a position
that should be lost for white the good
oh sorry excuse me for black obviously
the good news for type of Dubai is like
you don't have many choices to make
but this looks very bad
yeah I don't see how to win I just
really really want to have white yeah
it's really a fox position I mean the
check and take on F6 that looks like a
pretty good well we might get in the
same position where you get your H Pawn
against
uh you know why is the extra H Pawn but
you can't win because it takes too much
time to get your king to the other side
so I this might be a hold
I mean he can play Bishop D3 check here
right yeah and King E6 and then if I
attack the uh if I take the Jeep one you
just check and take and defend it right
yeah eventually 98 Knight
takes up six is going to be the uh right
but that but the point is that made from
there you can't win
that's possible
although I mean is shaking his head so
that's yeah but it's 15 more moves once
you take that pawn so that's good
does he really have 30 seconds left
oh you just
well he wasn't sure what to do when he
touched his piece he was thinking about
it yeah you know which Square to go he
goes Bishop E2 head shake
our Christian quickly 98 check
but these are seconds you can't really
afford to waste if you are attempted to
buy it because you don't have much time
you just need to play that move
instantly and then write the move down I
know that sounds unimportant but Ben and
you and I have both played so many games
been in time trouble you need as much
time remaining as you possibly can get
now it's even more unpleasant
how are you Christian is like obviously
this is winning the way he's acting but
maybe that maybe there's a show
maybe yeah I'm not saying he knows for a
fact that's a draw but he might not see
the the win he just is putting on that
error value your laws come up
just uh gonna be a quick finish
yeah I get I guess they got to move 60
based on that right yes
and there's no extra time at move 60.
some events have that third time control
not here
King E5
yeah and the reason he did that was King
E5 Bishop E2 there was nowhere to move
because you're right upon G4 new defense
so 94 was
necessary I guess
to King
this is so unpleasant Ben
it's so incredibly
frustrating
to defend this position for another 50
plus moves
you know I'm trying to find like a
simple winning plan for white but I
don't see anything that's simple
I just want to win easy with no problem
well
we can't all be so lucky
but yeah I don't see anything that that
clearly wins
I just expect that it is a win but as
you pointed out
since the engine can see a billion moves
ahead it should be way up the the
evaluation if it's if it's an easy win
but the fact that it's only saying like
you know plus two or one and a half that
usually that's a draw because I can't
see a way to win I think it is a draw
yeah with with correct play right but
you still think white will win yes
[Laughter]
I know what the engine says but I also
then think about it from the player's
perspective like if our planes fishing
for black I know I have chances to
survive but you don't have much time one
little mistake can just immediately end
the game well I can Shuffle around
forever and honestly the worst part
is if you think about this from Black's
perspective you're like what
configuration of pieces does my opponent
want and you may build it up in your
head thinking that if the king is on E5
rather uh rather than on
if the king is on E5 rather than on F4
like somehow that's winning for white
because the king is one step closer this
way and as you just pointed out earlier
if you get this like Knight F6 H6 thing
where you have a pawn that looks like it
could be lost for black but in fact it's
not we have the benefit of the engine to
tell us that it is not lost
[Music]
yeah I don't see a way for white to win
but
I don't know I'm I'm starting to lean
like it's going to be a draw
um I mean
you're saying it is a draw but you think
that black can't hold it which is
usually what I think right but I'm not
sure how to win though
this is also a very instructive Fortress
that
what's going on here I mean the Queen's
side is great for white but the king
side means that white can't run his King
over because all those pluns are hanging
and actually
hard question thinking right now and
that makes me
kind of feel like he knows or he senses
that it's not winning
and I don't know how much you can really
Blitz your opponent here because you get
the 30 second increment and
sometimes about is a very very good
speeches player
what movies just made
I thought he pretended to move and then
he didn't
just but he changed his mind did a
little bit head fake
yeah
Knight G3
okay Bishop C4
it made black smoke just easy Ben after
all that black is just hanging in there
and
holding everything together
so Knight F5 King H7 see that just looks
bad right belongs King is on H7 White's
pieces are heading over to the queen
side but
there must just not be a way
even Jeff Goldblum doesn't think that
white will find a way so that's that's
when you know things are bad
oh good old buddy Jeff
wow this is yeah I mean black can
constantly harass the G4 Pawn when the
King goes over to C5 or wherever it goes
and uh
I don't see a way to win
that would be I mean how many upsets
because can this guy you know are they
even upsets anymore
I think the players are upset that they
lose yeah
so it's time to buy beat berkish no
that's not really a major upset and then
he beat you Yang Yi one and a half half
that's an upset that is an upset and if
you can beat Hare Krishna that's that's
an upset it's a lot of upsets
all right well that King's on E5 now
yeah he just doesn't want his Jeep on to
be attacked so he's leaving the Knight
on G3 instead of playing Knight F5 track
but you know I could I can play Bishop
so what he wants is the Knight on G3
defends the H Pawn
so he's hoping the guy takes on G4 and
then he takes on B5 right and H pawns
defended
so I'm not saying that's winning but
yeah so let's hope for something King hm
was playing but let's say King D6
King G7
King C5
of the king of six I mean the king's
ghost
yeah I'm not saying how to win this
English is to draw yeah that is
black is always getting counter play
with Bishop E2 Bishop D1 King G5 there's
a lot of counter play there really is we
have to take the B Pawn and stop the
counter play
I don't see how to do that
and actually we have another fascinating
end game and you know I had a music
trick against Elizabeth Pate let's go
over there because that one also looking
like it's trouble for once I didn't Anna
music's King is all the way up on C4
that d-pawn is ready to roam and then
it's quality not quantity even material
but that d-pawn is real fast and even if
White's a pawn up by taking the H Pawn I
mean the king's trapped on A3 I can't
play King A4 you get mated can't move
the a pawn can't move anything and black
has a very simple plan of just queening
the d-pawn
so this is this is very uh unpleasant
for white
wow very unpleasant I don't even see a
move at this point is Black's turn but
D4 seems kind of obvious just push it
past upon Rook takes H5 D3
it's a good plan
so Rook
h8
now this looks
oh you can't even play Rook d8 because
Rook C3 to D3 right
and just Pawn promotes
so you have to throw in this check and
well
keep checking check forever
but they can't come to C1 and you go D1
it's just right out of checks
looks funny
oh then needs a calculator like is this
Pawn going really fast and it doesn't
look fast enough
then why is the eval bar not at like
minus a zillion the truth hurts I should
be winning though I would assume so yeah
also The Rook Pond is always the worst
one to have because you know you can't
promote tonight like you can in other
positions right yeah
so D4 was played
E3 as well
yeah somehow the engine isn't uh so
upset
I'm not sure and I'd be upset if I was
white I'm and I'm upset the engine's not
upset like this is right yeah I agree
with that it's just winning
yeah
it looks winning until it isn't
so
mortgage forged King C3 just walking the
king up a little bit as now
this looks losing right
I think that the engine is just on a
relatively low depth so it's not seeing
all the way through
it looks one
yeah I don't see anything for white all
I see is getting these lost King and
Rook versus King into one end games
those just look lost to me
I'm looking like it so let's uh see how
trying to juggle these two games just
two remaining Unless somehow goody is
still playing no she won her game so
it's like that game can't last forever
can it but we have just the two games
remaining between
Krishna and ameen and we have Elizabeth
Pates and on a music truck here
just looks like a win for black in this
one and if we go back to the other game
just to see what the latest progress is
not all that much
oh Let me refresh I think you gotta
refresh because the everybody's moving
around yeah no this is where it is it
was King D6
yeah I don't think he's gonna lose
either
I don't think it's like hard to play
Black you just chill
chilling sounds nice
sounds like a stress-free time
maybe I was wrong no it's objectively
equal but it just seems like
in a position where it's miserable to
play as black but type of Dubai is just
hanging in there
yeah
no fear in the world
not a one
I mean it can't be a win because the the
engine would say some crazy number it
just says like White's upon out
so it should be a draw with best play
objectively is a draw I just thought
from a practical point of view playing
like just a minute left is what I think
too but I don't see the Practical
problems
I guess the drawing mechanism is that
easy just know that your Bishop's going
to come to E2 if the king ever runs the
C5 the black king can start escaping out
right yeah
id4 yeah he's trying to stop Bishop E2
Bishop C2 Bishop F3 and Tech yeah there
we go
doesn't work but yeah the problem with
that is that doesn't stop the black king
at all
right so the Knight on F5 was stopping
the king but it wasn't stopping Bishop
E2 now we're stopping Bishop E2 but you
know King G7 King G F6 King G5
so it's hard to stop both of them
assuming White's winning plan is to you
know
stuff like King C5
at some point it must be
and it looks like by the way that the
game between Elizabeth Pates and Anna
music is following the exact
events we predicted where the pawn is
all the way down
on D2 the king went to D1 and
yeah
right so it's a king B3
it's King C1 rook d8 and oh gosh there's
also this one now the end now the engine
likes black
yeah you can also just move your Rook
away but yeah yeah that's yeah promoting
yeah because usually you need your king
and your Pawn to go up the board but
it's not going to do the trick
like here's Rook C6 wins yeah you grab
the pawn and I've teamed before I mean
this isn't even hard yeah
very simple yeah let's check this is
nothing yeah
just winning
all right so let's uh
go back to the game between
Christianity by no moves
there's none that I see
oh Knight's over on C6
yeah they're on move 70. yeah and that's
over C6
but where is it going where is it going
if you could try out every different
square and then I'll move 49 play G5 and
then do it again then play H6 every 49
moves you push upon if you could somehow
check the King on H7 then you'd have a
chance but the only place you can check
from is
f8 then the king attacks the Knight as
soon as it gets there so
there's no real way yes my Bishop said
we have a yeah my Bishop's on D3 He
can't play qg6 anyway wow and shout out
to our producers working so hard behind
the scenes to bring up this board view
for everybody so now we can see both
games in action here and on the right
hand side patelahari Krishna is doing
his best to even score against a means
of Dubai and in the matchup between
Elizabeth Pitts and and music well that
was a draw in game one so if Anna could
convert this it is a win for her and the
match
will be uh
hers to claim and she'll move on to the
next round
so
the Knight on E5 when I look at the
engine lines it's just random loose for
white just move the pieces around no
plan
I mean there's not like something
consistent It's just sometimes White's
key is on F4 in the variations that's
not a way to try to win it's just a joke
that's probably just a draw and it's
very hard to blunder with black
I don't see a blunder I don't see a way
you can just blunder and lose
never blunder one of your rules too I
mean there's there's got to be some like
tactical trick but I don't see it
no there's nothing
I wonder at what point
Amin realized that he just had this kind
of draw
and was it at the beginning when he
traded Rooks did he know for certain
that he could hold a fortress like this
he probably doesn't know for a certain
now
he looks like he's suffering
he does
and
it looks like
what's going on in the game in The Rook
end game over there it looks like you
can just take the A2 Pawn King C1 first
though
that's amazing beating sorry Krishna
I can play chess that's amazing for
anybody
hahaha
it's true
and I actually think he's gonna do that
the the the silly thing that I said
like move around a lot doing nothing and
then play G5 and move around a lot he
will but game over on the other board
yeah and
we saw the players shake hands Hannah
Music wins the game and moves on to the
final eight players so her sister was
defeated in pretty epic fashion by
Alexandra kostenyuk but Anna music moves
on to the next round so I guess they're
not going to play in the final then the
music sisters no they're not going to
play in the finals it looked like it was
possible but yeah not anymore anything
is possible Ben
haven't you heard
yeah but what if I what if I win the
World Cup is that possible no I gotta
sneak in a lot of engines under the
radar
and you just have to uh teleport over to
that's right and I can do it yeah but
yeah look Anna will play the winner of
um Zog needs it and Shiva Lova and
well probably Bittersweet defeating your
good friend a person you constantly
stream with and do coaching sessions
with uh not always Pleasant and actually
almost always unpleasant so Bittersweet
victory for Anna music triple she moves
on she will be thrilled because she
wants to make her way to the final
three and Y3 because the top three
finishers in the Women's World Cup make
their place in the women's canvas
tournament so we have just one game
remaining you see it on screen here it
is Krishna taking on Amin Tabitha Bai
Ben nothing's happening
um
yeah this game reminds me of the Blair
Witch Project nothing's happening
nothing's happening nothing's happening
it's over but it's we're not using uh
handheld recorder are we
I don't know maybe we were last time
because they had two boards
usually when I think of young players
you know in the past
great opening play
attacking good at tactics I wasn't
thinking defending worse endings and
drawing anyway against better players
but here we go
I mean he's worse than the ending he's
been worse forever
forever and it's almost like
but did you see that though what he was
like holding the piece over a number of
squares complete uncertain where to go
to yeah
I think as they all draw
so which draw looks the best yeah
hey Ben it's move 74.
over under
move 130
um
it better be under
thank you
oh gosh well you said there's gonna be a
G5 then the king will go over the other
side that's what he's gonna do too he's
gonna you know make it last as long as
possible
well if it's Gonna Last as as forever
I think I need a quick water break my
voice feels a little bit shot so we are
going to head on out for a very quick
break you'll have the board in front of
you and when we return the finale of
this game the final game of the fourth
round second game in this feed a World
Cup
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
do not worry everybody no no Bishop was
lost no Bishop was hanging sometimes
when players drag pieces things happen
and pieces get on squares that they
shouldn't be but either way we're still
in the same situation white is up a pawn
pressing needing a victory being down
one game to none in this match but I
mean time it's a body with the black
pieces is not going to break he is going
to hold this game Ben unless something
really crazy does happen seems like he
has everything under control no pantalo
looks like he's resigned to his Fates he
looks like oh well I guess I'm not gonna
win
yeah it looks actually he's a little
more confident
no
yeah I lost to this guy no because he I
mean
he was he had such an advantage like
forever I mean usually when you're the
better player you put the foot on their
throat that
I mean he defended great yeah and it
just goes sent to the bad position it
goes to show right there are no easy
points this term in every single player
even if you outrank them by a hundred
rating points they're still Mighty tough
and for a mean type of device who
knocked out Yu Yang Yi in a previous
round now he is about to knock out and
tell our Christian that's two 2700 plus
scallops in a row so really well done
from the player from Iran
yeah I don't I don't see how I can even
try to win I mean just he plays G5
another 49 moves but there's there's
nothing going on
so
yeah yeah there was some kind of relay
error where people thought that black
hung his Bishop on E2 and white didn't
take it but that that didn't happen no
it did not
but it it probably is because I mean
slides yeah he's always you know
confusing the audience with his Bishops
yeah
and because the magnet probably just
looks like it's stuck on the E2 square
and F1 but either way
the game is continuing here at some
point Ben you're right G5 has to happen
otherwise after 50 moves the without a
pawn move or a piece capture the game
concludes as a draw so
I don't know when the last Pawn mover
capture was but it feels like forever
ago
well I can tell you that let's see or
can I move 60 Knight takes F6 oh was
only 20 moves ago
no
only 20 only
I've never been so mad
well there's only so many tries that
Hari Krishna can go for here
you play G5 he's not knocked out of the
World Cup as long as this game doesn't
end you're still in the World Cup that's
true
and they're just rinsing and repeating
we've seen these types of positions
before
yeah Harry Christian doesn't look happy
no he does not
yeah he's always he's always sliding the
bishop on the board
so confusing the dgt yeah
it's hard though to
admit that you're not gonna win this
game and then you're eliminated from the
tournament if it's a Swiss tournament
you just draw you're upset and win and
then you move on and play the next game
the next day but this is going home
you're flying back to India
is it G5 time now
but they've only played like 22 moves
Robert you're just hoping
you forget how many moves it's been you
haven't made any progress whatsoever
so you just play G5 it happens
a little flick of the wrist
s
see I I know
there it is
so is there a way for black to go wrong
we know that it should be a draw but is
there something tricky that can happen
in this position that's really the main
question I don't see anything tricky I
was I'm always playing for tricks
because I can't win any other way but I
didn't see any
I don't there's one
yeah the problem is
if you cheat and play King C5 Knight
takes B5 and Black's King is still on
the hrg file that seems like an easy
draw anyway
if I was like yeah I took your B Pawn
you lose your H pawns like you could
just never win
the bishop just keeps stopping the pawn
the king runs over
it's
if you can't win that position with the
King on the G file and you've taken the
B Pawn you're not gonna win that's the
best you can hope for I think and you're
yeah you're not gonna get anything close
to that and we showed the king probably
not yeah
no I mean he knows it they both know
it's a draw that Hari Krishna is like
could you hang your bishop or something
you can relay your mouse slip
there's so much uncertainty and so many
nerves and I mean he puts his Bishop on
both like D3 there but you can tell that
he is not going to feel confident he
needs to draw until the game is over the
score sheets are signed and he moves on
to the next round
just
yeah he looks nervous I mean he's really
nervous
I mean if I was beating if I was going
to beat Harry Christian a match I'd be
really nervous too
yeah and it shows what a hard worker he
is he's not taking a single move off and
that's how you lose games like this is
you get complacent you think I've
already made the draw and then you make
one inaccurate move and you've lost the
game
and with that 30 second increment he's
using about 20 seconds of his 30. on
most moves I like every move he's very
unsure yeah
I'm glad you went King G7 or something
yeah you play King G7 no but Harry
Krishna is not making this go 900 moves
and thinking forever in every move he's
playing very quickly right you know he's
not he's not making us stay here forever
what's forever and divided by two
uh uh let's see I think that I think
that's all you can do that you can't you
can't make it go down anymore
so let's see
so what time is it at the tournament
site uh eight almost 8 30 p.m almost 8
30. all right
Harry Christians like if this game never
ends I'm still in the World Cup
he's not going to his longest game
what's the 200 moves
in this tournament no no didn't he play
David Howell and have a 200 plus oh yeah
that sounds like them yeah
so this won't even break his personal
record
so so back to story time
yeah in the 80s in the 80s and 90s the
two players in the U.S whose games never
ended were karklands and martinovsky
okay and I was in Beale in 1993 with a
billion players and they got paired
and their game was a billion moves and
then in a draw
and they argued in the analysis the
whole game that they were both slightly
better the whole game
I'm better now I'm better and the
strange thing was
martinovsky in an 11-round tournament
with I think 450 players
seven of his games were the longest of
the round
which is impossible but yeah those those
games never ended I mean they just kept
playing forever there's a famous game
before you were born shirazi was playing
martinovsky and it was Queen and Bishop
against Queen and Pawn
and martinovsky was trying to win with
the bishop
and he moved his Queen where the pawn
could take it because he got confused
with what the pawn was going the other
way no way because it was like move 130
or something so
oh okay so H6 was played we're getting
down to you know
uh we're getting down to it it looks
like now the problem is it takes a long
time for the Knight to take the B Pawn
right because we looked at this position
you know as soon as the nights start
taking the B Pawn and we take the H Pawn
we looked at that already and thought it
was an easy draw
we did uh this is a good question if the
pawn was on another file would this be
winning if the power went down to H Pawn
and I believe the answer is
uh yes
uh probably yeah probably maybe
well actually it should be because the
problem with having the H Pawn is your
the white Kink can't get in to help
escort the pawn forward in this Palm
we're on G6 then the king yeah then we
could actually yeah you're right yeah
the king would come in that's right the
dark square is there so
yeah there's no way to make this work
because Bishop F1 there you go
you know it's a tail based draw now
people are saying it's been a table
based drop well he looks really
confident now yeah but it takes so long
to win the B Pawn well now that he heard
your mortonofski story yeah he's like I
can't lose my queen I don't have a queen
no I mean there were two ways to lose
before you belong to your H Pawn or you
lose the B plan get one your H Pawn
anymore right so
yeah the only the only way to win is to
Knight takes B5 and that that don't win
but even if you lose your Bishop it's
stalemate so that's right just take his
Bishop off the board Bishop D3
is funny too
and what is the point of that you know
make to get make it still in the World
Cup
that's true
and I feel for Heart Christian he's an
exceptional player in all jokes aside
and he's worked really really hard if
he's always playing fantastic chess but
in a two-game match your opponent may be
lower rated but that doesn't mean that
they're going to lose and for our
Christian you make this match
10 games sure he's gonna win that most
the time but in these two game matches
anyone can break through and it's going
to be a mean time to buy and he is going
to play hike Marty rosian wow in the
next round
foreign
who's the favorite in that match nobody
they're a toss-up yeah
yeah that's just not winning Knight
takes B5 but that's it that's all you
can do
yeah what was H Pawn and win the B Pawn
yeah that's just that's just like no
chance of winning
and they both know it
yeah
they do
the rest is just going to be
back and forth the white king is going
to go all over the place and finally
he's gonna bring the Knight over and
then we'll get the draw that we
knew about a long time ago
gosh how long has this game been going
on it's 93 and a half hours yeah five
and a half hours yeah man black against
Hare Krishna much worse the whole game
five and a half hours at least holding a
draw to win the match that's
that's why for some people their draws
are more memorable than the wins because
they had to draw and
now when you're worse against a higher
rated player you really feel the
pressure but he really defended well he
did well speaking of the draws you were
just mentioning my longest game was an
eight and a half hour draw mm-hmm
miserable experience but I held it held
a pawn down end game Queen and two
against queen of one at the end against
Alexander reasons maybe eight and a half
hours I don't know how long it was it
was way too long yeah
is an aeroflot where they have a three
time controls and the increment and
a consecutive US championships I had the
longest game of both one was 146 moves
one was 153 moves wow against Josh
friedel and Salvia spurchies both draws
but I was pressing in both I just
couldn't win Rick and Knight versus rook
and rook in three versus rook and two
but I
I made sure the people who were working
at the tournament you know the people in
the product that they couldn't eat
dinner
yeah you're a nice guy yeah wait no
eating oh he's up to five minutes so he
can actually leave his chair for the
first time in like three hours
and and that's the worst feeling Ben is
after a game where you've been defending
for so long so you don't have time to
leave your chair your legs are just
wobbly
and he finally stood up for the first
time in forever
he actually got his night off of F6 to
put his King back on G5
but yeah I don't I don't see what the
winning plan is
maybe if you allow you know Knight f8
check H7 King H6 and then others and win
that's right
actually if you play all those moves
that's a draw right yeah it's still a
draw yeah even if if white plays a lot
of moves in a row you can't win the only
way to win if you're gonna do that is is
get Knight F7 check H7 check h8 Queen
right
man man can you not do that no
this game is just oh that's that's funny
King he's he's moving the king away so
the night traps that doesn't work though
was he on King F6 or something
yeah
you know what would be just absolutely
soul-crushing
is if somehow type of Dubai like made
some mistake after all of this tough
defense yeah it looks like he wants to
play King F6 H7 but that doesn't do
anything
foreign
so what we've learned all end games are
drawn yeah
oh man he's so upset yeah that's not
pleasant to see no
hard questions such a nice guy too
yeah we don't see the agony of defeat in
chess so much because it's very rare to
have a knockout of that
right but The Knockout event when you're
getting knocked out in that game that is
so unpleasant
yeah everyone's used to a bad tournament
a bad stretch of games but not you're
not used to just leaving the tournament
while it's still going on
yeah this is sad
I feel for him
um yeah it must be really just
a tragic experience because Hare Krishna
you know you think about it we just said
the winner of this match plays hike
martyr grocery on and part
Christian's favorite in that match yeah
you'd be the favorite on paper and
that's the round of 16. and then you get
to the you know if you win you hit the
round of eight you s you can just get
right outside the candidates
qualification the top two finishers get
there so our Krishna can match up
against anybody in the world that just
not his tournament not his time and
yeah he's just dejected
yeah I don't even know what to say Ben
just
heartbreak for our Christian has many
many many fans
hey he's acting like he wants to offer a
draw
but you can't right you can't offer a
draw you gotta take that B Pawn and draw
that way yeah make that's how you draw
yeah
make a man prove it so we're we're going
to make a uh a movie and uh
it's gonna be a real tear jerker it's
called heartbreak for Hari Krishna
that sounds good is it a documentary
because all you need to do is play the
footage that you just saw I thought it
would be a love story but all right it
could be a documentary
oh man you don't laugh you cry so we're
just uh we feel for the guy but you also
have to be really happy for I mean time
to buy who is a really strong young
player from Iran he came to this event
probably with not many expectations but
I actually spoke to him a few times in
Sochi he's seen like he just was ready
to play his games he didn't have
anything more than that on his agenda
and he is in the junior speed Chess
Championship he's remaining in the field
he defeated
his first front opponent Anton Smirnoff
in a very close match that was right
before he went through so she's so good
on him he is good in The Knockout format
clearly
yeah
all right so we're probably gonna see
pretty soon White Moving his King to C5
moving the Knight away from H7
and it's going to be king Knight takes
B5 and King takes H6 I guess King takes
HX is first
and then uh that's a drawn position but
that's that's the last thing to try I
don't see anything else to try and there
is some room for error if you leave the
bishop on C4 rather than on E2 yeah you
would prefer that it wasn't so you don't
lose the tempo right exactly right
because when the Knight comes to D6 you
do not want the bishop to be in the
knights path so that could be an
essential tempo
Knight D6 Bishop A6 I don't see what to
do
I don't see anything to do
wow I don't
I'm trying to find a way to win and I
guess you could play
King C5 and then if Bishop goes to and
stays on A6 the Knight B5 then King
Beast yes yes yeah and that's actually a
little scary you know you have to be
careful right so there's still yeah but
obviously when the guy's gonna you know
Bishop's not gonna be on on C4 you're
not gonna lose the tempo no and actually
here's a good example there right could
have played Bishop C all right time to
do it
and then Knight D6 comes with yeah this
was the only way to try to win but they
both know it's not winning yeah yeah to
draw regardless yeah
to hear
finally at long last yep and now he
didn't play that many moves before he
could have played a lot more but it
would have been pointless so
it's like G7 they can't Fork my king and
Bishop yay different colors
let's say Knight D6 was played but the
king just runs
back and running and running
king of fate
oh those king of six up the board
I removed draws what do I do don't take
the Knight that's the one thing that
doesn't draw
at least not yet at some point you could
take the Knight but
um
and don't put your King on D7
as long as his pieces are on different
colors he's good
it's a good way to look at it
okay now Bishop takes C4 draws up that's
correct
you can take yeah he's gonna play it too
he's gonna make extra double triple sure
yeah
there it is it didn't take him long to
make extra double triple sure he had a
lot of time to calculate this in his
head earlier
and there it is that's a draw oh look at
that sigh of relief from I mean Times by
what we couldn't see because the Arbiter
was putting the kingdom
oh gosh and you know nobody else is in
that playing Hall except the Arbiter and
the two players so
you can breathe again if you're a mean
time to buy and if you are pentalahari
Krishna you know it's your time to pack
your bags and head on home so a sad
conclusion it's the World Cup for the
Indian star but for the Iranian Talent
he gets to move on Ben and it was the
under
yeah
in the final position all three King
moves to the D file draw
that's true NDA King D7 and King D6 man
that's harsh spoiled for choice
I'll make a draw the king will go in
front of the bee pawn and that is very
known theoretical draw so a mean tablet
to buy look at him there uh he must be
just absolutely wiped good thing for him
he gets a rest day tomorrow yeah
and he's probably happy with his next
opponent too
check and there there are three I think
only three sub 2700 players in the field
and two of them are playing with each
other the others Casper pieron
oh I guess image is in the tiebreaker
against I'm drakens yeah I was man
andrekin drew that wow he was in trouble
yeah and well Buckroe is probably
unhappy he played a game of chess today
because that one did not go his way no
oh well we're gonna take a quick break
when we return we'll wrap up the day
that was maybe take a peek at some of
the moves that we missed but in the
meantime enjoy this very last break you
don't have to hear from us for a few
minutes and when return we will wrap up
today's action
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to wrap up this round of action from the
fide World Cup and the fide Women's
World Cup but before we do we have a
funny tweet to show you and who knew
that Casper piorun had jokes up his
sleeve you see that Anis the other day
posted a selfie with Grandmaster
sundarov at Casper pure and today goes I
apologize for beating your idol to which
a niche the ever clever super GM that he
is says you beat my idol one round ago
already talking about Jordan van Forest
so it's nice to see some friendly barbs
from these Grandmasters and for Castro
pior and getting it on the fun not just
in the chess board but on social media
as well man after our interview of
Casper I didn't think there'd be you
know trash Trucking or jokes on Twitter
so I guess you learned something new
every day I think you inspired in Ben
that must have been what it was yeah
there were some other tweets from Sam
Shanklin saying he was out played both
games and
um progdananda thanking everybody who
helped him get here so there was a lot
of the players are tweeting after the
round and we're going to see um Magnus
tomorrow in in tide race which we
haven't seen yet
that will be exciting because tomorrow
is the Tie break Day from the round four
of action you see July 24th that is
tomorrow today July 23rd is Judah
polgar's birthday so if you didn't know
that go wish her a happy birthday on
social media or just to yourself I don't
know but she deserved it she is the best
female chess player of all time and an
exceptional Ambassador for the game but
tomorrow will be the tie breaks I
believe that there are eight in the
world cup and four tie breaks in the
Women's World Cup we will verify that
for you so many games happening so many
matchups but Ben any final thoughts
about today's action yeah no I just
before I make my final thoughts you
remember when we were in China Robert
yes you remember that Yasser be Judith
on her birthday
I do remember that yeah that was uh that
was an unusual game I remember they were
laughing a lot before the game they were
too friendly not a nice thing to bring
up on her birthday yeah some people
don't do well on their birthday Joel
Benjamin told me he always loses on his
birthday always and then he played me on
his birthday so I got overconfident I
was waiting for you to make a joke about
how some people's birthday must be every
day
that's right
yeah
she's looking at my rage that was a
really exciting round because it looked
like Magnus was going to win a smooth
game it didn't happen
excuse me and then he played your
brilliant peace sacrifice to hold the
draw very good I thought Andrea Kim was
going to lose for sure
um and just a lot of people who were
down 1-0 tied it up and they're going to
the tie breaks I guess we're gonna have
eight in the open and four in the
women's tomorrow which of the win on
demands would you say was most
surprising to you most surprising
um that drawn demand was the most
surprising
um I mean anybody who wins on demand is
surprising that's the least surprising
is Gorge Kina who beat stefanova because
she had the white pieces and it looks
like she just lost yesterday because of
a one move wonder you know letting her
Knight get pinned yeah
um
I think I think winning with black is is
the most surprising so with the filador
against
um durabiali I think that was the most
surprising winning with black playing
the philador and making it look easy
yeah so it's interesting Ben because
psychologically speaking you lose the
game you no matter how you lose it right
you have to play tomorrow but sometimes
I feel like when you make a one move
error in the opening and you never have
a chance that just drains your
confidence uh sometimes it's like oh you
need to forget about because like oh I
play better the next time but getting
ground down for hours and hours that's
no fun either so it's a weird
psychological situation for some of
these players who come in today thought
that they were going to make it to the
next round and all of a sudden you have
to play a very intense High break day
and abusatar of that guy is always in
the top in title Tuesday and other speed
chess events I would not want to face
him in that format nope it's true I've
I've been watching him as I said before
in the in the world uh Youth and World
Cadet and he's always finishing near the
top and now he's at a higher level and
finishing near the top here as well
and excuse me he and ivich need to
continue representing the junior players
the teenagers in the field now the
Prague Nanda is gone it's sad to see him
leave but we're very thrilled that he
had this performance and you know his
compatriot and tell her krisha that was
really upsetting to see his reaction as
he suffered not a defeat today he lost
yesterday but he could only draw his
game he looks just absolutely
demoralized yeah he didn't look happy at
the end but that's that's what happens
when you get knocked out that's a really
bad feeling yes and in the music
household one sister Maria is eliminated
by Alexander costenio which may have
been the game of the round I know that
they've been doing some brilliancing
prize and all that I'm already giving
her the prize that was a wonderful game
a demolition with multiple extreme
sacrifices and material imbalances and
just a clean game from start to finish
and then of course Anna music won the
longest game in the Women's World Cup
with around beating her good friend
Elizabeth Pates so a Bittersweet moment
but still she will be thrilled to move
on in this one so Ben I just want to
thank you for joining me again for the
call I want to thank our producers and
everybody at chess.com working so hard
behind the scenes and of course I want
to thank all the fans who you know stuck
around for how many hours now for six
hours watching this chess watching our
commentary putting up with some of our
subpar jokes but enjoying the good ones
especially from you Ben so thank you to
everybody who continues to make chess
such a joy for all we will be back
tomorrow for coverage and tie breaks but
until then have a good day and enjoy toy
chess bye everybody
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign